hey everyone welcome to this devops
testing full course devops is a
collaboration between development and
the operation teams which enables
continuous delivery of applications and
services to our end users
there are several tools in devops that
facilitate the smooth functioning of
applications
this video covers three such important
components but before we begin if you
haven't subscribed to our channel
already make sure to hit the subscribe
button and the bell icon to never miss
an update
so let's look at what's in store for us
first
we'll understand jenkins which is an
open source continuous integration tool
it helps automate continuous development
testing and deployment of newly created
codes
followed by this we learn about selenium
which is an open source automation tool
that is used for testing web
applications
after that we learn all about jmeter
which is also an open source java
application used for load testing and
measuring the performance of several
applications
under j meter we'll first understand the
installation
then we'll look at performance testing
moving ahead we'll also look at load
testing
and api testing and finally we'll
understand jmeter script recording
so now that you know what's in store for
you let's jump right in
meet tim
tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner mia's house mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction
mia is now really annoyed and she has a
lot to correct and it seems to her as
though tim didn't really do much
this wall between them leaves a poor
robot to bite the dust well what if we
broke this wall tim and miana work
together in a common space tim develops
each block of functionality of the robot
which is then immediately checked by mia
both are now working simultaneously
instead of waiting on the other to
finish their task as and when a feature
is ready for use they are put together
to build the final product they develop
a common mindset and share ideas to
further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective
tim would be the developer while mia the
operations their union is the core of
the devops approach devops has several
stages and set of tools to automate each
of these stages let's have a look at
these tim first puts down a plan in
terms of software this could mean
deciding on the modules and the
algorithms to use
once he has the plan he now codes the
plan with tools such as git tim has a
repository for storing all the codes
and their different versions this is
called version control
next this code is fetched and made
executable this is the build stage tools
such as gradle and maven will sort this
out now before deployment the product is
tested to catch any bugs the most
popular tool automating testing is
selenium
once the products are tested mia must
deploy it the deployed product is then
continuously configured to the desired
state
ansible puppet and docker are some of
the most common tools used that automate
these stages
now
every product is continuously monitored
in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage
and finally we have the core of the
devops lifecycle the integration stage
tools such as jenkins is responsible for
sending the code for build and test if
the code passes the tests it's further
sent for deployment this is called
continuous integration
giants such as amazon netflix target xc
and walmart have all adopted devops and
see the considerable increase in
delivery and quality
in 2014 an hour of downtime for netflix
would cost
thousand dollars
it became absolutely crucial that
netflix prepared themselves for any sort
of failure and so they took to the
devops approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they developed a
tool called simeon army
this tool created failures and
automatically deployed them in an
environment that did not affect the
users
the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future
hello this is matthew with simply learn
and today we're going to go through and
introduce you to devops we're going to
go through a number of key elements
today the first two will be reviewing
models that you're already probably
using for delivering solutions into your
company and the most popular one is
waterfall followed by agile then we'll
look at devops and how devops differs
from the two models and how it also
borrows and leverages the best of those
models we'll go through each of the
phases that are used in typical devops
delivery and then the tools used within
those phases to really improve the
efficiencies within devops finally we'll
summarize the advantages that devops
brings to you and your teams so let's go
through waterfall so waterfall is a
traditional delivery model that's been
used for many decades for delivering
solutions not just it solutions and
digital solutions but even way before
that it has its history that goes back
to world war ii so waterfall is a model
that is used to capture requirements and
then cascade each key deliverable
through a series of different stage
gates that is used for building out the
solution so let's take you through each
of those stage gates the first that you
may have done is requirements analysis
and this is where you sit down with the
actual client and you understand
specifically what they actually do and
what they're looking for in the software
that you're going to build and then from
that requirements analysis you'll build
out a project planning so you have an
understanding of what the level of work
is needed to be able to be successful in
delivering the solution after that
you've got your plan then you start
doing the development and that means
that the programmers start coding out
their solution they build out their
applications to build out the websites
and this can take weeks or even months
to actually do all the work when you've
done your coding and development then
you send it to another group that does
testing and they'll do full regression
testing of your application against the
systems and databases that integrate
with your application you'll test it
against the actual code you'll do manual
testing you do ui testing and then after
you've delivered the solution you go
into maintenance mode which is just kind
of making sure that the application
keeps working there's any security risks
that you address those security risks
the problem you have though is that
there are some challenges however that
you have with the waterfall model the
cascading deliveries and those complete
and separated stage gates means that
it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and if the project has
been running for six months and they've
gone hey we need to change something
that means that we have to almost
restart the whole project it's very
expensive and it's very time consuming
also if you spend weeks and months away
from your client and you deliver a
solution that they are only just going
to see after you spend a lot of time
working on it they could be pointing out
things that are in the actual final
application that they don't want or are
not implemented correctly or lead to
just general unhappiness the challenge
you then have is if you want to add back
in the client's feedback to restart the
whole waterfall cycle again so the
client will come back to you with a list
of changes and then you go back and you
have to start your programming and you
have to then start your testing process
again and just you're really adding in
lots of additional time into the project
so using waterfall model companies have
soon come to realize that you know the
clients just aren't able to get their
feedback in quickly effectively it's
very expensive to make changes once the
teams have started working and the
requirement in today's digital world is
that solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback this allows us to create what
we call a feedback loop where we're able
to get information to the client and the
client can get back to the development
team much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the clients the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and that typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of sprint two and the client
says hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple sprints but when you go through
the sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
their sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day to with the actual sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment
is running in a stable fashion that is
really difficult to do when you have the
two teams really not working together so
here we have is a breakdown of that
process with the developers submitting
their work to the operations team for
deployment and then the operations team
may submit their work to the production
service but what if there is an error
what if there was a setup configuration
error with the developers test
environment that doesn't match the
production environment there may be a
dependency that isn't there there may be
a link to an api that doesn't exist in
production and so you have these
challenges that the operations team are
constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works so this is where devops
really comes in and let's dig into how
devops which is developers and operators
working together is the key for
successful continuous delivery so devops
is as an evolution of the agile model
the agile model really is great for
gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the ops team and the
dev team and so with devops what we're
doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production-like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that it's based on data so let's
step through the different phases of a
devops team so typically you'll see that
the devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
agile and what i'd like to point out at
time is that again agile and devops are
very closely related that agile and
devops are closely related delivery
models that you can use with devops it's
really just extending that model with
the key phases that we have here so
let's step through each of these key
phases so the first phase is planning
and this is where we actually sit down
with a business team and we go through
and understand what their goals are the
second stage is as you can imagine and
this is where it's all very similar to
agile is that the coders actually start
coding but they typically they'll start
using tools such as git which is a
distributed version control software it
makes it easier for developers to all be
working on the same code base rather
than bits of the code that is rather
than them working on bits of the code
that they are responsible for so the
goal with using tools such as git is
that each developer always has the
current and latest version of the code
you then use tools such as maven and
gradle as a way to consistently build
out your environment and then we also
use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another pointer
here is that the tools that we're
listing here these are all open source
tools these are tools that any team can
start using we want to have tools that
control and manage the deployment of
code into the production environments
and then finally tools such as ansible
and chef will actually operate and
manage those production environments so
that when code comes to them that that
code is compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things i want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using jenkins you may
already be using git but some of the
other tools really help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start scripting out your
entire devops toolset this really helps
when it comes to speeding up your
delivery because the more you can
actually script out of the work that
you're doing the more effective you can
be at running automation against those
scripts and the more effective you can
be at having a consistent experience so
let's step through this devops process
so we go through and we have a
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make a release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the build
environment and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the all the way through to
the production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the the scripting test it
can then be deployed and once it's out
to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to agile
which is two weeks or four weeks
depending on your sprint cadence to
where you are today with devops where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
google google any given day will
actually process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great
videos on youtube that you can find out
on how their dev op teams work netflix
is also a similar environment now what's
interesting with netflix is that netflix
have really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team and netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on smart tvs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the devops team for netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
devops can be when you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that devops has it's the actual time to
create and deliver software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to waterfall complexity and
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment you're improving the
communication between all your teams so
teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted welcome everyone to this
topic on continuous integration delivery
and deployment so this topic by simply
learn is going to explain you that what
exactly is all about the continuous
integration process continuous
deployment and continuous delivery so
let's talk about these concepts one by
one so continuous integration is in kind
of a process which is which comes up in
the first part right so first the
continuous integrations comes into the
picture then the continuous delivery and
the deployment comes into the part
so the main important component or the
main task which we primarily perform in
the continuous integration is all about
the build automations test executions
and merging in various branches so it's
nothing but the integration of the
source code from the each and individual
developers machines to a shared location
which we often call it as an kind of a
version control system so continuous
integration is integrating the source
code into the shared repositories and
then depending on the order triggers
once the changes are checked into the
version control system the automated
build test cases all these executions
can really happen now in the build
process and the test cases automation
it's going to validate that how the
source code is really working
how the compilation is going on how the
test cases are getting executed so all
these things are getting validated
during the execution of these things now
once the continuous integration is
successful we can not assure give a
hundred percent surety that the code
base is working fine because it's just
taking care of the compilation and the
test cases there could be a possibility
that some kind of errors may also come
up into the production environment
because those test cases or those
scenarios are not being covered in the
test cases so test cases are very
important aspect over here because it's
giving us the authority whether we need
to proceed further or we need to halt
there itself so after the continuous
integration the next process which comes
into the picture is the automatic
release to the repository over here
right so it's just a kind of a mechanism
where we will be releasing the source
code to the uh artifacts we are
uploading the artifacts to
particular component so that kind of
automation is available but that is also
happening when we are saying that yes
the test cases execution is successful
and we have to proceed further and at
the end it's nothing but the automated
deployment to the production environment
which we call it as an kind of
continuous deployment over here so these
are the overall process which we are
looking forward so that we will be able
to have an end-to-end automations going
on over here with the help of ci cd
automations
now continuous indications again the
build test merge these are the different
options which we do
so continuous integration is a kind of a
process a kind of a development process
which is being used by most of the
development teams nowadays that
eventually enables the developers to
merge their source code uh whatever the
changes whatever the modifications they
are doing they can a particular uh you
know like merge their source code from
their local systems to the central
repository so that after that with the
help of ci tools we can actually have
the build automations and the test cases
automation there so this is the reason
why we prefer the continuous integration
process because it depends on the basis
of our modifications that how the whole
build and test cases automations can
really happen here
now continuous integration is considered
as a very important process because of
the various reasons let's talk about
those reasons one by one the very first
one is that it avoids the merge
conflicts because if we frequently uh
sync back our source code from our
systems to the shared repository and the
same thing can be done by other
developers also so eventually it
definitely helps the different
developers to collaborate their source
code into a single uh shared repository
and that can really help you to avoid
the merge conflict situations because
you are always going to work on the
latest source code so the scope of merge
conflicts is not going to be there
it also helps us to decrease the need of
the code review because we are just
doing the collaboration frequently so
we don't require any person to be
sitting there and you know have
uh to perform a kind of a heavy duty
code review because uh that is something
which we can easily manage and we can
work with that so code review uh is
something which we can easily decrease
with the help of this continuous
integration process
it also speeds up the development
process yes definitely because
the developers can easily collaborate
with each other so from collaboration
perspective also it's beneficial for us
to do and that can really help us to see
that how easily we can integrate our
source code and that differs or that
basically helps us to go for the overall
mechanism and you know going for and
perfect automation process over here
so it also increases the overall
development process which needs to be
implemented during the ci process
next it also reduce the product backlog
because we are doing our changes
frequently into the repositories so uh
any kind of product backlog which is
there which is pending from long that is
also can be managed easily because it's
keep on you know reduce there so we keep
we keep on implementing our changes we
keep on implementing merging us
particular changes to the share
repository so that reduces the amount of
backlog which is available
now next thing is the continuous
delivery which is an automatic release
to the repositories here so what exactly
is in continuous delivery all about
so continuous delivery is a kind of a
practice that refers to the particular
building testing delivering improvements
to the software code so the important
part of continuous delivery is that the
code is always in the deployable state
so we are saying that we are done with
the delivery we are ready with the
delivery and whichever environment
whichever uh particular server you want
us to deploy we are ready to do that so
that is where we call it as in
continuous delivery so we have our
artifacts ready and whenever it is
desired whenever we feel that we want to
do the deployments we want to proceed
further we will be able to do that with
the help of this process so it's in kind
of an end-to-end process
you do the belts you do the test cases
executions once the test case execution
is done once the testing is done then
you create an artifacts you create a
particular war files jar files er files
whatever the artifacts we have we
prepare that artifacts and then we
deliver it to a specific environment we
say that yes let's go with the delivery
let's make it into a particular state
where we will be able to deploy to
pretty much any environment which we
feel as such over here so that's a real
beauty about the continuous delivery
where we can actually deliver it to
whatever environment we feel we want to
deliver
now continuous delivery is uh also
something which is a very important
concept for most of the organizations
so
each and every organizations are
actually looking forward to invest in
this one for a variety of reasons
because uh it's something where we can
invest some of our particular efforts
budget money a lot of things are there
but the kind of benefits which we get in
the return that's what we are going to
talk about over here as such so let's go
with that so it provides the higher
quality of products yes the efforts are
there yes the investment is also there
but in the return the prime the very
important concept or very important
thing which we get is the high quality
of products here so the kind of quality
which we are getting with this one is
quite high and that's the biggest
benefit which we get when we talk about
any kind of continuous integration
continuous delivery or continuous
deployment here so the quality is always
top notch when we work of these
particular processes
it also helps us to go for a quicker and
less risky releases so that's another
benefit which we get this process
customers are also satisfied because
they feel that yes we are going with
this particular automated process
um within you know few days we are
getting the deliveries uh we don't have
to wait for months for getting our
delivery so that's the biggest benefit
which a customer usually gets when he
talks about the continuous delivery
and it's more efficiency is there and
the cost of fitness of the team also so
from the cost and from the uh particular
uh efficiency all those parameters are
fully fulfilled when we talk about the
continuous delivery so this process
delivers a lot of benefits
which can eventually help us to go for
an perfect high quality product which we
can develop as such over here
now the next thing is the continuous
deployment which is an automatic
deployment to the production environment
so let's see that what exactly is
incontinence deployment all about here
so continuous deployment uh refers to
the final stage in the pipeline so which
means that we are not only preparing our
artifacts we are not only doing the
particular compilations or test cases
executions we are actually going one
step ahead and this one step ahead is
nothing but the deployment to the
production environment so this is what
we are typically doing when we talk
about the continuous deployment over
here that we are going to one step ahead
and that's where we are going for the
deployment of our particular artifact so
we are deploying to the production
environment so that our changes whatever
the changes we are trying to do we are
trying to make that should be deployed
to the production environment
right now
so continuous deployment again is can be
deployed to uh hire whatever the
organizations want to feel or want to
deploy they can actually go with that
and there are a lot of benefits actually
which we get when we talk about the
continuous deployment so let's see about
all these particular deployments one by
one so first of all the faster
development of the products is there so
we are looking forward that when we are
going for the automations when we are
going for this deployment so it we get a
kind of a faster uh you know development
process which is there so the products
are getting developed very quickly very
fast that's the biggest benefit which
you are getting when we talk about this
continuous deployment here
and it's less risky releases also there
and it's easy to fix problems whatever
the automations we are feeling we are
trying to perform that can definitely
help us to go that how we can automate
and how we can go for these uh
particular releases over here so these
are releases are very less risky because
we are doing all the things automated
there is not much of a scope which is
there for the manual errors so usually
manual errors is something which is the
biggest uh problem or which is the
biggest risk when we go for any release
but that is something which is totally
removed with this automation here
now it also helps in continuous
improvement in the quality so
continuously improve quality is also
getting improved as such here
now let's talk about that why exactly
as and we talk about at the industry
level in the market level also that the
ci cd is one of the best practices now
what is the reason behind that why those
are known as the best development and
devops practices as such
now continuous integration and
continuous delivery are the best
practices as they create an effective
process the kind of integration and
delivering the source code these are the
prime things which we need to take care
when we talk about the development uh
teams over here so they want an
automated process first of all and they
also want to streamline process which
can you know take up the things uh which
should not fail it should be a fail-safe
process mechanism
through which they can release various
kind of changes to the production
environment because ultimately they are
looking forward for the deployment of
their changes to the production
environment so how they are going to do
that that is where the ci cd or the
continuous integration and continuous
delivery helps on that part and that's
the reason why they can help the teams
the development teams to go for an
effective
process implementations when we go for
these implementations of these two
practices
small call changes can be easily made in
the software course so you don't require
much of the efforts if you are going for
even small changes in the source code
that can also be effectively deployed to
a production environment in a simple
straightforward and easy mechanism the
changes can go from the developer
machines to the production environment
that's the biggest benefit which we get
due to which we feel that yes these two
processes should be implemented into a
devops platform
right so ca and cd provides continuous
feedback from the customers and also
from their development teams devops
teams so the increase of transparency is
also something which is important which
is implemented with these processes here
so the process enables faster release of
the product so we don't have to wait for
months to release the source code there
within a couple of hours within couple
of days we can actually release it to
the production environment provided we
do all these steps like build
compilations testing development
validation all these things will be done
in that duration of time so the failures
can be easily detected faster and we can
easily find out that what is the problem
with the code base what is the problem
the changes and we can even do the hot
fixes now hot fixes these kind of
ad hoc changes are also can be easily
deployed to a production environment
within just a couple of hours there
so that was a complete summary on what
exactly is the acd and the prime
important concept which we have got a
proper understanding is that why these
two processes are really important for
our development process and the only
benefit which we are getting the prime
benefit which we are getting from these
processes implementation is that we get
an effective build process effective
test cases automation process and
automated deployment process and these
processes when we combine that is
something which we can use to deliver
our source code our features to the
production environment and eventually to
the end user so that's how the ci cd
automations really works into a devops
environment hey guys welcome to jenkins
pipeline tutorial by simply learn my
name is chidanan and let me quickly walk
you through the topics that i plan to
cover as a part of this tutorial at a
very high level i'll be introducing you
jenkins and then get into more details
of the continuous integration process as
most of you are aware most of the
software's in recent times are developed
using some or the other kind of agile
practices and continuous integration is
an important or key factor in all such
agile software development lifecycle
next i'll be looking at the software
delivery pipeline from a perspective of
if someone were to visualize all the
steps that is required from the time
someone gives out a requirement a
software requirement it gets translated
into some sort of a code and gets tested
may be moved into one of the testing
platforms and then migrated across or
moved across or propagated across
various environments and then finally
put out in production if one were to put
a value stream mapping for all these
steps that is involved each of these
steps could translate into a simple job
within jenkins i will first look at what
existed in jenkins or rather pre-jenkins
2.0 where we had a way of upstream
downstream mapping of jobs there were
some plugins that allowed us to
visualize all the jobs at one shot
starting from the first job that
triggered and then i will get into the
most powerful groovy scripting that are
there in jenkins 2.0 or post jenkins 2.0
these groovy scripting uses much more
powerful ways of defining our pipelines
there are two different ways in which
you can write your scripts one is the
scripted one the other one is
declarative one there's very subtle
change or difference between each one of
them but these gives you a much more
flexible and much more powerful feature
to write complicated pipelines for your
software delivery having said that most
of these topics that i'm going to
discuss will be followed up with a demo
and the source code for most of these
would be honor github repository all
right now as a prerequisite probably it
may be a good idea in case if you
haven't already watched please watch our
previous video wherein i mentioned how
to install jenkins and how to put up
some sample jobs on our jenkins server
so what exactly is jenkins jenkins is
nothing but a powerful automation server
that is written in java and it is a web
application which can also be run on any
web server but what makes jenkins an
ideal choice for a continuous
integration server jenkins has got
wonderful plugins that allows it to
connect to all kinds of tools software
development deployment coding build
source code kind of tools that is what
makes jenkins very very powerful from a
continuous integration perspective
jenkins can connect to various source
code servers and it has also got plugins
that allows it to build deploy test all
kinds of software artifacts so this is
what makes jenkins an ideal choice for a
continuous integration server but mind
you for me jenkins is nothing but a very
very powerful automated server at the
heart of it there's a lot of automation
in it but the powerfulness of jenkins is
more so because of the tools that it
integrates with and the kind of plugins
that it has got what is continuous
integration from a software development
lifecycle assuming that the software
delivery is happening in very small
sprints maybe three to four weeks is
your delivery life cycle and there are a
bunch of developers who are located in
different locations who are working on
the same code base on the same branch if
the code check-ins do not happen quickly
as in every day if at all developers
stagger their code check-ins into the
repository finding problems at a later
stage would be very costly for the whole
project early detection of any such
issues would be you know quick to
resolve and would not affect your
delivery schedules so as a part of
continuous integration what is requested
or what is demanded is that every
developer checks in code pretty much you
know every day as long as it doesn't
break the code he checks in code pretty
much regularly and at the end of a day
you have an automated server which kind
of wakes up pulls the latest code so
this code has got the integrations of
all the code bases that has been checked
in by various developers so it pulls out
the code it builds on a completely
different server there is a ci server
which pulls this code it builds it it's
got all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it and
assuming that you got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test suites automated if at
all there is a way by which in a couple
of hours time when the team is out or
rather team sleeping you have
verification that happens at a very
crucial level and then any breakages
even before the team arrives for the
next day if these are notified to the
whole team members saying an email going
out saying that something got broken
most of the code would be pretty okay
from the perspective of compilation
errors or build errors it is the
functionality and the regression that
the team is worried about so if these
can be automated test it very very
quickly and very very fast and then any
breakages are detected early during the
day right by the time the next day
people come in they know what is broken
and possibly they know what code
check-in broke that particular thing and
they can have a quick stand-up meeting
and then they discuss what broke the
code and able to fix it so this way any
problem that could possibly arise at a
later point in time if at all they kind
of move to the initial phase of the
project any detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and jenkins plays an important role in
being the continuous integration server
because it's got connections to anything
and everything all kinds of tools i mean
and then it has also got various ways on
which triggering the job which is a part
of its automation strategy now that we
know what is continuous integration and
where does jenkins come into picture
let's look at the rest of the tasks of
our software development lifecycle so if
at all i were to visualize the kind of
steps that is involved in delivering my
software possibly the continuous
integration phase would be somewhere
here where multiple developers are
developing on that and then we have a
little bit of a stable code that is
there that can be kind of moved across
because i want to go ahead with the
particular build that i have and then i
want to migrate that i want to propagate
that across various environments so if
you consider the standard software
delivery approach in the first cycle you
just do some minimal testing and then
you kind of move that to one of the
environments and from there you kick off
more and more tests they could be
integration test they could be
acceptance tests they could be
functionality check they could be a
stress test there could be a load test
it could be a system integration test
all kinds of tests that you can think
about and all the way may be propagating
the build across various environments if
all this can be considered as various
steps the workflow is such that as and
when the build moves across various
phases if there's any failure of course
the build propagation kind of stops
everyone gets notified but if at all
everything goes well so your workflow is
progressing well and at the end of the
workflow you eventually have a code
which is pretty much good to release now
mind you i make an assumption here that
most of your test cases are automated
and you have a good percentage of
coverage of your test cases but if that
is not the scenario then possibly there
are some automated tests or checks that
may be required in between but if the
workflow can kind of accommodate all
that as well you know you can visualize
this as the steps that is required for
your software development or software
delivery life cycle now in jenkins the
way this kind of translates is that each
of these tasks can be put out as a job
so now let me quickly let you know or
let me quickly demo what existed in
preaching 2.0 where i could put up a
couple of jobs and i can connect them
using the upstream downstream linking
mechanism so if there's job one if at
all it is a build and even test cases if
at all that passes successfully job 2
gets triggered if the job 2 is more
about running some more automated tests
or possibly deploying it to environment
and then kicking off some more test
cases that would be job too but if the
deployment fails or if some of the other
test cases fail it would not propagate
to the third job all right so let me
quickly bring up my jenkins instance and
put up some sample jobs and tell you how
to connect that or rather how could one
connect that using jenkins 2.0 or pre
jenkins 2.0 release i have now brought
up my jenkins instance and in case some
of you don't know how to install jenkins
or you don't know how to bring up your
jenkins instance i would strongly
recommend that you watch our previous
videos on simply learn youtube channel
where i've detailed out the steps that
is required for you to install jenkins
and bring it up so all right so i've
brought up my jenkins instance let me
put up few of those jobs now mind you
i'm going to cover the pre jenkins 2.0
feature here all right so let me put up
my first job all right i hope i don't
have that job i say it's a freestyle
project
i don't want to change anything i'm
gonna put up a very very simple job here
it's in batch command let's say echo
first job
triggered
at right that's my first job
now let me put up my second job
freestyle project
all right that's my second job
all right that's my third job i've got a
very very simple
echo statement in this
so it just prints out the system date
and the time in it
all right
so i could run these jobs individually
if i want so let me just check running
my third job so this is what i get
the console output third job triggered
at date and time oops
let me fix that
right that should fix it
let me check my second job
all right that's my second job
all right so i've got three jobs now if
i were to link them together or if at
all i want a scenario where after the
first job is successfully run i would
like to trigger my second job so i would
do a small configuration change in here
i would say after this first job is run
i want to trigger the second job so i
have something called as a post build
action so i can say that trigger some
other jobs from here so if you see this
publish record deploy
all right trigger
trigger trigger trigger let me check the
other one build other projects this is
what i would want to do so after the
first job is done i want to trigger my
second job all right i would say save
this now let me go back to my second job
and then trigger the third job after the
second job is done
all right i will add this post build
build other projects third job again
i'm not really sure if you guys notice
this there is various configurations as
to when exactly do you want to trigger
the other job and the default one is
trigger only if the build is stable so
typically this is the configuration that
would need we definitely don't want the
third job to be triggered in case the
second job fails all right so this is
the combination that i want or this is
the choice that i want and i save this
now i have three of my jobs if you see
this the second job the upstream job is
the first job so let me check this kind
of a pipeline what i've set here is a
very very simple pipeline so after my
first job gets triggered if i build this
guy right the second job gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
i click on the second job all right so
the first job was to get the second job
and after the second job it is
triggering the third job so this is how
first job second job and third job were
kind of linked but it's pretty hard to
visualize this as to you know if i need
to see one holistic picture where after
the first job after the second job after
the third job what was the flow it's not
possible for me to visualize that that's
where in i install a plugin so let me go
to manage plugins right here i think i
already have it installed for those of
you who don't have it installed you can
go to the available button available tab
and click on that the plugin is called
delivery pipeline plugin i already have
it installed in case you don't have it
installed you just go to the available
you click on this and say install
without restart this is the plugin that
i want you to install all right so now
we have that plugin installed so what i
want to do is after the plugin is
installed you see something like this so
this is where i would create a new
visualization for the pipeline that i've
created so i would say my first pipeline
or i give a name for my visualization i
would say yes this upstream downstream
dependencies this is exactly what i want
and there are a bunch of settings here
i'll not look at any of that now what i
want is i just want to tell this view
that you know the i can give a name for
this i would give it as simply learn
pipeline
and what's important is that i specify
what is the first job that should be
picked up as a part of this pipeline and
the final job is optional because it
knows that if the first job is
triggering those other jobs it knows
where to end this whole life cycle so i
define a pipeline and they give a name
for my component and i initialize that
as my i mean i give it the first job so
i say okay and there you go this is much
better this gives you a beautiful
visualization of as to what happened
after the first job second job was run
second job if you click on any of these
that will in fact take me to that shop
all right there is also one other option
which is pretty good option in my
opinion which is about edit view yes
this is where it is enable start of a
new pipeline build let me apply and let
me click ok on this what it gives me is
a way in which i can trigger my whole
pipeline from here so if i click on this
there you see the first job getting
triggered the second job is still
running the green means it's all run
properly and nicely second one is
triggered now the third one it's still
running all right so this is the
pipeline that existed prior to jenkins
2.0 this is pretty decent enough and if
you see there's a one-to-one mapping but
if at all you remember we could go and
add multiple dependencies for the
projects that i set in just to give an
example let's say if i go to my first
job i can do a configuration here and
nothing stops me from triggering
multiple jobs after this by giving me a
comma i can trigger multiple jobs here
in case if i have to run few things
parallely this also gives me that option
to do that but having said that this was
the most primitive way in which the jobs
were kind of visualized and run prior to
jenkins 2.0 now this feature became such
an important feature the users wanted
more and more complicated because the
pipelines were a lot complicated it was
not just one job after the other there
were multiple jobs that has to be run
and there is also an introduction of the
jenkins agents where multiple tasks
could be parallel run on different
agents so they wanted to club all of
that and the pipeline could have all the
such complicated stuff that's where in
post jenkins 2.0 or in jenkins 2.0
jenkins
released a version which has got the
feature of pipeline which can be written
in groovy scripts now groovy is
wonderful scripting language it's very
very powerful anybody can visualize your
pipeline or write your pipeline using
programming language and the point of
everything is code where this whole
groovy script gets into your source code
repository so instead of putting jobs
here and in case my jenkins kind of
fails you know there's a crash on my
jenkins i don't get back these jobs how
do i bring back all these jobs back so
everything has code that's the devops
principle so the pipelines will be
written as scripts that is what i'm
going to do in my next exercise in my
previous example i showed you the crude
way in my opinion of putting up a
jenkins pipeline but this is what
existed prior to jenkins 2.0 and now i
have post jenkins 2.0 in terms of my
version jenkins version is 2.107. so
this supports something called as a
scripted pipeline wherein you can write
your pipeline in terms of groovy scripts
no need to put up any jobs here and
remember how exactly you put up these
individual jobs you can write a pipeline
script in terms of groovy language let
me quickly show you a very very simple
and elementary pipeline that i have this
is what a groovy script would look like
pipeline any agent can run this stages
there are individual stages that is
defined as a subset of these stages so
the first stage is the compile stage and
stage has got some steps in it you can
have multiple steps in it and once only
after all these steps successfully
complete that's when the stage gets
through perfectly with the pass so
there's a compile a stage there's a j
unit stage there's a quality gate stage
there's a deploy stage and i'm really
not doing anything much within this
other than echoing you know some text
within each of these stages and what's
interesting is at the end there's
something called as a post which is
similar to or you can kind of equate
that to what would be there in a try
catch kind of a block supposed always
meaning this would run all the time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures so typically you would have
your email that is going out here saying
that the build is successful and stuff
like that failure if something went bad
if any of the step resulted in a failure
this particular block will get executed
unstable whenever any build is marked
unstable if at all only few things that
failed within your test run and you
would want to mark the build as unstable
are changed this is an interesting
option so this compares the present run
with the previous run and if there's any
change meaning if the previous run was a
failure and the present run is a success
or vice versa this would get triggered
so this is what a simple pipeline script
would look like so let me copy this
pipeline and let me put up a simple job
for running this pipeline so let me open
up my jenkins say a new i would say
scripted pipeline yeah this is what i
want i don't want to choose a freestyle
project this is going to be a pipeline
project so i would say pipeline and say
okay all right this has got far less
options than the other jobs that we put
up so general i don't want anything here
i don't want any build trigger right so
this is where i kind of i can paste in
whatever i had copied there's also
something called as a pipeline syntax or
a syntax generator this is like a lookup
where you can choose what you want to do
and choose the option that is specific
to those steps and you will get a
pipeline generator or a script generator
for you jenkins knows that you're not
very good at understanding these
pipelines so this gives you the sandbox
kind of an environment where you can
check out whatever you want to do as a
part of your pipeline and then get the
equivalent groovy script from here let
me look at this in a bit later so for
now i have my pipeline syntax already
copied so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to paste what i copied all right
so this looks good okay i'm not
connecting to any github repository of
any of that i'm just running a very very
simple pipeline which has got some steps
in it and it just compiles or rather it
just puts out some messages saying that
these stage completed successfully and
stuff like that so let me save this and
let me try to run this scripted pipeline
all right if you see this you'll see
each of those steps going through and if
at all i look at the console output
compile successfully unit passed all the
stages passed there was a pass the
failures doesn't show up you will see
the messages from our post or the try
catch block that i was mentioning
earlier so this is how one would put up
a pipeline and you also get to see the
visualized view of your pipeline that
says which stage run after which phase
how much time did it take and you can
click on any of these and get into
looking at the logs from that particular
pipeline run that was pretty easy wasn't
it now let me give you another scenario
for a pipeline wherein the source code
of my pipeline would be in a github
repository and i will write scripts to
grab this particular code and run some
part of the code which is there as a
part of the repository so let me look at
the repository that i have i have a
repository out here on the simply learn
github account which is called the
pipeline script and if you see in there
there are a bunch of batch files that
are there so the first batch file would
be a build.batch so there's nothing in
it except that it is just trying to
build a particular project you can
visualize this as individual batch files
which actually contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your particular
project so i have a couple of batch
files that is here and this is on the
github repository so i would need to
write jenkins job which will log into my
github account and then check out this
particular repository from my account
and then run these batch files as a part
of those individual steps within within
the scripted pipeline so let me check as
to how i could do that
let me put up a new project for this let
me call this scripted pipeline
scripted
pipeline from github all right so let
this be a pipeline project that's good
enough for me let me see my scripts all
right now this is where i need to put in
the scripts for pulling out the code
repository from my github server and
running those batch files that are there
as a part of the repository so what i
want to do is i already have the
skeleton of my pipeline that is written
which is very similar to whatever was
the pipeline syntax that i showed you in
the previous step so i just copy this
out here and then paste it here so what
i have here is i've written on the high
level skeleton without really putting in
the actual steps required for checking
out rather or rather running those build
scripts so i've got four steps one is
the git checkout step the builds tab
unit test quality gate and possibly the
deploy all right so i need to put in the
actual scripts that is required for
first checking out the repository from
my github server so this is where i will
make use of this pipeline syntax so as i
mentioned earlier you have a bunch of
help that is available for you to figure
out the actual scripts that is required
for you to write within your pipeline so
what i wanted to do is check out
something from git so it's get related
so search on git and you'll find this
option so i got to specify my git
repository url and my credentials so let
me look at the repository url this would
be my repository url so let me copy this
i'm going to copy the https url of my
repository and branch is good and one
thing that you got to notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on github so even though if
you don't specify any credentials that
would work for me still but in case you
have a repository which needs strictly a
username and password to be specified
you can kind of add it out here using
add jenkins and you can give your
username and password out here but for
now i don't need any of these things so
i'm going to just say git checkout or
rather the url of my repository and what
we want is the master branch for now i
have only one branch on my github server
so this is good for me so this is what
exactly i want to do as a part of the
script so if i click this this is the
script that i need to put in my build
script so i come over here and this is
what will check out the code from my
repository all right so now once i get
my code onto my repository from my
repository rather it will grab those
code all these batch files and get it
onto my jenkins workspace now i'll have
to run these batch files as a part of
each of my step so let me look at what
would be the syntax so the first one
that i want to run would be my
build.bat all right so i want to run a
batch file all right and what is the
name of the batch file that i want to
run i want to run this build.bat so
generate pipeline script this is all
that i got to specify as a part of my
build step and then unit test i'm gonna
just
change this to unit i think that's what
i have in my repository okay that is
unit and then deploy and quality queue
capital
quality and this one would be deploy
all right so this piece of code will
actually get into my repository and
check out my source code and grab it and
take it to the jenkins workspace so from
this workspace since all the files are
there in the root directory of this
workspace it will run these batch files
one after the other all right let me
save this and let me try to run my
pipeline
all right so it runs a lot of things in
the background trying to get the source
code from my repository whoa whoa whoa
that was fast all right so i pulled out
all the source code from my repository
the last commit message from where the
source code was pulled out it was this
create deploy dot bad that looks good
i'm saying building checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what i've had in my build.bat if i'm not
mistaken okay building the project
that's what is there with the timestamp
running unit test cases unit.bat it is
running the unit.bat and then giving me
the date and timestamp okay so all these
kind of pass and if i go back to the
project i will also see this beautiful
view of how exactly what is the time
that was taken for checking out the
repository running the build on bat
running the unit test cases quality
gates and all this isn't that pretty
simple now let me modify my previous job
or rather let me put up a new job for
making use of an agent wherein i could
delegate a job to an engine typically
agents can be brought up on any other
remote machines other than where your
primary genkin server is running in case
you don't know or you don't know how to
start up these agents i would strongly
recommend that you refer to our previous
jenkins video on the simply learn
youtube channel alright so let me just
check the status of my agent for now yes
he's offline so let me start this agent
because agent is not running so i have
the agent uh set up in my second agents
so let me copy the script file that is
required for starting my agent let me go
to the agents folder open up a command
prompt and let me try to bring up my
agent all right so the agent is up and
running for now i don't have the luxury
of starting my agent on a different
machine so my agent is running on my
same machine but the agent workspace is
sql agent while my primary jenkins
server is running has the workspace out
here c colon program files 86 and this
is the workspace of my jenkins all right
i hope you can kind of differentiate
those two all right so now what i want
is i look at the same job that i put in
earlier or rather modify that let the
steps be the same but i don't want to
run that on my master server let me try
to delegate that using the script so let
me put up an agent scripted job
right it will be a pipeline wrap job
let's say okay
and let me copy this was a step that i
had put in for my previous job so agent
any so what i'm gonna do now is i don't
want this to be running on any other
agent i want this to be running on the
agent whose label is let me check what
is the label of my
agent that is running okay
so this is the name of my agent okay
windows note so let me just copy that
there all right so with a very subtle
change instead of saying agent any i'm
going to run or rather i'm going to
specify the agent will be running this
job is the one who has got the label as
windows note so this agent that i
brought on my system has got the name as
windows node and it is configured to
pick up any job that matches the label
to which any job is kind of delegated so
let me come back to my jobs where is my
scripted agent job
i've got too many jobs running all right
so this is my agent scripted job that i
left halfway through so here in the
pipeline what i'm going to do is
this is all i'm going to need so the job
remains the same kit checkout is going
to check out from the same repository
run the batch files accordingly but this
change is just to ensure that this job
is kind of delegated on the agent
all right so this would be my agent job
let me save this
and let me get back to the dashboard and
let me run it from here if you see this
you know the master and agent are both
idle as of now let me try to run this
agent scripted job all right so the
agent kind of kicked in and there was a
job that was delegated to the agent if i
look at what is there in the console
output he's pretty much doing whatever
was there as a part of the job but the
interesting thing to notice that this is
the new workspace or rather this is
delegated to the agent and the agent's
workspace is this particular folder so
this is where it's going to get all this
stuff
run the whole thing and
you know the flow is pretty much the
same the only thing is this whole thing
ran on the agent if i need to check
my agent i would see the workspace out
here agent scripted job if you look at
this all the batch files are here and
this is where the job was kind of
delegated to run so with a very subtle
change in in the scripting i can ensure
that the jobs are kind of delegated onto
the agent the pipeline job specifically
as i mentioned earlier jenkins provides
you two different ways of writing
pipelines called the scripted and the
declarative the first one that was
launched was the scripted pipeline this
is heavily based on groovy scripting
since jenkins ships along with the
groovy engine so this was the first
script or the first support for pipeline
that was provided by jenkins in 2.0 this
needs a little bit of a learning curve
since groovy is a wonderful script
understanding that may be a little
cumbersome but then once you kind of
master it you can write really powerful
scripts based on groovy at a very high
level this is what a typical scripted
pipeline would look like something
called as a node node represents the
agent or the actual box on which your
job would be running and then a bunch of
stages are put out with each of the
stage along with the steps that needs to
be covered as the part of those stages
listed one below the other so all these
stages if they run peacefully then the
whole task is kind of marked as run
successfully since understanding groovy
or learning groovy was a little tough
for many of the people so this is a new
one from jenkins where it provides you a
much simple and friendly syntax for
writing pipelines without really needing
to understand or without nearly reading
to learn some group scripting again
there's a very subtle change between
these and you there are a lot of lookups
for figuring out what is a better
pipeline for you to kind of write but if
you can figure out the difference or if
you can try to find that particular
piece of code which kind of helps you
out with your pipeline either of the
skips there's not really any difference
in writing or kind of delivering your
pipeline using either of these two
methods all right so declare a pipeline
is something like this where you have an
agent you can specify the agent label or
if you can say agent any it will pick up
whatever is an available agent and run
the job and then you have something
called a stages stages is nothing but a
collection of stage and stage could have
multiple steps defined within this so if
any of the steps in any of the stage
fails then that particular complete
stage and the build is marked as failure
so very subtle difference between both
these
two syntax but using either of these you
can write powerful scripts for your
pipeline now let me come up with an
example where i'm going to at least demo
one of the feature where you could run a
master and a slave job in parallel so
let me come up with a demo for that
particular scenario let me put up a new
job for my parallel agent pipeline let
me call this and this would be a
pipeline
project i don't want anything here let
me look at the pipeline script that i
have pipeline agent none stages and
there's a first stage where this would
be a kind of non-parallel stage where
there's a need for you to possibly pull
out the source code from one of the
repositories and possibly unit test it
if all the unit test cases pass then
possibly you want to deploy it to one of
the test environments that would be what
would be there as a part of the
non-parallel stage and then you may have
a bunch of tests that could be run and
assuming that you know you have a
windows node you have a linux node you
have some other kind of an operating
system based node you could run these
stages in parallel so for just for
demonstration i've just put in two
parallel stages in parallel is the
keyword that you're going to use for
running tests parallely so i would say
parallel stage test on windows and i'm
going to run this in my windows note
well i could run a bunch of steps that i
want out here and then in the other
stage or other step what i want is i
will run something else on on my master
as long as this parallel keyword is
encountered jenkins will ensure that
these two stages are run parallely for
now i have both these things running on
my same machine but assuming that these
were running on different boxes you
could kind of visualize it as these two
steps are going to be started parallely
without really any dependency on each
other and then you could wait for the
test results and then based upon whether
both of these steps passed or failed if
one of them failed then we could kind of
mark the build accordingly so let me
copy this pretty pretty simple script
let me put this out here and now let me
save this out and let me try to build
this
all right there you go the stage will be
executed first this is the non-parallel
stage that's gonna happen then the task
one on agent task one one master
followed by as i said since i have only
one node or rather one system one with
both these things are running
simultaneously you will not really see a
benefit of this but assuming that you
have couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you'll possibly
want to run your selenium tests on the
windows box because selenium brings up
some of those ui which needs a browser
you could possibly need some regression
test that could run on linux boxes or
linux agents and then you can kind of
break down your tasks into multiple
things that is running on multiple
systems at the same time and then
collate all the results okay one final
thing all right now i have all my
particular
job or rather the steps required for my
pipeline put down in terms of the
scripts and this is saved in this
particular job that's not a good or a
recommended approach so what i'll do is
i'll copy all of these steps out here
and then what needs to be done is
actually let's say let me go back to
this repository the most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a jenkins file jenkins file
and you paste all the scripts that is
required for your pipeline now this is
in a true sense the devops approach
where i'm going to save this out so if
at all you have a pipeline defined for
your project uh the best place to kind
of
put out your configurations for the
pipeline is within your repository so
this may be a different project that i
was referring to but assuming that you
have your project where you know you
have to define your pipeline instead of
putting that as a particular job on
jenkins and fearing that if jenkins
fails other jobs if there's a crash and
then you lose out your job configuration
the best approach is to use a jenkins
file put all the steps that is required
the try tested steps that is required as
a part of your jenkins file and then you
can put out a job that can pull the
source code from here as well as use the
steps that is defined in the jetkins
file so let me end up by putting up
another job which is a true jobs kind of
a job so i would say devops
pipeline
and this is a pipeline script
and then i'm not going to say any of
these things i would say the pipeline
script is from the source code
management so my pipeline script is
already defined it is present in scm so
what is my svn i mean what is my source
code repository this is my source code
repository where i already have this so
let me copy this url this is my url i
don't need any credentials because the
repositories anyway in public repository
that is all that is required i would say
and the scripted file it automatically
picks up jenkins file all right so let
me save this let me build this
so that's the beauty of devops wherein i
have a pipeline that is defined and
instead of putting the pipeline as a job
because pipeline is nothing but a
configuration the configuration is also
checked into the source code repository
and any changes to this pipeline instead
of putting that modifications in the job
these are all captured as a part of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
devops today is being implemented by
you know most of the major organizations
whether it's a financial organization
whether it's a kind of a service
organization every organization is
somehow looking forward for the
implementation and the adaptation of
devops because it totally redefines and
automate the whole development process
all together and whatever the manual
efforts you were putting earlier that is
simply or gets automated with the help
of these tools here
so this is something which get really
implemented because of some of the
important uh feature like a ci cd
pipeline because ca cd pipeline is
responsible for delivering your source
core into the production environment in
large duration of time so cicd pipeline
is ultimately the goal which really
helps us to deliver more into the
production environment when we talk
about from this perspective
now let's talk about that what exactly
is a ca cd pipeline now when we go into
that part when we go into that
understanding so ci cd pipeline is a
basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept which is
used or which is considered as a
backbone of the overall devops approach
now it's one of the prime approach which
we implement when we are going for a
devops implementation for our project so
if i have to go for a devops
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation and the
automation which i'm looking forward is
actually from the uh particular ci cd
pipelines here so cacd pipelines is
really a wonderful option when we talk
about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term
all about so pipeline is in series of
events that are connected together with
each other it's kind of a sequence of
the various steps like you know
typically when we talk about any kind of
deployment so we have like you know
build process like we compile the source
code we generate the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment all these various steps
which we use to do it like manually that
is something which we can do it into a
pipeline so pipeline is nothing but a
sequence of all these steps
interconnected with each other executed
one by one into a particular sequence
now
the pipelines is responsible for
performing a variety of tasks
like building up the source code running
the test cases uh probably the
deployment can also be added up in when
we go for the continuous integration and
continuous delivery there so all these
steps are being done into a sequence
definitely because sequence is very
important when we talk about the
pipeline so you need to talk about the
sequence the same way in which you are
working on the development and in a
typical world the same thing you will be
putting up into a specific pipeline so
that's a very important aspect to be
considered now let's talk about what is
the continuous integration here now
continuous integration is also you know
known as the ci uh pretty much you can
see that a lot of uh tools are actually
named as ci but they are referring to
the continuous integration only so
continuous integration is a practice
that integrates the source code into a
shared repository and it used to
automate the verification of the source
code so it involves the build
automations test cases automation so it
also helps us to detect the issues and
the bugs quite easily and quite faster
that's a very early mechanism which we
can do as such if we want to resolve all
these problems now continuous
integrations does not eliminate the bugs
but yes it definitely helps them uh you
know easily to find out because we we
are talking about the uh automated
process we are talking about the
automated test cases so definitely that
is something which can help us to
find out the bugs and then you know the
development can help on that and they
can you know proceed with those bugs and
they can try to resolve those things one
by one so it's not a kind of automated
process which will eventually remove the
bugs bugs is something which you have to
recode and you have to fix it by
following the development practice but
yes it can really help us to find those
bugs quite easy and help them to remove
now what is the continuous delivery here
so continuous delivery also known as cd
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh into the code before
the deployment now in this case what
happens that uh it's um something which
we are discussing or we are validating
that what exactly we want to deliver it
to the customer so what exactly we are
going ahead are we are moving to the
customers so that's what we typically do
in case of continuous delivery and the
ultimate goal of the pipeline is to make
the deployments that's the end result
because
coding is not the only thing you code
the programs you do the development
after that it's all about the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a very important aspect you want to
go ahead with the deployments that's
right you can go there and that's a real
beauty about this because it it's in
kind of a way in which we can identify
that the how the deployments can be run
or can be executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments and to proceed further on
that
right
so when both these practices are placed
in together in an order so all the steps
could be referred as in complete
automated process and this process is
known as cicd so when we are talking
about like when we are working on this
automation so in that case what happens
that we are looking forward that how the
automation needs to be done and since
it's in kind of a ci cd automation which
we are talking about so it's nothing but
the uh end result would be like build
and deployment automation so you will be
taking care of both the bill and the
test case executions and the deployments
as such when we talk about as such the
cacd here
the implementation of chcd also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly and efficiently because
these are things which is you know
happening automatically so there is no
manual efforts involved and there is no
scope of human error also so we have
frequently seen that while doing the
deployments we may miss some binaries or
some miss can be there so that is
something which is you know completely
removed as such when we talk about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the uh confident here
because um the automations definitely
gives a kind of a boost to the
confidence that yes things are going to
work perfectly fine and there is no
issues as such present
now why exactly jenkins like jenkins is
what we typically understand or we you
know uh here and there that it's in ci2
it's a cd tool so what exactly is
jenkins all about so jenkins is also
known as a kind of orchestration tool
it's an automated tool which is there
and the best part is that it's
completely open source yes there are
some particular or paid or the
enterprise tools are there like cloud
b's and all but there is no as such of
offering difference between the
cloudbees and the jenkins here so
jenkins is an kind of open source tool
which a lot of organizations pretty much
implement as it is itself so even if
they don't want to go um we have seen in
a lot of big organizations where you
know they are not going for the
enterprise tool like cloud b's and all
and they are going for the pretty much
you know core jenkins software as such
here
so this tool uh makes it easy for the
developers to integrate the changes to
the project that is something which is
very important because it can really
help the teams to say that how the
things can be done and how it can be
performed over there so the tools is
really easy for the developers to
integrate and that's the biggest uh you
know benefit which we are getting when
we talk about these tools as such so
jenkins is a very important tool to be
considered when we talk about all these
automations now jenkins achieves
continuous integration with the help of
plugins that is also a kind of another
feature or benefit which we get because
there are so many plugins which is
available there as such which is being
used and uh for example you want to have
an integration with kubernetes docker
and all maybe by default those plugins
are not installed but yes you have the
provisioning that you can go for the
installation of those plugins and yes
those features will start embedded up
and integrated within your jenkins so
this is the reason this is the main
benefit which we get when we talk about
the jenkins implementation
so jenkins uh is you know one of the
best fit which is there for building a
cicd pipeline because of its flexibility
uh open source nature plug-in
capabilities the support for plugins and
it's quite easy to use and it's very
simple straightforward gui which is
there which can definitely helps us you
can you know easily understand and go
through the jenkins and you can grab the
understanding and as an end result you
will be able to have a very robust tool
which using which pretty much any kind
of source code or any kind of
programming language you can implement
ci city whether it's an android it's a
not net it's a java it's a node.js all
the languages are having the support for
the jenkins
so let's talk about the ccd pipeline
with the jenkins here now to automate
the entire development process a cicd
pipeline is the ultimate you know
solution which we are looking forward to
build such a pipeline jenkins is our
best solution and best fit which is
available here
so there are pretty much six steps which
is involved when we look forward for any
kind of pipeline it's a generic pipeline
which we are looking forward now it may
have like
any other steps which is available there
probably some additional steps you're
doing like some other plugins you are
installing but these are the basic steps
which is there like a minimum pipeline
if you want to design these are the
steps which is available there now let's
see the first one is that we have the uh
required java jdk like a jdk to be
available on the system now most of the
operating systems are already available
with a gre like a java gre but the
problem with gre is that it's only for
the build process uh it will not be
doing the compilation you can run the
artifacts you can run the jar files you
can you know run the application run the
code base but the compilation requires
the java c or the java jdk kit to be
installed onto the system and that's the
reason why for this one we also require
the jdk and certain linux commands
execution understanding we need to have
because we are going to run some kind of
steps some installation steps and you
know process so that's pretty much
required now let's talk about how do ca
cd pipeline with jenkins now first of
all you have to download the jdk
and uh that is something which is
installed so after that you can go for
the jenkins download now jenkins dot io
slash download is the website is our
official websites of jenkins but the
best part is that there you have support
for different operating systems and
platforms
from there you can easily say that if
you want to go for a java package like a
war file tucker ubuntu deviant centos
fedora red hat windows open sushi uh
freebsd ganto mac operating system in
fact whatever the different kind of
artifacts or different environment or
different uh
application you want to download you
will be able to do that so that's a very
first thing to start upon you download
the generic java package like a war file
then you have to execute it you have to
download that into a specific folder
structure let's say say that you have
you know created a folder called jenkins
now you have to go into that jenkins
folder with the help of cd command and
there you have to run the command called
java hyphen jar and the jenkins dot bar
there so these are the executables uh
artifacts so var files can be easily
executable
jar files raw files can be easily
deployed so
just because with the java command you
can run them you don't require any kind
of web container or application
container as such so here also you can
see that we are running the java command
and it runs the applications as such
and once that is done so you can open
the web browser and uh you can open like
localhost colon edt so jenkins uses atd
port just like a tomcat apache so uh if
you know once the deployment is done
installation is done so you can just
open the localhost colony
now if you want to get
the jenkins up and running in the
browser probably you can you know go
through the uh public ipad address also
there so you can put the public ipad is
calling 880 and that can also help you
to you know start accessing the jenkins
application
now in there you will be having an
option called create new jobs so you
need to click on that now once the uh
particular new job new item new job
that's a
different naming conventions which is
available there now all you're going to
do is that you're going to do like you
are proceeding with the creating the
pipeline job so you will be having an
option called pipeline job over there
just select that and provide your custom
name what pipeline name or job name you
want to uh refer or you want to process
there now once that is available so what
happens that it will be an easy task for
us to see that how exactly we can go
ahead and we can perform on that part so
this can really help us to see that how
a pipeline job can be created and you
know performed on these modifications as
such
now when the pipeline is selected and we
can give a particular name that is this
is the name which is available and then
we can say okay as such over there now
you can scroll down and find the
pipeline section so uh there what
happens that when you go over there and
say that okay this is the way that how
the pipelines are managed and you know
those kind of things so you will scroll
down and find the pipeline section and
go with that pipeline script now when
you select that option there are
different options which is available
like how you want to manage these
pipelines now you are you know have the
direct access also like if you want to
directly create the uh create a pipeline
script you can do that if you feel that
you want to manage like you want to
retrieve the jenkins file so so scored
management tool also can be used there
so you can work on that also so like
this there are so many a variety of
things which is available like which you
can use to work around that how exactly
the pipeline job can be created so
either you can fetch it from the source
code management tool uh like gate
version or something like that or you
can directly put the pipeline code as
such over there right now so next thing
is that we can configure and execute a
pipeline job with the direct script so
uh we can once the pipeline is selected
so you can put the
particular script like jenkins file into
your particular github link so you
you may be having like already a github
link so that the where the jenkins file
is there so you can make use of that now
once you process the github link so what
we can do is that we can proceed with
that
and uh once the processing is done so
you can do the same and you know you can
keep the changes and you know uh it will
be picking up the pipelines you know the
pipeline script is added up into the
github and you know you have already
specified that uh let's just go ahead
with this jenkins file pipeline script
from the github repository and proceed
further now once that is done so what
next you can do is that you can go with
the build now process you click on the
bill now and once that is done so what
will happen that you will be able to see
that how the build process will be done
and how the build will be performed over
there so these are pretty much a kind of
a way so you can click on the console
output you will get all the logs that is
happening in the inside that whatever
the pipeline steps are getting executed
all of them you will be able to get or
you will be able to you know get on that
part there so these are the different
steps which is involved as such and uh
the sixth one is that you know uh yes
whatever the uh particular uh
when you run the build now you will be
able to see that source code will be uh
you know will be checked out and will be
downloaded before the build and you can
proceed with that part now later on if
you want to change the url of this
github you can configure the job again
the existing job and you can change that
url github link url whenever you require
you can also clone this uh job whenever
you go ahead and you work on that and
that's also kind of you know the best
part which is available as such right
and uh
then you can have the advanced settings
over there so in there you can put like
uh your github repository you can say
like okay uh the github repository is
there so i'm just going to put this url
and you know with that what will happen
that the settings will be available
there and the jenkins file will be
downloaded as such and when you run the
build now you will be able to have a lot
of steps like a lot of configurations
going on so uh then they check out scm
so uh we can have a declaration like
checkout sm which is there so when the
checkout sm is there so it will check
out a specific source code after that
you go to the log and you will be able
to see that each and every stage which
is being built up and executed as such
okay so now we are going to talk about a
demo here so on the pipeline here so
this is the jenkins portal now you can
see here that there is an option called
create a job you can either click on the
new item or you can click on the new uh
create a job here now here i'm going to
say like a pipeline
and uh then you know you can select the
pipeline uh job type here now you have
the freestyle pipeline github
organization multiple branch pipeline
these are the different options which is
available there but i'm going to
continue with the pipeline here as such
so when i selected the pipeline and say
okay so what will happen that i will be
able to see a configuration page which
is related to the pipeline now here the
very important part is that you have all
the uh general build trigger
you know options which is similar to the
freestyle but the build step and the
post build step is completely removed
because of the pipeline introduction now
here you either have the option to put
the pipeline script all together you can
also have some particular example for
example let's talk about some github
maven uh particular uh tool here so you
can see that
we have you know got some steps as such
over here and you know it's pretty much
running over there now you run it it
will work smoothly it will check out
some source code but how we are going to
integrate like the version the jenkins
file into the version control system
because that's the ideal approach we
should be following when we create a
pipeline of a ci cd now i'm going to
select a particular pipeline from a cm
here then go with the git here now in
there the jenkins file is the name of
the file of the pipeline script and i'm
going to put my
repository over here in this one now
this repository is of my gate which is
like having even built pipeline which is
available there it's having some steps
related to ci with for the build and
deployments and that's what we can
follow as such over here now in this one
the uh if it is a private repository
definitely you can add on your
credentials but this is a public
repository a personal repository so i
don't have to put any kind of
credentials but you can always add the
credentials with the help of add here
and that can help you to you know set up
whatever the credentials private
repositories you want to configure now
once you save the configuration here
now what it's going to do is that you
it's going to give you a particular page
related to build now
if you want to run if you want to delete
the pipeline if you want to reconfigure
the pipeline all these different options
are available there so we are going to
click on the build now here and when i
do that
immediately the pipeline will be
downloaded and will be processed now you
may not be able to get the a complete
stage view as of now because it's still
running so yeah you can see that the
checkout code is done then it's going on
to the build okay that's one of the step
which is there now once the build will
be done so it will continue with the
next steps with the next further steps
there so you can also go to the console
output log here like you can click on
this or you can click on the console
output to check the complete log which
is happening there or in fact you can
also see the stage wise logs also
uh because that is also very important
when you go for the complete logs uh it
may you know uh have a lot of steps
involved and you know lot of logs will
be available there but if you want to
see a specific log of a specific stage
that's where this comes into the picture
and as you can see that all the
different uh steps like test cases
executions the scenar cube analysis the
archive artifacts deployment and in fact
the notification so all this is a part
of a complete pipeline this whole
pipeline is done here and uh you know
you get a kind of a stage view it's
success over here and the artifacts is
also available to download so you can
download this war file is a web
applications as such over here so this
is what our typical pipeline looks like
that how the automation the complete
automations really looks like as such
over here now this is a very important
aspect because it really helps us to
understand that how the pipelines can be
configured can be done and pretty much
with the same steps you will be able to
automate any kind of pipelines as such
so that was the demo to build a simple
pipeline as such with the jenkins and
pretty much in this one we understood
that how exactly the cic pipelines can
be configured and we can use them and we
can get hold on that part hello and
welcome to continuous integration
tutorial using jenkins my name is
chidanand and i am with the simply learn
team today let's get started with
jenkins jenkins in my opinion is one of
the most popular continuous integration
servers of recent times what began as a
hobby project by a developer working for
sun microsystems way back in early or
mid 2000s has gradually and eventually
evolved into a very very powerful and
robust automation servers it has a wider
option since it is released under mit
license and is almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
build being good or build being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
containers integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
will have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what i'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or linux-based services so if at all you
have windows like the way i have and i'm
going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever i install it as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic warp file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt if it
layer on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration all
the way in which i'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there's always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
homepage and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you will have to
accept the license agreement and there
are a bunch of installers that is okay
that you can pick up based upon the
operating system on which you're running
so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into those environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this c colon program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i have been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if i told i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i am good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins there is available for download
you also have a docker container
wherein you know you can launch jenkins
as a container but i'll not get into
details of that in this tutorial
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is a
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into sql and program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to back up your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if i told you you're running as a war
file you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station
so as a part of the installation it just
asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will [ __ ]
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugin that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your your network is not so good
few of these plugins would kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or or mirrored sites and sometimes some
of them may be down so do not worry in
case some of these plugins kind of fail
to install you'll get an option to kind
of retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so i'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that i can remember i will
that's my name and um an email id is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case i don't so i just
given an admin and i got a password i've
got i remember my password this is my
full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate you know all
the effort that has gone into the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it but once
you start using it possibly you'll start
liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as managed in cans
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all jenkins configuration so i'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace anything and everything
regarding jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and is possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time if there
are multiple jobs that kind of get
triggered at the same time in case the
number of executors are less compared to
the number of jobs that have woken up no
need to panic because they will all get
queued up and eventually jenkins will
get to running those jobs just bear in
mind that whenever a new job kind of you
know gets triggered the cpu usage and
the memory usage in terms of the disk
right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you're in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for a jenkins server so you
can specify the smtp server details of
your
company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me i have configured my
personal email id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email
with the configuration that i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configuration that
i'm going to change here all of these
look good
all right so i come back to managing
kens okay one other thing that i want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know
what kind of a code base it's going to
pull in what kind of a tool says that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you will have to put in all the
tools that is required for building the
appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it git if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system
which is your continuous integration
server you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
manage jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say ok
at a very high level you will see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job
all right i don't want to choose any of
these again there are some helps
available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
will let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some building stray out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running would you know there will be
individual folders specific to the jobs
that has been put up here all right so
one job one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second
job i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what i'm going to do
i will just keep everything else the
same i'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that
gets
triggered automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this github
uh triggering or hook or a web hook kind
of a triggering later on but for now
what i want to do i want to ensure that
this job that i'm going to put in would
be automatically triggered on its own
let's say every minute i want this job
to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one
two
three
four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and he's asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there is updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for it to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role-based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using the
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
right looks good so far
yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go and restart
your jenkins instance but for now i
don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security
and
i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based uh plugin
so this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy uh plugin and i'm
going to enable that strategy all right
i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these rules all
right so let me go to
manage
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qr guys would need to provide
some sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why i'm creating a
role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if you hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little you
know different but i would want to give
very very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that's looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
or check you know have read-only access
to the job run
no i don't want him to give him any any
particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure yeah possibly create
yeah delete i don't want read yes
definitely and this is the specific role
so what i'm doing i'm just creating a
global role called developer and i'm
giving him very very limited roles in
the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here how sick configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user i would
call this user as yeah developer one
sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
t dot com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that it
created so developer i would assign this
developer one to this particular global
rule
and i would go ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who
is tagged as a part of this developer
role would get the same kind of
permissions and these permissions can be
you know fine grain it can be a project
specific permissions as well but for now
i just demonstrated the high level
permission that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plug-in you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a jenkins build you can
build a job on jenkins and push it to
sonar cube and get sonar cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our jenkins
instance to github i already have very
very simple java repository up on my
github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello java and this is
what is there in the repo there is a
hello hello.java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of
system.out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the url for this repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
stps url so what i would do is i would
connect my jenkins instance to go to
github provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloudhosted github.com and get it to my
jenkins instance and then build this
particular java file i'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just a
java file how do i build my java file
how do i compile my java file i just say
java c and the name of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
what it needs is a git plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git is already
installed on my system so i don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here it says git job let it be a
freestyle project that's good for me i
would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
the step would pull the source code from
the github and then what would be there
as a part of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
kit on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i have integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based uh
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based
build tool that will allow you to run
various targets and it will compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify it can compile it can run some
tests and you can you can build a war
file and even deploy it into some other
server for now what we're going to use
maven is just for building and creating
a package out of this particular web
application it contains a bunch of
things and what is important is just the
index.jsp it just contains an html file
that is there as a part of this web
application so from a perspective of
requirements now since i'm going to
connect jenkins with this particular
repository git we already have that set
we only need two other things one is
maven because jenkins will use maven so
in order to use maven jenkins would have
to have a maven installation that is
there on the jenkins box and in this
case the jenkins box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download i'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
tomcat all right so download maven first
and the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source uh build tool so you'll have
to set in a few configurations and set
up the path so mvn hyphen iphone version
if i specify this after i set in my path
my one should work and if at all i echo
m2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip my one just set this
m2 home variable to the directory where
you unzip your mi1 also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat
server 8.5 is what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080. since we
already have our jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port clash
so what i've done i have configured
tomcat to use a different port so if i
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup dot bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository is
this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that i
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server again i would need
a small plugin to do this because i need
to connect tomcat with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment
so i will go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i have
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify the
what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
as the name of my thing now i need to
specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
the stomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember i
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is find found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is same
in web use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this local host
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like
a deployment went ahead perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
ip address all that you've got to go and
change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what you'll do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
he if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some other machines or some other
slaves you know that's a wonderful thing
to have okay use case one use case two
assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server that is running on a
windows box or on a linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
windows you know windows based dot net
kind of a projects where you would need
a windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
linux linux based systems you also have
a mac you you support some sort of an
apps or something that is built on mac
os you would need to build you know mac
based system as well so how are you
going to support all these needs so
that's where in a beautiful concept of
master slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some sort of triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control a lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple runner or
a slave that is a simple jar file that
is run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what i'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is i will set
up a simple slave but since i don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is i will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so i've got the c drive and d drive my
jenkins is on my c drive so what i do is
i would just use my e drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there i'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agent's
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this so i'm
going to use this jlp which is nothing
but java network launch protocol and you
know i'll configure the master and
server to talk to each other using jlp
so for that i need to enable this guide
so i enable this guy instead of making
the by default the configuration was
disabled so i make him random i make him
you know enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now i've configured or has
made a setting for the master
so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so i'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server jenkins would put in some sort of
security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular agent so that he can
connect your jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i'll just give an
identifier saying that windows note i
would say this is a permanent agent i'll
say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or not 86
c column program files
it is indeed 86
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so i create a
folder here called jenkins node and this
is where i'm going to place my or i'm
going to provision my slave
and i'm going to run him from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copied here the label
you know probably this is fine for me
and usage
how do you want to use this guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
will have to specify this particular
label
so imagine this way if i have a bunch of
windows mesh system i name it as windows
star anything that says from windows i
can give a regular expression and say
that anything that matches windows run
this particular task there if i have
some mac machines i name all these mac
agents as a mac star or something like
that and i can delegate all tasks you
know saying that start with whatever
starts with mac this node run the mac
jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands along with an
agent.jar so this is the agent.jar that
has to be taken down to the other
machine or the slave node and from there
i need to run this along with a small
security credential so let me copy this
whole
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
alien.jar
i would say yes
and this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this
sorry for launching this agent is found
this agent.jar so typically i need to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then
kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or
whether i cut this i come back to my
folder my jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and i need to use this whole
command
ctrl a ctrl c and then launch this
particular agent so let me
bring up a command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are on different
locations or different ips let us
specify the ip address all this any way
would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
connect very well so let me come back to
my
jenkins instance
and see you know if you told me you see
earlier this was not connected now let
me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials of the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node or the jenkins slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it'll create a workspace right here all
right so good
so let me just come back and let me kind
of put up a new task here i will say
that you know delegate job is good i say
freestyle project i'm going to create a
very very simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
relegated to the
slave negative two i don't like the word
slave delegated to agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that
i've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label
right so now i'm going to put in a job
that will only match this particular
label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it ran successfully
and uh where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
jenkins node it created a new workspace
delegated job it put in here so my old
or the my primary master
job is in sql uh program files under
jenkins and this is the slave job that
was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed built in jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we back up all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of us
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present but we
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage and cans
and uh click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so i would
recommend one of these plugins that i
specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin
so let me come back to my managed
plugins
stop this plugin is there
so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you uninstall this
plugin so first time i can you know do a
setup i would say back up this
particular i'll give a folder uh this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
i want jks to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good i want it in
verbose mode i don't want to shut on my
jenkins or should i shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens if there
are too many jobs that is running on the
server
it can kind of slow down your uh jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying a few of those things
and the files are being changed at that
moment it's little bit problematic for
jenkins so typically you back up your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically try to you know bring
it to a shutdown kind of a state and
then take a backup
all right so i'm going to back up all
these things you know i don't want to
exclude anything else i want the history
i want the maven artifacts possibly i
don't want this guy i would just say
save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my manager cans
come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
that's an or
jenkins configuration hi guys welcome to
this video on jenkins interview
questions and answers
jenkins is a popular devops open source
automation server
it is used to automate the non-human
part of software development
and supports continuous integration and
continuous delivery
jenkins is a server based system that
runs in servlet containers such as
apache tomcat
we have compiled the most important
jenkins interview questions that you
might face in a jenkins or devops
interview
so without further ado let us get
started with jenkins interview questions
and answers so the first question you'll
be asked about with jenkins is explain a
master slave architecture of jenkins so
the way that jenkins is set up is that
the jenkins master will pull code from
your remote git repository such as
github and will check that repository
every time there is a code commit it
will distribute the workload of that
code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code to all of the
jenkins slaves and then on request the
jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
jenkins file and simply put a jenkins
file is a text file that has a
definition of the jenkins pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit trail for
that pipeline and also provides a single
source of truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs jenkins from the
command line is it java jar jenkins dot
war java dash war jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins jar java dash war
jenkins.org
and the answer is a java jar jenkins.war
so when working with jenkins you're
going to be asked what are the key
concepts and aspects of working with the
jenkins pipeline and you want to really
hold out your fingers here and go
through four key areas and that is
pipeline node step and stay so pipeline
refers to the user-defined model of a cd
continuous delivery pipeline node are
the machines which is which are part of
that jenkins environment within the
pipeline step is a single task that
tells jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to define
dependency in maven and do we have a
build.xml
b
palm.xml c
dependency.xml or d
version.xml and the answer is palm.xml
working with jenkins you're going to be
asked to explain the two types of
pipeline used in jenkins along with the
syntax and so a scripted pipeline is
based on groovyscript as their domain
specific language for jenkins and there
are one or more note blocks that are
used throughout the entire pipeline on
the left hand side you can actually see
what the actual script would look like
and the right hand side shows what the
actual declaration for each section of
that script would be the second type of
jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to find the work
completed in a decorative pipeline so
how do you create a copy and backup of
jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
there essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you are asked about this question of
security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from end user credentials b is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or see you
can actually configure jenkins to
authenticate
by using such as oauth which is a more
modern method of being able to
authenticate users you're going to be
asked how to deploy a custom build of a
core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot hpi plugin file into the jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi.pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
disable allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time jenkins
is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the url for your jenkins
environment slash safe restart so before
we talk about selenium let's understand
a few drawbacks of manual testing let's
take an example of a very simple use
case as a user i want to login to my web
application using username and password
a very simple use case and it's a very
common use case for any kind of web
application you're working so as a
tester what do i do i need to write
multiple test case to test this use case
so i can use multiple data sets like
valid credentials invalid credentials
null values and so on to test this
particular use case and then what you do
you start executing the test cases one
by one you find bugs then your
developers fixes them and then you will
need to rerun all the test cases again
and again until all the bugs of for this
use case are fixed and your application
is ready to ship now look into this now
this brings us to the first merit
demerit of the manual testing which is
what if one has to run test cases with
hundred transactions and repeat them
again and again this is going to be a
very time consuming process and very
boring also it is more error prone since
it's done manually and human mistakes
are bound to happen the third challenge
is the scope of manual testing itself is
very limited for example say regression
testing ideally you would want to run
all the test cases which you have
written but since it's a manual process
this is going to be very tedious to do
and also you would not have all the
luxury of time to execute all test cases
so what do you do you start picking up
those test cases which are very
important to be run and that way you are
kind of limiting the scope of your
testing also working with large amount
of data manually is going to be
impractical what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measure as a part of
your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on your
application under test and all these
things manually it is very difficult to
perform and it's not feasible also and
to submit all this creating manual test
reports after running all the tests who
wants to really do that and again
another level of challenge here is say
if you're working on an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers the testers are building
their test cases executing them as and
when the bills are available to them
this happens iteratively and hence you
will need to run all those test cases
which have written multiple times during
your development cycle and doing this
manually definitely is going to be very
tedious and boring and is this effective
of doing it no so what do we do we
automate it so this tells us why we want
to automate one for faster execution two
to be less error prone three to help
frequent execution of our tests so there
were many tools available in the market
for automation one such tool was
selenium and that brings us to the slide
advent of selenium so much before
selenium there are various tools in the
market like rft qtp just to name a few
popular ones the selenium was introduced
by a gentleman called jason huggins way
back in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was kind of working on a
web application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
in doing manual testing of his
application repeatedly so what he did
was he wrote a javascript program that
automatically controlled the browser
actions and then he named that as
javascript test runner he made this open
source which was later renamed as
selenium core and this is how the
selenium came into existence so with
this brief history of selenium let's
understand what the selenium and what
are its main features selenium is the
most popular and widely used automation
tool for automating web applications it
enables us to test web application on
different kind of process like internet
explorer chrome firefox safari opera and
so on and also they introduced support
for edge browser after microsoft
introduced it selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components and
those we will be seeing uh in some time
all these tools together help us test
the web application so selenium is open
source and it is platform independent
this is the biggest reason why people
are preferring this tool because it is
free of cost qtp and rft which i just
talked about are a chargeable one
selenium scripts can run on any platform
because selenium is primarily developed
in javascript so it is platform
independent well as you know it's common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming background so selenium has a
record and replay back tool called the
selenium ide which can be used to create
a set of actions as a script and to
replay that script but this is mainly
used for demo purpose why because
selenium is such a powerful tool that
you should be able to take advantage of
all its feature and not just be with a
record and replay tool right so that way
there are a lot of record and replay
tool anyway available in the market the
selenium provides support for different
programming language java python c sharp
ruby php and so on you can write your
test scripts in any language you prefer
or you like and again as i said one need
not really know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages you would
still be able to write the selenium
scripts with the basic knowledge of this
programming language and also selenium
supports various operating system you
can run selenium tests on windows mac or
linux or even say if you have ubuntu
machine you can always run your selenium
test on ubuntu machines so of you can
run the test on any platform of your
choice okay so let's go now a little
more deeper into selenium so i said that
selenium is not a single tool but it is
a suite of tools right so now let's look
at what are those major components which
comprises of the selenium suite first
one is the selenium id so selenium id is
the most simplest tool in the whole
suite of the selenium it is nothing but
it's an integrated development
environment earlier this ide was simply
a firefox extension and it offered a
record and playback functionality it was
a very simple and easy to use and as i
said mainly this is used for prototyping
or for only the demo purposes right and
not creating automation for your
real-time projects because you know of
its own limitation of being a simple
recorded replay too however selenium
what happened selenium ide it died with
firefox 55 so that means uh the support
for ide was stopped from firefox 55
version but the good news is very
recently all new brand new selenium ide
has been launched and also what they
have done is they have made this cross
browser that means you can install the
extension on chrome the id extension on
chrome or as an add-on on firefox so it
is supported on both the browsers
firefox and chrome all right so while we
are talking of this ide let me also show
you uh how the latest id on the chrome
looks okay for that let me go and launch
my chrome browser so let me just open a
new tab and what i'll do is i'll search
for selenium id for chrome download then
i go to this website and then you can
see a selenium id offered by
seleniumhq.org so what i simply need to
do is like you install any extension on
your chrome browsers i just say add to
chrome and this adds this extension on
your chrome browser
now it is added so selenium ide has been
added to chrome use this extension by
clicking the side so can you see this
icon here which is selenium id that's it
so once you have installed this you are
free to start using the idea on this
chrome browser similarly you can do
adding of this add-on which is called as
add-on on firefox so go to the firefox
browser search for the selenium id and
just install that add-on so let's get
back to our presentation so that's about
the id so what's our next component our
next component is selenium rc which is
nothing but selenium remote control
selenium rc is used to write web
application test in different
programming languages it interacts with
the browser with the help of rc server
it has an rc server through which only
it can interact with the web browsers
and how does it communicate it uses a
simple http get and post request and
this is what was called as selenium 1.0
version but it got deprecated in 2.0
version and it was completely removed in
3.0 and was replaced with something
called as web driver so we will be
talking in detail about why this
happened what were the drawbacks of rc
which led to replacing with the web
driver so now that brings us to third
component which is the selenium
webdriver this is the most important
component it is just a programming
interface to create and execute our test
cases of course it's a successor of rc
because there were certain drawbacks
which i just mentioned and we will be
going in detail of what it were so web
driver what the major difference what we
see with the web driver is the
architecture of the web driver is much
simpler than rc for the reason that
webdriver interacts with the browser
directly unlike your rc where it needs
an rc server to interact with the
browser so this gave a lot of advantage
an edge over the rc the fourth component
selenium grid selenium grid is used to
run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with selenium
driver you can only do the sequential
execution however in real time
environment you know that there is
always a need to run tests on
distributed environment for example say
you have a web application and say you
have automated around hundreds of
thousands of test cases and you need to
run them as a regression suite and also
one of the ask is that you need to run
this on multiple browsers and multiple
os why since you have automated them and
your application supports multiple
browsers and os now imagine the time
taken to run these thousand test cases
sequentially with the web driver right
it's going to take quite a bit of time
so what you need is to run this parallel
on multiple machines matrix across the
browsers and operating system and that
is where the grid helps you in achieving
that so grid has this hub and node
concept and it helps in achieving the
parallel execution which i just talked
about so you can check out our detailed
video on selenium grid on simplyla all
right so now we talked about the
components of the selenium so let's look
at the different versions it evolved
into so when i talked about rc i
mentioned that this was selenium one
version so now let's understand how this
evolved over years and what it offers
today so when jason huggins introduced
selenium the tool was called javascript
program he called it as javascript test
runner it had one major issue now that
is something called a same origin policy
so what is the same origin policy it
says that a javascript when executed in
a domain can access web pages in that
domain only and it cannot access any web
pages in another domain i will repeat it
same origin policies dictates that a
javascript is executed in a domain can
access web pages in that domain only and
it cannot access web pages in another
domain for example say every web page in
say google.com domain like search email
drive can be accessible but nothing
outside of google.com like say if you
want to access a web page and say amazon
or yahoo is possible to access why
because of the simple reason which is a
security reasons now to overcome this
paul homan created something called a
selenium remote control server and why
did he create that he wanted to trick
the browser in believing that the
selenium core through which you're going
to run your scripts and your web
application under test are in the same
domain with which you are able to
achieve run your test on your web
application without having to get into
this issue of same origin policy so this
is what was a version one of selenium
and we called it as selenium remote
control and then what happened in 2007
simon stewart okay he invented this web
driver now why did he invent this
because the architecture of selenium rc
was little complicated rc required a
separate server to talk to your browsers
so what he did was he removed the
requirement of having a separate server
in the rc and this was the selenium 2
version now since it was a transition
phase both the selenium rc and the web
driver co-existed in selenium 2. while
the web driver was still under
development and then what happened in
3.0 selenium is the selenium core which
is the rc was completely deprecated and
only the web driver was made available
so in this series of videos we will be
working with selenium 3.0 and now
selenium 4 is already around the corner
so alpha is already released as of the
day when this video was made and i
believe some of the features what the
selenium 4 is going to offer is they are
moving towards w3c webdriver
standardization one and also there is
going to be an improved id the id which
i just talked about that it's a improved
version of the previous ide and then an
improved version of selenium grid also
so they might be doing a gui based grid
right so these are some of the major
features expected in this version why
selenium webdriver so let's look at what
led to replacement of selenium rc with
this webdriver for that first we need to
understand the selenium rc and its
shortcoming as i said selenium rc is a
simple tool to write tests for web
applications in various supported
programming languages like java python
ruby and c and this is the architecture
of the selenium rc at a very high level
first you need to write test scripts in
any of the supported languages of your
church so if you're more familiar with
java you would be writing your test
scripts all your commands in the java so
before we start writing the test one of
the major requirement right required for
the rc to run is your rc server so first
you need to start this rc server before
you run even a single line of code and
this rc server is a separate application
and now what is the function of this rc
server the selenium server or the rc
server is responsible for receiving
cellini's commands from your test script
it interprets them and then reports the
result back to your selenium test now
what are the selenius commands these
commands are nothing but the commands
returned in your test script these are
called as selenius command that is what
the selenium server does now after the
selenium servers function let's look at
how the browser interaction happens the
browser interaction happens through this
rc server this rc server uses a simple
http post and get request to communicate
and how does this communication happen
this rc server acts like a proxy say for
example your test script asks for
launching a browser this command from
your test script goes to the server and
then this rc server launches the browser
injects its javascript into the browser
once this is done all the subsequent
calls that is all the subsequent calls
is all the rest of the commands which
you have written after launching the
browser go to this rc server and then to
the actual web server so it routes all
the commands are getting routed through
your rc server to your web browser upon
receiving this instruction so what does
a code do it executes these commands as
the javascript commands on your browser
so once these are executed the response
from the browser or the results what you
say are sent back to the rc server and
rc server is responsible for sending it
back to your test and then the test
results are displayed here now if you
see this complete cycle from starting
your command from your test script
talking to the rc server then rc server
talks to the web browser it injects the
javascript here runs your command takes
back the results sends it to rc server
and then back to this test script this
whole cycle gets repeated for every
command which is written in your test
script and this is how your test case
gets executed all right so now
everything is fine so great we are
unable to run the scripts we are able to
launch the browser we are able to
execute all the commands so what was the
problem here why was still rc not good
enough for the reason why the rc was
still not good enough was one the
architecture of rc is very complicated
because of that intermediate rc server
to communicate with the browser so there
is no indirect interaction with the
browser this rc server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts that means it has an additional
setup because that is rc server is a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser the execution of the
commands takes very long time it is very
slow why because we saw that every
command written in your test clips needs
to make a full trip from your test
script to the rc server to the core to
the browser and then back which makes
your overall automation test execution
very very slow so how the selenium
webdriver now overcomes this this is a
simple architecture of selenium
webdriver even in web driver we have
test scripts we have a web browser and a
web server however we do not have an
additional server for communication like
the rc server which we saw in the
selenium rc this makes the architecture
of webdriver very simple the selenium
webdriver that's one of the biggest
advantages the selenium webdriver does
not use an additional server then
secondly it makes direct calls to your
browser using your browser's native
support automation so since there is no
intermediate server there the browser is
controlled directly from the operating
system level itself now due to this
direct communication the overall the
trips what we saw from the rc server to
the browser and from the browser back to
the rc server and to the test script
right this was an indirect communication
since this whole thing was avoided the
speed of test execution is much faster
in rc and this overall architecture of
the web driver if you see it is much
much simpler than what the rc provides
so this was the major drawback from the
rc and this is where webdriver replaced
rc now was that all because of the
architecture no there were few other
shortcomings with the rc api is in
selenium rc a single function has
several commands redundant and confusing
api rc is less object oriented api
though there are good set of apis to
work with they are pretty redundant and
confusing for example how and when to
use a type key or a type command another
example is the mouse commands click or
to use click at or when to use mouse at
or mouse stop so this was getting pretty
confusing for the developers and to top
it all this every browser interprets the
command differently which makes your
test cases brittle when it has to work
on the multiple process developers had a
tough time making their scripts cross
browser and they had to add browser
specific code whereas selenium driver
comes with a set of more matured and
simpler api which are pretty
straightforward to use for example a
simple click to simulate a click action
on any web element send keys which
simply means send the text to any web
element on your web page scroll up or
down on the web page and so on so we
will see more of this commands when we
actually start working with the web
driver another difference is the browser
support though both rc and webdriver
supports multiple browser rc does not
have support for html unit which is a
headless browser whereas the web driver
supports testing on headless browser now
what is the settlers browser headless
browser is a browser which does not have
a ui it makes testing much faster
because it does not need a real browser
for testing now to summarize all this so
if you look at the rc and the web driver
comparison which we talked about rc is a
complex architecture whereas webdriver
has a simple architecture for the main
reason that webdriver removed the need
of having an intermediate server rc the
execution of your test cases or your
automation scripts is much slower than
the web driver rca requires a rc server
to interact with the browser whereas the
selenium web driver interacts with the
browser directly using the web drivers
also we saw the apis which rc provides
which are pretty confusing and web
drivers we have much easier and easy to
use apis no support for html unit
browser which is a headlight browser
selenium driver also provides support
for html unit browser now that we have
understood what selenium rc is and why
webdriver replaced rc let's go another
level deeper into webdriver so what is
selenium webdriver we know that the
webdriver in its simplest term is a tool
or a programming interface to create and
execute test cases on a web application
it supports multiple browsers ie firefox
chrome opera safari edge and it also has
support for headless browser so we will
know in some time what is in headless
browser some of the features of
webdriver so while rc was introduced in
2004 web driver got introduced by simon
stewart in 2006. webdriver can run on
any platform of your choice linux
windows mac and even if you have a
ubuntu machine you can run your selenium
web drive and what is this actual web
driver is it an ide no it is a simply
and programming interface to run your
test cases and how does it work the test
cases are created and executed using web
elements or the objects using web
locators and webdriver methods so once
we get into the demo or once you start
understanding how selenium works you
will understand what are these webdriver
methods and the locating techniques
which are used to perform these actions
on web element selenium webdriver is
pretty fast why since the web driver
interacts directly with the browser and
does not have an intermediate server
like rc each browser with which you want
to work with has its own driver on which
your application runs and this driver is
responsible to make the browser
understand the command which are being
passed from your script like a click of
button or entering some text in any of
the input fields through your scripts
you tell which browser you want to work
with say you want to do all this action
say on the chrome browser if you want to
work with chrome browser then the chrome
driver is responsible for interpreting
your instructions from your test case
and executing them on the web
application which is launched on chrome
browser earlier so like rc webdriver
also supports multi-programming
languages in which you can write your
test scripts like the ones which are
listed here also webdriver supports
different frameworks like test ng junit
and n unit when we talk about the
limitations of webdriver you will
appreciate how the support for various
frameworks and tools help in making the
selenium a complete automation solution
for web application now let's try to
know what is the architecture of
selenium webdriver webdriver has four
different components in it one we have
the client libraries or what is also
called as language binding since i said
selenium supports multiple languages and
you are free to use any of the supported
languages to create your automation
script there are libraries available on
selenium website which you need to
download and use them let me show you
that so let's go to my chrome browser so
i have the selenium hq website already
launched here so guys if you're working
on selenium this website selenium hq dot
org is going to be bible so everything
and whatever you need to know and work
with selenium is available here for now
we want to see the client library so the
language binding so for that what you
need to do is if you go to the download
section here can you see the selenium
client and web driver language binding
so for each of the languages which is
supported you have a client library
which you can download from here so if
you're working on java you need to
download the java libraries if you're
working on python you need to download
the python libraries right so these are
called as language bindings so selenium
provides lot of aps for us to interact
with the browsers and when we do the
demo i will be showing some of those
apis now what are these abs these apis
are the rest apis rest is
representational stateful aps and
everything for selenium happens to this
rest calls the second component is the
json wire protocol so what is json
javascript object notation and it's a
standard for exchanging data over the
web so for example you want to launch a
web application through your script so
what selenium does is it creates a json
payload and post the request to the
browser driver right and where are this
browser driver these are here right and
what are these browser drivers these are
a driver specific to each browser so if
you see here you can see drivers for
chrome firefox opera safari and edge
right so we interact with the actual
browsers here using these drivers and
how does this happen this driver
establishes connection with the real
browser without revealing the internal
logic of browser functionality right
that's exactly the function of this
browser driver now what does that mean
let's say we want to execute a test
script so what happens when the script
is executed is an http request is
generated and sent to browser driver for
each command in the script and then the
driver receives the request through this
http server and does all the execution
on the actual browser once the execution
is done the execution results are just
sent back over the same http server to
your test scripts so this is the
simplest form of the architecture of the
selenium webdriver well now as every
tool has its own advantages and its
limitations so let's look at what
selenium limited webdriver limitations
are cannot test mobile applications
requires framework like apm selenium is
for automatic web application it cannot
handle mobile right mobile applications
are different and they have its own set
of automation tools however what
selenium provides is the support for
integrating this apm tool apm tool is
one of the popular tools for mobile
application automation right so it
provides a support for integrating apm
tool so using apm and selenium you can
still achieve mobile application
automation now when do you usually use
this in cases where say your application
under test is also supported on mobile
devices so that means you need a
mechanism to run your test cases on your
web browser as well as your mobile
browsers right and this is how you
achieve it using selenium when we talked
about components of selenium i said that
the web driver can achieve only
sequential execution but in real time we
know that we just cannot live with this
we need to have a parallel execution on
multiple machines and on multiple
process so this limitation of webdriver
is replaced by having the grid which
helps us in achieve the parallel
execution and do check out our video on
more details on selenium grid selenium
webdriver has limited reporting
capability it can help create basic
reports but definitely we need more
especially when we are working on a big
project we need good reports to be
created so what it does is we have a
support for multiple tools like test ng
report ng and even the extent reports
which you can integrate with selenium
and generate beautiful reports isn't it
really powerful all right there's
another challenge what we have these are
amongst few of the challenges what i
have put across here there are other
challenges also but always there is a
workaround to get through this challenge
so another challenge which we have
mentioned here is selenium is not very
good with image testing especially
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium to achieve
any kind of image testing you want to do
like auto it and securely so same way
the way it provides a mechanism to
integrate apm so selenium also provides
a way for integrating auto and the
security tools so if you look at all
this selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium that makes
it most powerful tool today for
automation okay so let's look at
webdriver in action so before we do that
let's understand some of the basic
browser commands and functions that we
will be using in our demo today the get
commands so there are six get commands
to perform various actions on the
browser driver.get
this is used to launch any website
application it takes a string argument
and this needs to be a fully formed url
which you want to launch driver.gettitle
so this method fetches the title of the
webpage which you're working with so for
example let's go to ebay so if you just
hover your mouse here can you see the
text there electronics cars fashion
collectibles coupons and more ebay so
this is nothing but title of this
current pitch and this command helps us
to get the title get current url so to
get the url of any page is when you want
to use this command so this will be used
especially when you're working with
multiple web pages and you want to say
print whatever the current url you're
working on on the console get page
source this method dumps the complete
html page source on your console
actually this is not really much used
unless you really need to look at
anything in your html pages and then
there are two more get commands related
to windows handles these are used for
handling multiple tabs and multiple
windows on the browser now we will not
be dealing with this in today's demo
however if you want to know the details
of this command these are available in
our video tutorials for this commands
the next set of commands are the
navigational commands so these are self
explanatory and basically are used to
navigate between the multiple pages of
your web application the first one the
driver.navigate.2
is very similar to driver.get so both
does the same function and then you have
navigate dot back navigate got forward
and navigate dot refresh so this is used
for refreshing your browser page and
then there are two commands browser
commands which we use one is the
driver.close so this closes the current
browser window so if you have got
multiple tabs opened in the window and
you want to close a particular tab so
that is when you use driver.close and
driver.quit what it does it quits the
entire browser session then there are
few other commands and
these some of the commands are listed
here however if you see there is a huge
list of commands available in selenium
and since we'll be using just a few of
them in today's demo i have listed here
so let's just understand these very
basic commands which we will be using
driver dot find element now when you
want to work with any application what
is that you need to do you need to
perform actions on the elements of the
web page and these are called as web
elements for example let's go to our
ebay dot in so on this website say you
want to search for jbl speakers and what
do you do when you want to search for
this you would identify the search box
and you will enter the text jbl speakers
right and then you go ahead and click on
the search button so this is the set of
operations which you will do now for us
to write this and this is exactly what
you need to do through your commands for
us to really write this text as jbl
speakers i need to know what this
particular element is okay so this
particular input box is my web element
which i need to identify similarly if i
want to click on the search button i
need to identify what this button is and
that's exactly is done by using
driver.find element selenium has
multiple ways of finding these elements
it has eight element locating techniques
and our future videos on selenium do
cover these eight element locating
techniques very much in detail so for us
right now we will be using couple of
them so one is with id and one is with a
link text the next one the send keys so
as the name indicates it is used to send
a certain text to any web element you
have identified or you want to work with
like in this example as i said since we
want to search for jbl speakers right i
would be basically sending the text jbl
speakers to this web element using send
keys click so after entering the text
what we need to do i said we need to
click on the search button so for all
such actions we have methods defined in
selenium and one of them is this click
what this does is it just clicks on the
web element or the button which we want
to work with so now with these basic
commands let's go ahead and start
writing our code for our test case so
what is the test case we are going to
write today so this is my use case today
so use case 1 as a user i want to log to
ebay application search for jbl speakers
and then i want to check the today's
team so there is something called as the
days deal we will go and click on that
and see what are the deals available i
have another use case here what says is
from this website from wherever we are
right navigate to the simply learn
website and navigate back to the ebay.
so this using this use case 2 what i
want to show you is how do we use the
navigational commands and my third use
cases from the ebay.in i want to print
the page title and close the browser so
with this we are trying to demonstrate
at least few commands from each of the
categories which we talked about so i
will be using eclipse for writing our
test scripts and if you want to know how
to get started with selenium how do we
install selenium you can refer to our
videos on installation of selenium by
simply done okay let me go to my eclipse
so in eclipse what i have done is i have
already created a project called
selenium demo and in this project i have
gone ahead and created a java class in
which we will be writing our test case
so the java class which i have created
is ebay search dot java and also what i
have done is if you look at few import
statements here i have imported all the
required selenium jars here so if you
look here in the referenced libraries
the way after we you work with java here
right so java is the prereq for your
eclipse so you already have the java
libraries available here so what i need
to do is i also need to import the
selenium jar phase and this is the list
of selvium jar files which you will need
to work with the saline and this i've
already imported for you then another
thing what i do as following a best
practice is instead of writing all my
code under this main function here what
i do is i create methods for each of the
use case or the test case which i am
writing so same thing i am going to do
that today for all the use cases which
we have taken for this demo now lets get
started so what is the first thing which
we need to do the first thing what we
need to do is you need to declare your
web driver so which i've already done
here i've said web driver driver and
then i need to launch the browser before
even i go into ebay dot in and start
performing the other testing now for me
to launch browser this is one method
which i've already written here so let
me walk you through this so there are
multiple steps we need to follow for
launching the browser the first thing is
set system property so let's understand
this particular command here the one
which i have highlighted so this is used
to set the property for your gecko
driver now what is a gecko driver if you
remember while we are talking of
webdriver architecture i said for
whichever browser you want to work with
you need to tell the web driver as which
browser is what you're going to test
with and in my case here i'm going to be
using firefox browser and also if you
remember while explaining the
architecture i said every browser every
browser has its own driver which you
need to download and install and where
is this driver let's go ahead and see
that on the selenium hq dot org so let
me go to my chrome browser i already
have a selenium hq dot org website open
here now on this website in the download
section if you go down you can see
something called as third party drivers
binding and plugins and here you would
see a list of all browsers gecko driver
chrome opera edge right and html unit
which is headless browser so all these
browsers with selenium supports listed
and for each of this browser we have a
driver associated with it which we can
download so if i want a gig driver what
i need to do is i need to click on this
latest link this will take me to the
latest web driver which is available so
depending on the operating system which
you're using right now i'm using a mac
so i've already downloaded it so once
you download you need to place it in a
particular directory so let us go back
to this and now if you see this path
here what i'm highlighting this is where
i have kept my gecko driver so this
gecko driver what you see is my
executable so if you are using using a
windows machine it will be
geckodriver.exe so this is the driver
which should be working with now coming
back to the system.set property this
particular method or this particular
command is used to set your driver
property it is a key value pair and you
will need to know which keys depending
on the which browsers you are working
with since i am working on the firefox
browser the key which i need to set is
the webdriver gecko.driver if i'm using
chrome what i simply do is i have a key
called chrome and then i would set this
path to chrome driver and this is
exactly you need to do so for you to
even before launch the browser you need
to do this set property so let me change
this back to gecko so now we are clear
till here now what is the next command
which we need to after setting the
property is after setting the property
you have to instantiate the web driver
which is done by using this particular
command driver is equal to new firefox
driver so once you do this your browser
is going to get launched then once your
browser is launched what is the next
step you do you would be launching the
application on which you want to perform
your test and that is done by using the
command which we just saw now driver dot
get now since i'm going to be working
with ebay dot in i have just said driver
dot get and the url fully formed url so
this particular method is going to help
me launch the firefox browser and also
launch the ebay application now
advantage of using methods like this is
you can reuse this methods in every test
case which you are going to write or you
can make a common function of this and
just call this function in any of your
test cases now for me to call this
method what am i going to do i am going
to create an object of this class let's
do that object is equal to newton and
then i need to call this method obj dot
launch browser good so far all right so
now let's get to the first use case so
let's go back to our presentation and
see what was our first use case our
first use case was that we want to
launch the ebay application which we
have already done in the launch browser
method and then we want to search for
jbl speakers now for that what we will
do let me create a method here so i will
call this method i'll say public void
say
search product that's my method name so
i have created a method called search
product now what i need to do is i need
to search for jbl speakers so for that
let me go to my firefox browser and i
need to first identify the search box
element so for identifying what i do i
go to this website i go to this element
and then i say inspect element so now i
know that there is already an id which
is unique to this particular web element
available so i'm going to make use of
this id i need to go to my eclipse so
now here i'm going to use the find
element method so for that i'll say
driver dot find element i'll say by dot
id and it's a string argument i'll just
copy the id which i copied from the
firefox browser and then what is the
operation i need to do here i need to
send keys and what is the keys i need to
send the product which i am searching
for i am searching for say jbl speakers
done so with this command what it will
do is it will enter the text jbl
speakers in the search box after doing
this i need to click on the search
button now similarly i need to identify
what is the web element search for this
again i already have a unique id here
which i'm just going to simply copy from
here and use it in the find elements so
same thing i will do driver dot find
element by dot id and this is the id of
the button and here what is my operation
i need to click done good so far now
other thing what we also need to
understand here is so what happens
sometimes depending on the website some
websites are pretty slow even by loading
the page and some are pretty fast now
for the selenium to work without having
to fail or without having to create
exception of not finding the elements it
is good to use certain weights so why we
need to use weights say for example when
after entering the jbl speakers and
after clicking the button it's going to
take a while for it to search for jbl
speakers and give us that webpage with
the list of jpm speakers and even before
we start doing the first command like
searching once we load the page it takes
time for the complete page to get loaded
so selenium provides lot of
synchronization commands right and it's
a very big topic on its own which needs
to be used especially when you're
working with any kind of website okay so
there is a since it's a separate topic
there's a separate video which will help
you understand how to use the
synchronization now for the demo purpose
we have certain weight commands which
can be used and that is exactly which i
am going to use here so that is called
as thread dot sleep so what this does is
say i am going to give 2000 here what
this does is this basically this script
waits for two second right after the
previous command is executed and then it
executes your next command which is our
find element now this is showing us an
exception because it wants us to add a
exception here add throws declaration
which is interrupted exception okay we
need to do this so once we are done okay
we have done the click so let's see what
is the first use case which we had have
we covered everything in the first use
case okay we said log in to ebay done
search for jbl speakers and then i want
to check on the days d we need to do
this also so for that again what we need
to do is we need to go and identify so
what i will do i'll use the inspector
here and look for this daily deals now
this is a link text it's an anchor tag
so what i will do i'll copy this link
text daily deals i'll go to my eclipse
now after this i will give another
thread dot sleep of say two seconds that
should be more than enough and then i'll
say driver dot find element now this
time i will be using something called as
linked text and here as an argument as a
parameter i am going to paste the daily
d's which i just copied and then what do
i need to do on this web element i just
need to do a click operation done so the
complete first use case we have covered
so what we will do is let's go ahead and
execute this first use case now i have
launched the browser here i also need to
call this method which is search product
now again here since we are
doing that add through declaration on
the method we also need to do it for the
main function exception added i'll save
this and for me to run this what i do is
i simply right click on that and i say
run as java application now we see that
our firefox browser is launched the ebay
application is also launched and jbl
speakers entered and search clicked so
we have a list of jbl speakers here and
now as per our test case it has to go on
the daily days which it just did great
all right so we have our first use case
working so right now i have not used the
browser.close so what i will do is i'll
just manually go and close this browser
so we are done with our first use case
now let's move to our second use case so
what second use case says is from
wherever you are right now we are on the
eb ebay dot in navigate to simply learn
website and then navigate back to ebay.
so let's see how to handle that so let's
go back to my eclipse here now let's
create another method instead of saying
test case 2 or use case 2 will give a
more meaningful name i'll say navigate
since we are exercising the navigates
command navigate commands here i'll just
use this method now so we have done the
click so i need a quick thread dot sleep
here because i want it to wait so that
we can see otherwise it's going to be so
fast we will not be able to see what are
the operations in it so i'll just add a
thread dot sleep before we start
navigating to the new website okay
thread dot sleep and i guess two seconds
should be good enough even here so same
thing we need to add the exception so
add throws declaration and interrupted
exception all right done so now what we
need to do is we need to navigate to the
simplylearn.com so for that first i need
a fully formed url of the website which
i want to launch okay so let me go to
and here instead of ebay dot in i would
say let's search for simply learn i have
it here and i just pick this from here
https
www.simplylearn.com so let me go to my
eclipse and here we saw another command
like get we said navigate dot 2 so let's
use the same command so i'll say driver
dot navigate dot 2 and i'm going to use
two url because or you can just use a
string because this is going to be a
string variable now what does this
command do this will simply navigate to
the url which we have specified here now
here again i'm going to give a quick
sleep here so that we are able to see
that website before we navigate back to
the ebay. so i'll use a thread.sleep
this time probably i'll give a three
second wait then what does our use case
say let's go back to use case once and
check and it says and navigate back to
ebay dot l so that means i need to use a
driver dot navigate dot can you see the
list of commands here which provide for
which the navigate class provides okay
and the back is what we need to use so
that it comes back to the ebay dot done
so far so good now let's do one thing
before even we go to the use case three
let's execute our test case still here
so what i'll do i'll save this program
and after search product i will call
navigate method okay i will save this
and then right click run as java
application so our firefox is getting
launched it has launched the ebay
application is on so it's going to first
find the jbl speakers click on the
search we have a list of jbl speakers
then it will click on the daily deals
yes it is doing that we got the deals of
the day yes it is now navigating to
simplylearn.com now after three seconds
it should take me back to the ebay dot
it okay cool so this was the last page
where we left before we navigated to
simply right and that is where we have
come back using the back command so now
let me close this again because i have
still not incorporated the driver.close
now let's look at the use case 3. now
use case 3 says once you're back to
ebay.in print the page title and then
close the browser cool very simple so
we'll go back to eclipse probably in the
same method what i can do is once i'm
back here i will say so i have to use
driver dot get title that was a spelling
mistake driver dot get title okay this
is the method which we are going to use
to get the title of the page now we also
said that once we get the page title we
want to print it on the console now how
do you print it on console you just use
a sis out statement so instead of just
writing this what i will do is i'll
directly write a sis out statement
system.out.println
and i'll write a text as the title of
this page is and then we will
concatenate with driver dot get title as
simple as that and after i do this i
will simply call it's actually i want to
call the driver.list but it's always
good to create a separate method so i'll
say public void close browser method and
here i'll simply say driver dot quit you
can use close or you can use quit so let
me demonstrate how do we use twitter now
i need to call the close browser so
simply what i'll do i'll say obj dot
close browser method okay so this
completes our all three use cases so now
let's execute all these three use cases
now and we should be able to see the
title of this page on the console so
same thing what i do is right click run
as java application okay same thing our
ebay is launched now send keys the jbl
speakers click on search button executed
and then it has to click on the daily
deals that it is done moves to simply
learn website now it has to come back to
ebay.n and we should be able to see the
close process which just happened at the
snap of the finger right now for us to
know whether it really happened what we
have done is we have printed the page
title okay now can you see here we have
the complete page title printed here all
right so let's go back so let's look at
what are the key takeaways from that so
in this overall video we saw what was
selenium what is selenium web driver
what was the limitation of the remote
control which is selenium rc how did
webdriver replaced it and we went into
learning the architecture of the
selenium webdriver which is very
important for us to understand because
we will be working with the web driver
to create all our automation scripts and
then as i said every tool has its own
limitation we also talked about
limitations at a very high level and
also as there are workarounds and then i
also demo some of the browser apis and
the usages and some of the methods which
we use with selenium this video focuses
on teaching how to use selenium ide for
creating automation scripts what does
this video cover one a brief about
selenium and where the ide actually fits
in very recently a new version of ide
has been launched so we will look at
what it has to offer how does the record
and replay tool work and then let's
understand the components of this id
interface we will work with few commonly
used selenium commands and then since we
are using the new ide let's look at some
of the key features of the selenium id
and like every tool has its own
limitations we will also look at what
are the limitations of selenium id so
what is selenium so selenium is an
automated testing tool used to test web
applications across various browsers in
my previous video where we have covered
the complete basics of selenium
webdriver i have explained each and
every components of the selenium suite
so selenium ide is one of the components
in the selenium suite and other
components of the suite are selenium rc
web driver and selenium grid so in this
video we will be looking in detail about
how the selenium id works so what is
selenium id selenium ide was developed
way back in 2006. it was created to
facilitate a simple record and replay of
the test automation so record and replay
tools were pretty much invoked during
this time and the main advantage of
using such tool was an automation
engineer was not really required to know
any knowledge of programming he could
just use this record replay tool and
create the automation and this ide was
available as a firefox extension so for
one to use it you need to just go ahead
and install the extension on firefox and
then use its recording and record the
steps of your test execution it is a
very simple interface which helps in
building the automation scripts and how
this works you just need to start the
recording on id perform your test steps
on the browser and these steps gets
recorded in the script and then what you
could do is you could export the script
into say a web driver or a junit ruby or
any javascripts and then you can use it
now however the record and replay tool
is not a very powerful automation tool
and hence this ide is mainly used for
prototyping or you could say demo
purpose now since selenium webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust test scripts ide more
or less remains as a prototyping tool
only so in short as i said ide is a part
of overall selenium set of tools and
mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases and what is the
other advantage of that one need not
really have any programming knowledge to
use this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick test for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium id back in 2017 selenium id
development was completely stopped the
last supported firefox version where
this ide was available as a plugin was
firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was remote or
it was completely broken however
recently apply tools help revamp much of
the selenium id code they basically
rewrote the whole ide code and then now
they have released a new version under
the apache 2.0 license and it is
completely managed by the selenium
community now let's look at some of the
features of this now traditionally the
selenium id was only a firefox plugin
however the new ide supports both the
browsers the chrome and the firefox and
thus making it cross browser so before
even we start looking at the other
features of the selenium id i would like
to show you how do we install this
firefox plugin or the chrome extension
so for that let me go to my chrome
browser so in the chrome browser what
i'll simply do is i'll search for
selenium id for chrome so then let's go
to this chrome.google.com
and here you will see it as an extension
selenium id so go ahead click on add to
chrome so this will add this extension
to your chrome browser so now it says
selenium id has been added to the crew
so how do you make out if it is added so
you can see this particular icon here
which says selenium id so this is the
way you can go ahead and install it on
the chrome now on the firefox i have
already installed it since we want to
use the firefox as a browser for all the
demos in this video so here again you
can see the selenium id so if i click on
this ide it is going to open a window
for me and the first window when it
opens it says either open a new project
or open an existing project or simply
you can start recording a new test case
in which case it creates a default
project for you first so what i will do
is i'll say open an existing project and
i've already got a project created so
let me go to my folder where i have this
project so i have this project created
and i've opened it i also have a simple
test case written now what this test
case does is let me show you here it
simply goes to google.com and then here
what i'm doing is i'm searching for
selenium hq documentation and then i
click on this site which says
seleniumhq.org and docs so which should
take us to this particular website where
the documentation is available so this
is a simple script which i have tried to
write it in this id so let's keep both
this windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of the selenium id the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality what are locators so these
are nothing but the techniques used for
locating your web elements on your
website now for example in our
example here now the type here the type
which says name equal to q so name equal
to q is a locator now this is a locator
of what initially if you saw i went to
google.com and this is the search button
which i used right the search text and
then i said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is name equal to q now what happens in
id is when you recorded it has taken the
attribute name and it is recognized this
particular web element using this
attribute however it also has a feature
wherein it also records its multiple
locators available for that particular
web element for example it also has a
css locator it has an expat locator now
how does it help here say for example
tomorrow this particular attribute name
right for the search box if it changes
then what id does is when you execute
this test script it falls back on your
other locators mentioned here in the
structure and then if none of this
locators work only then the test case is
going to go and fail not otherwise so
how does this help this helps to make
the test cases more robust otherwise
having just one locator there is high
possibility that test case might break
or become pretty brittle as and when the
web elements change their attributes so
this is what the locating techniques are
and that is how they have improved the
locator techniques in the
functionality in the new id now what's
the next one parallel execution is
possible with this new id so the first
id the traditional one the parallel
execution was not possible however this
is a new feature which has been added so
we will be looking in detail how to work
with this parallel execution later in
this video next is you can add control
statements in your scripts now what are
these control statements like if else
while loops for each loops and even the
switch case the earlier ide also had
this provision but you had to install a
plugin to enable the use of this control
statements and now with this new id it
is available out of box automatically
waits for page to load in any automation
synchronization between your application
under test and your automation scripts
is very important your script should not
run faster than your application
otherwise your scripts are going to
start failing so it is necessary to have
enter float times on the operations
of your web elements and also enough
load times on your page now this low
time ensures that all the elements of
your web pages and the page itself is
loaded completely before even a single
line of script is run this new id takes
care of providing that enough uh wait
time and also you have a global set
speed option which you can
use to control your execution of your
scripts so that is something which i
will show you now so if i go back to
this so can you see this clock icon here
so it says test execution speed so what
you can do is right now it is set to the
fastest so i can actually control the
execution speed here so right now i've
just kept it a little slower so let's
see how our test scripts run so you'll
be able to see a remarkable difference
when i slow down the complete speed of
this so now do you see how slow it is
initially when i ran it you are unable
to see what i entered in the search
field of the google right so now it's
clearly taking time on each of the steps
which we have mentioned there so now it
is executed successfully so next it
supports embedded code you can run a
simple java script from your test script
right and how do you run that by using a
simple command called as execute now
let's see how do we do that so let's
take the same example here now after
clicking this okay so this is our id so
what i will do is i'll first execute
this test case and then in the end where
i will show you how do we add a simple
javascript and do some function so
let me get the speed back to a little
normal because we do not want to waste
too much time so i'll just play the
script once so now we are in the
selenium documentation now if you look
at this page this is a pretty long one
so now i'm going to write a simple
javascript wherein i scroll down towards
the end of this page that's all i'm
going to do now for me to do that what i
can do is in my script itself i can just
add another line here okay here i will
say add a new command
here i'll say execute script which is my
command and what is the script which i
want to execute it's a java script which
i'm going to write here i'll say window
dot scroll by and i'm just going to
mention some coordinates here start from
0 and i'll say 1 5 0 0 okay this is all
my code is and now i'll simply run this
test again let's see what happens so
it's going to the documentation now it's
clicked on the link okay let's move down
do you see this initially it was right
here on the top of the page and once the
javascript was executed it brought me
somewhere to the middle of this page
that is how you can insert a snippets of
javascript and it has to be in context
with your currently selected window okay
and that's how you run it all right
let's go back to our ppt okay what's the
next feature so every ide has a debugger
which allows step execution adding of
breakpoints now apart from just having a
break points or adding the step
execution there is another feature which
it provides called i will show you that
which is called as pause on exception so
let's close this window and let's just
keep this id window open here right so
can you you see here pause button it
says pause on exception so what it does
is if you enable this button okay and
when you're running the script so if at
all there happens to be an exception in
your script it stops the execution at
that particular exception field and we
will see this in detail when we look at
complete debugger for the id can be
integrated in ci since you can execute
scripts from command line right we also
talked about the parallel execution and
you can also export the scripts to any
of the programming language you want so
since you can do that these scripts can
be run from command line and hence they
can also be integrated with your maven
project and through jenkins you can run
it and that's how you achieve your ci
working principle of selenium id
selenium id works on a very very simple
principle one is the recording it
records user interactions with the
browser and which forms basically your
id script and using this id script which
is a recorded script you execute the
script and verify and monitor for its
stability and success rate and thirdly
what you can do is you can simply save
your recorded script for your future
runs or regression testing and these
scripts can be saved either in the form
of an id project itself or you can also
export these test scripts into the form
of a javascript or your ruby scripts or
even the web driver scripts now let's
look at the components of this id
interface itself the first one is the
menu bar so let's go back to our id
window so here in the menu bar what you
can see is is a project name so either
you can edit the project name here or
you can simply create a new project open
an existing project and save the current
project so these are all the options
available and since we have already
created a project here i will not be
showing how to create a new project so
that we can do it little later now next
one is the toolbar so this is the
toolbar what we have here for the id now
there are multiple components in the
toolbar so let's see one by one so it
says run all test now if you have
multiple test cases written okay so this
is an option where all the tests can be
run one after the other this is to run
your current test which the focus is on
so currently our focus is on search test
so if i click on this button it is going
to execute the search test for me ide
has this debugger option where you can
do a step execution right you can do
step by step execution using this option
we'll see how to do that for example
let's say we start from here okay and i
click on this so what it does is
basically it has just executed the first
step for me so let's keep this side by
side so that we can observe the complete
execution now if i go and press on this
again step over current command so that
is the next command it is going to
execute now it says type into this all
right so now you can see the selenium hq
documentation okay then again i say step
send keys which it basically it said
enter and then it is going to click on
that documentation which it did and now
we have a script written which scrolls
down on this particular page so let's
execute that and that is what it is so
this is how the step execution happens
so let's close this window and let's
come back to our id window then we have
buttons here where you can say record or
you can stop recording okay then you can
pause the execution and then there are
other options available for disabling
breakpoints so basically you can add
breakpoints any barrier so for example
if i want to add a breakpoint on the
click here so what i have to just do is
i have to just click here so this adds a
breakpoint and if you want to remove all
the spraypoint you just say disable
those breakpoints so when you run the
script even though you have a breakpoint
available here for that particular run
your breakpoint will be disabled and
your execution will not stop at this
point and let's enable them for now and
what we will do is we'll just run the
script until there so now it has stopped
here at this click now from here either
you can execute the rest of the test
case by just clicking on this run button
or you can stop the execution okay so
for now what we'll do is we'll just stop
the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red which means that this particular
line was not executed or it failed
either of the things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component let's come back here
so we saw the menu bar here we saw the
toolbar we saw start and stop of
recording address bar now what is this
address bar so this address bar is where
you actually write your url from where
you want to start your recording and as
in when you start writing more and more
test cases it keeps a complete history
of all the websites which you are
working on next then we have a test
script editor box which is this so let
me just minimize this little bit okay
this is nothing but your test script
editor box and this is where all your
script steps are all your interactions
are recorded now there are four
attributes in this okay can you see a
command now command is nothing but the
actual operation or the action performed
on your web element so there are
multiple actions you can perform like in
this case we have something called as
open we have got type we have got send
keys and we have got clicks so these are
all the selenium commands which are
available and then we have something
called as target now this target is
nothing but the web element on which you
want to perform the action and now this
target as i said earlier also it is
identified by multiple locating
techniques and if you click on any of
this like we looked at the name here now
similarly the website which we are
clicking on if you look at it there are
multiple locating techniques which are
available here so the one right now
which is being used is the css
identifier you can also have xpath here
which is a relative x bar so these are
all the locating techniques and this is
where which is applied on the target
value so value is an optional field so
you can send any value to your web
element for example in this case where
we are sending the value which is our
text which is selenium hq dot
documentation so this is the value which
i want to send it to as a search text to
my google.com and then comment or the
description so here you can mention any
description about that particular line
which you have recorded for example i
can say here sending search text to the
google search input box and this gets
recorded here against your uh
instruction now let's look at the test
case pane now test case pane that is
here so if you look here now it contains
all the test cases which you have
recorded now there are multiple things
here one is your tests so i can always
go ahead and create another to say uh
test case two okay i can add a few more
test case here test case three so all
these test cases are here now i can also
have a test suite now there is already
test suite which i have created which is
called the google suite and now if i
want to add test cases under this what i
can do is i can just say add tests and
now i can add any of this test which i
just created under this test suite so
say i have selected the first three and
i've added it so we have test suite we
have tests here and then executing so
executing is basically it shows the
particular test case which is currently
in the execution mode so whichever test
case we run you will see all the test
cases listed here which have been
executed at that point of time that is
your test case pane and then we have
test log and reference this is a very
important window which you need to be
aware of now here this is a running lock
so as in when you are going to run your
test cases the every instruction the
every test step as and when it runs it
is going to log here whether it is
passed whether it has failed whether the
command was executed properly or not and
this is how it records it it's a running
law also there is something called as
reference tag now for example just go
ahead and ah let's select one of this
command which you have written here so
which is send keys now this reference it
will show you the complete description
of the command and how to use that
command so say for click it says
references click locator clicks on the
target element it gives you a complete
detail of what exactly the command does
let's create a test script now for say
amazon.com so let's go back to our id
what we will do is we'll create a
completely new project so let's i'll
click on the create new project are you
sure you would like to without saving it
yes proceed further and let's give the
name as amazon project now in this new
project what i will do is i'll say i'll
add a test and my test name is search
iphone now basically what is the use
case which i'm going to automate i will
launch amazon.com and i will search for
iphones and once i get the iphones let's
verify the title of that particular page
now we just the simple steps will go
ahead and do that so for that first what
i need to do is i need to enter the url
now this url needs to be a fully formula
so for that what i will do i'll first
launch amazon dot in on any browser i'll
just copy this url and i can close this
browser window and in this url address
space i would say amazon.com and i'll
say enter and now i would click on this
recording button which says start
recording so once i do this what it does
is it launches the web page with
amazon.com and from there i can start
recording my script so let's do that
i'll say record it so
let me just keep this window side by
side so that you can see what is
happening on the id window here now here
what i will do is i'll click on the
search and i'll say iphone and i will
click on the search button and here i
will also click on this best seller once
i'm in this window i'll say right click
now when your selenium id is in the
recording mode you will get this option
here which says selenium id and there
are a lot of options here which you can
select now for this particular moment
what i want to do is i want to assert
the title so i'll just put an assertion
point here for assert title and then i
will close my browser window now let's
see what are all the commands which it
has recorded let's go one by one right
so it is done it is opening the amazon
dot in it is setting the window size
fine it clicked on the to search window
button and then iphone is what you are
searching and then it said submit it
it's basically clicking on that button
and then we said we also want to open
the best seller link and here is our
asset title right so it's a very simple
test so let's go ahead and execute this
now since i also have a close command
here this script is going to execute so
fast that you will not be able to make
out all the steps what we have written
so for that what i will do i will
comment out the slide now how do you
comment out any command here just select
the command and can you see here enable
and disable command just click on it so
now your command is disabled also what i
will do is i will reduce the execution
speed so that you should be able to see
exactly what is happening so let's go
ahead and execute this test first so
i'll say run current test okay i have
not stopped the recording so that is the
first thing after closing the window i
also need to click on the stop recording
now your script is ready to be executed
so let's go and run the current script
again i'll just bring this side by side
so that you can see each of these
commands being executed here okay it has
searched for the iphone it's clicked on
the best sellers and it has done the
title assertion now if you look at the
log here as i said see every step as in
when it was executed it has been logged
here can you see here and it puts an
okay and it color coded in green which
says that this particular command was
executed successfully now let's go ahead
now this is what we did by simply
recording all the steps from the browser
now one more thing what we will do is
say i want to continue recording here
right i'm not completed my test case so
what you can still do here is you can
come towards the end of the script and
press on record button again and then
you can continue recording from here now
say for example after the bestsellers
what we have got say i want to click on
say hot releases or new releases so i do
that okay it says it has recorded the
click and then i want to stop the
recording just the another step is what
i wanted to add now it has stopped the
recording so can you see this new line
which has got added so that means you
really need not restart recording all
the steps again if you want to add
something in the middle of your script
you can always go towards the end of the
script or anywhere in between and you
can add more commands there or you can
record anywhere in between the script
and that is how this does so let's go
ahead and again execute this then i will
show you another feature of this okay
it's done the title assertion now and it
has also clicked on hot new releases
done now let's say for example i need to
add another command here now instead of
going ahead and using this recording
what i will do is i will manually add
certain command here say for example
let's go to this amazon website and say
you want to click on this card so let me
add a command manually here so what is
my command my command is click and then
what is that i want to click i need to
identify that web element for that i can
use this here which says select the
target in the page so i click on that
and i simply select this target which is
my cart and that is all i need to do so
my command is written there so i'll just
simply go ahead and execute this again
let's see what happens so let me close
this window here okay let's run this
test cases bring this window to the site
so now you can see one by one the
instructions being executed okay the
iphone has been searched the best seller
has been clicked assert title so it says
your shopping cart is empty so that
means it is successfully able to click
on the cart so now with using id there
are multiple things you can do you can
simply record your script while you are
running your test case you can add a
command all by yourself you can stop
recording anywhere and again restart
from the same point now we have our
complete test script ready now let's go
ahead and save this so how do you save
this simply go here and save your
complete project so all the projects
from the id are saved as dot side files
so let's name this as amazon project and
i will save it so if i show you in my
finder how it looks like this is the
project we created so it always stores
with the file extension dot sid right
that is selenium id now also i said you
can export test cases into multiple
format so search iphone is my test case
so what i can do is i can just say right
click and i can say export now right now
you can see only three options it says
java junit javascripts and python
however the older ide had multiple
options of export which had even the web
driver scripts and also the javascripts
this is still in works and they would be
adding more support for other
programming languages here so but for
now the only options what is available
to us is java junit javascript and the
python so let's go ahead and export this
into java j unit so it's going to simply
save it as dot java file so let me go
here in the id test i'll save this file
so if you go back to my finder you can
find our search iphone test dot java you
can open the java file you can you can
see here it's a simple junit test it is
exported into so if you have an eclipse
ide you can use this test and execute it
from your eclipse side selenium commands
selenium commands can be broadly
classified into three action commands
accessors and assertions what are action
commands action commands are the
commands which interact directly with
the web elements on your application so
let's look at what these commands are so
if we go back to our previous example
where we had written a test script for
amazon.n so if you look at all these
things like open set window size click
type so these are all nothing but called
as action commands and if you go here
you can see let me do one thing so let
me just come to a blank line and now
let's look at the list of commands so
you have a whole list of commands here
listed in the alphabetical order like
add selection there are multiple asset
commands which is made available to you
and then there are set of commands where
you say click or click at a particular
location closing the browser using a
debugger command double click drag and
drop echo i'll just explain how to use
an echo command so this is a command
which is not or used on your web element
but something which you want to say
display on your console and then there
are if else statements which are used as
commands here then you have something
called as execute script for you to
execute any say javascript or any
different script which you want to
execute from your test script here and
then you have few mouse commands here
open which is what we use for opening a
new url pause and so on so there are
multiple commands which you can look at
and try to use this commands in your
script so these are all called as the
action commands so let's go ahead and
use this echo command and see what it
does so now in the same script what i
will do is towards the end of the script
i'll just add this command i'll say echo
and say i want to just display a message
saying that this is the end of the
script execution that is all i want to
do now i'll just go ahead and run this
and what we want to observe here is how
this particular message what we have
given here is displayed on the console
in the log so now if you observe here so
go to this last statement what we have
so it says after clicking on the card it
said echo this is the end of the script
so this is what we displayed and using
the command echo okay so this is how you
can use the echo com another feature
here what you can do here is now say for
example i just added a simple echo
statement here now for me to execute
that what i did was i executed the
complete script you really need not do
that always instead of that what i can
do is i can just come to this particular
line i can just say right click and i
can say play from here so what it does
is from this point it is going to play
the script for me and not right from the
beginning of the script so i'll show you
how now with this command if you look
here see it started running the script
here it says running search iphone and
then it executed only one command which
says echo this is the end of the script
so this is also possible to do with the
id accessors accesses are the selenium
commands that examine the state of an
application and store the results in a
variable so these are those commands
which allow the user to store say
certain values into your user defined
variables and these stored values can be
later on used either to create
assertions or you can have some
verification points created so let's see
some of the store commands in action so
i have few store commands here which
i'll be demoing so first one is a store
so simply using a store command you can
store any kind of user defined messages
in a variable and then after that you
can either use it for displaying it on
your console or you can do some
assertions with that similarly store
title so you can to store the title of
any of the web page under test then
store text so store text is basically
used to
capture the text attribute of any web
element on your web page and store it in
a variable use it as an assertion point
store value so store value again is
used to store the value attribute of any
web element like so you have lot of web
elements on the web page and say one of
the attributes is what you want to do an
assertion on so what you can do is you
can use the store value command here get
the value attribute of your web element
and store it in a variable so let's see
all these commands in action so let's go
back to the same example so we have this
amazon test script example so what i'll
do is
say instead of using amazon let's do one
thing so let's create another test case
itself so i'll go here i'll say add new
test and i'll name this test as accessor
test and we will use the same amazon
site here i'll say click on start
recording keep this window side by side
so first we will look at store title so
simply what i need to do is go to this
amazon site which you have launched
right click on this go to the selenium
id and you have multiple options here so
go ahead and select store title so once
i click on that it is going to ask me
the variable name where i want to store
the title of this page so let's create a
variable here i'll say var title and
i'll say okay done now come back to your
id all right so i will stop the
execution here now i have the store
title command i created a variable
called var title and i'm storing the
actual title into this variable so let's
also display this on our console so i'll
add a command here echo and in target
how do i use the variable now this is
the way to use it i'll say dollar and in
flower braces i will give the variable
name which i have defined earlier so it
is where i dle title okay so this is all
my script is where i'm storing the title
of the web page and i'm displaying it in
my console or the log so now there are
some extra commands which gets added
here now because we are doing the
recording on that so whatever the mouse
movements happen it is going to record
we do not need this so i will go ahead
and delete this particular command so
let us close this window and execute
this test first so the script has
executed successfully but let's go and
see whether did we get the title
displayed on the console yes so it it
did open the amazon site it has set the
window size it captured the title here
in this line and then after assigning
you to the variable we said echo and
that variable name and it is displayed
as the title of the page so now
similarly let's go ahead and let's see
how do we use the store text command now
for store text i need an use case here
say for example what about this cart
let's say we want to display the text of
this particular element now the text of
this element is cut so now instead of
again going and re-recording all the
steps i will simply manually add this
command so now after displaying the
title okay so let's go ahead here and i
will say store text and in store text i
need to pick the text from this web
element cart so what i will do is i'll
use this target select target and i will
select this particular element which is
cut after this i need to create a
variable where it can be stored so i'll
say where car text now similarly i will
also display it using echo comma echo
dollar in the flower braces i'll say var
car text so let's execute this and then
let's look at the other command so i'll
just say i'll close this window again
run this test so now look at this log
lines so our last statements was storing
the title and displaying the title after
that we added store text okay so here is
the command it said it is executed
successfully it was able to retrieve the
text from the element cart and the text
retrieved was cart and which is what got
displayed with the echo statement on our
console so now let's move to our next
store command which is store value now
as i said store value for us to use that
particular web element should have the
attribute value so first let's examine
which element we can take and display
the value now on the same website i have
the search button so i will right click
on this and i say inspect element now
look at all the attributes of this
element it is of type input it has a
class name it is of type submit and also
it has this value attribute which is
gogo and this is exactly what i want to
retrieve and print so we will be using
the search button now similarly same
thing what i will do here i'll go ahead
add a command here as a store value same
way i will select the target as i select
target from page i will click on the
search button all right so here it has
taken the target here in the value i
will mention the variable name where i
want to store the value so i'll say
where button and value and similarly i
will say echo and i will print the value
of this variable which is dollar var btn
value let's go ahead and execute this
i'll say run current test so it has
taken the title it has printed the value
on the line 7. so it says store value on
this particular element and the value
was stored in the variable where btn
value so that command was successful and
the value actually which was got stored
and which we retrieved using echo
statement was geogo and that's exactly
what we had here if you want to check
again go here to inspect element the one
which is highlighted so as you said the
value is go and that's exactly got
printed on our console now apart from
this i also said there is a simple
command which is just store so let's use
that also now after all this here i will
say store and say we want to just store
a user message i would say a target as
all store commands demo and this message
i will capture it in a variable say var
string since it's just a text and then
like i did it in the other that string
then i'll say echo and the variable name
so now if we
close this and one way to do it is
execute the complete test so which will
execute all our store commands and also
the last line is this the line number
nine in the log which says the store
command which we use to store the text
all store commands demod and that is
also displayed using the x so all the
store commands we have demo successfully
now let's close this window and go back
to our presentation so this is all about
the accessor command now what do we have
after accessor so we have something
called as assertions now what is an
assert so assertion is nothing but it
verifies the current state of an
application with an expected state so
this is something where you compare your
actual result with the expected result
now assertions are of three different
type one is assert verify and wait for
now what does assert does when the
assert command is executed and if it
fails right the test stops immediately
after this statement so if you are
asserting say a title of a page and if
you find that the title of page is not
as expected as soon as it finds that
failure your rest of the test case test
is not going to run and it's going to
immediately stop the test and also it is
going to flag the test cases fake what
is verify verify something where this
selenium id it locks that particular
assertion as fail however it would
continue with the rest of the steps in
the test case and then at the end of it
the your overall test case is flagged as
fake that is what verified us so verify
is called a soft assertion whereas
assert here is called as hard assertion
why it is called harder session because
as soon as an assert statement fails the
complete test execution stops at that
statement whereas in soft hazard what
happens is after the failure happens the
test continues with the rest of the
steps and continue it completes its
execution and then flags the test cases
failure and when is this usually used in
cases like as the same example say if
you are asserting a title you really do
not want the test case execution to stop
even if there is a failure why because
none of your steps are going to be
dependent on this assertion point and
this is where you will require a soft
assert wait for wait for something which
waits for a certain condition to be true
after that it proceeds to your further
steps so if the condition goes false
here for whatever say if you are waiting
for an element to appear on the web page
and if that element does not appear the
test fails however it carries forward
and completes the test by executing the
rest of the steps and then flags the
complete test case as a failure which
will be something similar to a software
search so let's see all these things in
action let's go back to our id we will
create another test case here so i'll
say assert test now for this what's the
example we can take so first for assert
title let's do the assert title on
amazon itself and let's change the same
test case to verify and see how this
test case behave now for this i will
launch the recorder with the same amazon
dot in okay my recorder is launched now
simply i will go to this website and
i'll say right click selenium ide and
i'll say assert title then i will stop
the recording now here i will remove
this command which has got added which i
don't need so this is my asset title now
we have already seen a third title
passing in couple of our other examples
now i want to show you a failure on
myself so for that what i will do i will
modify this actual type so here in the
last line i'll just remove this amazon
dotted so now ideally this test case is
going to fail first because the title
which it is expecting and what it is
comparing against are not the same first
let's execute this uh well i also need
to show some statements after this so
what i will do is let's add few more
statements here let me start the
recording here again say after asserting
the title we want to go and click on
this bestseller and then i will close
this now let's execute this stop the
recording and execute this test now do
you see this assert title is in red that
means it has failed the validation here
so you see here in the log it says open
the site done set window size done when
it comes to azure title it says actual
value was something different and it did
not match with what you are trying to
look for assert test ended with one
error now after this assert please
observe that there are no other
statements which got executed this test
stopped right away after this failure
this is called as hard assert now let's
go ahead and change this assert title to
verify title so simply what i will do in
the command itself instead of assert
i'll say verify title and now let's
execute this and see what happens now
let me close this window first and then
i'll say run test running assert test
amazon dot in was open window size was
set verify title failed because the
titles were different because we have
modified that however do you see this
fourth line being executed click on link
test bestseller and click on close now
since i it was a very fast execution and
i closed the browser probably was you
were not able to see the best sellers
clicked here that is fine but in the log
we can see here that the steps 4 and 5
got executed even after the title verify
title step fit and if you compare it
with the previous example where assert
title failed the two lines after that
the line 4 where we are clicking on the
best seller and closing the browser are
not getting executed so this is the main
difference between the verify title and
the asset title so now let's look at
wait for how do we use wait for now for
wait for i want to look at some kind of
website where it would load an element
dynamically after a while so for that i
have a website here let's let's create a
new test again let's go to the tests
pane i will say assertion test and now
uh let's go to a browser let me open
a new window and there is a demo site
which i want to use so let me search for
that and then i will use that url so
i'll say internet i'm going to use the
dynamic loading do we have here yes
dynamic loading page element rendered
now so if you look at this website when
i press on the start button right after
the file this hello world text is going
to appear on this webpage so in our use
case what we will do we will launch this
website we will click on the start
button and then we will put an assert on
this text using wait for let's do that
so let's go here let me copy this this
is the one let me say control c and in
my new test i'll say control v and then
i'll say start recording so it's going
to launch this let's close the previous
windows now in this i'm just going to
click on start so that is going to get
recorded done and now while the
recording is still on i will add a
command here for wait for so i'll say
wait for element visible that is exactly
what we are saying right so wait for is
used until for a condition and until
that condition is true so i am saying
here please wait for this particular
element which i am going to give it in
target until it is visible now the
target is i'm just going to select the
target from this webpage itself so i'll
say select target and i'm going to
select this particular text come back
here to your id so wait for the element
to be visible what is the element to be
visible is this hello volta hello world
text and then you need to give a value
here now what is this value since we are
using wait for we need to mention a
timeout so we have to tell basically to
id that okay wait for say one second two
seconds or three seconds whatever it is
required and that timeout value is needs
to be mentioned here so and this is in
milliseconds so what i will say is i'll
say so let's fail this test case first
so i'll use a little lesser time mark so
i'll say three thousand so that is uh
three thousand milliseconds which is
three seconds that is it and then we can
say so what we'll do here is we'll add
an assert so i will say assert text now
what is the other text i am going to do
i need to look for the same element so i
will simply say select target this one
and what is that i'm going to assert
with i'm going to assert with the same
text so i'll just copy this text and
i'll put it in the value there's another
way of doing that which we have done it
previously so i can just go here do a
right click go to selenium id and i can
say assert text which is basically going
to give me the same command so let me
just go ahead and remove one of them
either of them you can remove okay so
let's stop the recording i will not
close this browser because i want you to
see how the dynamically loaded element
behaves and will go ahead and execute
this so i'll say stop recording and say
execute this test now it's here all
right so it's waiting okay it just
failed now see this so it says wait for
element visible after that the value we
have mentioned is 3000 that is wait for
three seconds which was not enough
because and it failed with saying that
unable to locate the element within the
timer period now let's go ahead and
change it to a passing value so i will
say 10 000 here which is 10 seconds so
let's close this
and let's again execute this bring this
to the side so that we can see okay it
is waiting on that wait for element now
look at the problem here what we have
done is we have closed the website and
after that we have added the assert text
so this is a mistake what we have done
and hence though it is found that
element here for wait for what did it do
it went ahead and closed the window and
after that it's definitely not going to
find the ascertain right so that's the
mistake what we have done so let's go
ahead and debug this so what we will do
after this wait for element we want this
assert to be put after that we don't
need this click content because this was
an additional step which got added
delete it and then close okay fine so
now let's go ahead and rerun this so
let's run current test i'll move this to
a side okay it's waiting all right done
so now it is able to do an assert text
on this all right so this is how you use
the wait for key features of selenium id
let's look at the first feature
reusability of test scripts so many of
the test scripts have test steps that
involves signing into an application or
creating an account like for example a
login screen is a very key example in
this case where whenever you are testing
your application first you need to log
in and then perform any other test so
now it's going to be a written trend or
a waste of time to recreate the login
steps again and again for each and every
test case so we do not want to
definitely do that so as we know since a
record and replay tool does not have
enough capability
of writing
common test cases or a common functions
and calling those common factions like
our regular selenium web driver has
however what id is done is it has given
us a provision to run one script from
another script so what basically what we
do here is especially for a login we
write one test case which is going to
log into your application and call this
test case in the other test cases so
let's take a a look at how this works so
for that let's go to our ide so in this
id
we'll do one thing let's go ahead and
create a new project so let's say login
project in this project i will create a
new test case we'll call it as login
test let's say add now in this login
test i need to give a url now for this
purpose i will be using again a demo
site so first let me
launch a demo site here file new window
and i will say the demo site
go dot uk okay this is a simple demo
site which has a login functionality
right so here i will go to the login
screen now this also allows me to add
few users and using the same users we
can go ahead and do the login now coming
back to our
login page so this is the url which i
need to launch which is going to give us
username and password we will use to
login into this application so give this
url here and say start recording move
this window here for recording and this
here now what is the first step we want
to record we want to come here click on
the username and i'll say user1 okay and
i'll say password pwd1 and i will click
on test login and then what we will do
is we will assert this text so here i'll
say right click selenium id assert text
that's it and then i will close the
browser okay this is all my test is now
come back to your id let's see if there
are any unnecessary commands which it
has taken okay click type all done and
now for the time being i'm going to
comment out this close comment because i
want the browser to be still open so
that we can see the actual test
execution properly till the end of the
script this is the login test case now
simply if i run this let's execute this
let me execute this and show stop the
recording and execute this test case so
it typed user one it typed pwd which is
my password here and then clicked on the
button and then definitely it was the
wrong password so it gave me fail
docking so this is fast fantastic
however this is with one value i have
used it but this is a function which i
want to use it every time and also a
probable use case i might have is that i
might need to login with a different
user id and password and apart from that
even just to test this login test page i
would want to test with multiple user id
and password like valid credentials and
invalid credential now for that purpose
what we will do is we will parameterize
this name that is user id and the
password and how do i parameterize it
simply go here instead of giving a hard
coded value here what you can do is just
say use any variable name here and we'll
define this variable somewhere else so
i'll say username this is the variable
similarly for my password in my value
field instead of a hard coded value i'll
say dollar and i will say password now i
cannot run this program as it is because
there is this variable is not defined in
the login.test what i will do now is i
will create my actual test case so i'll
say here i'll say invalid credential as
my test case and let's say at now here
is where i will assign values for my
variable now which are these variables i
need to use username and password so i
need to assign some value here and then
call this function login test so let's
do that in this video previously we also
saw how do we use user variables and how
do we assign value by using the store
command so i'm going to say store and
then my target is going to be the actual
value so
user1 and where is that i'm going to
pass this to my variable username so
let's just check once if the variable
name is username yes all right done now
i have done the username now i need to
pass the password so i again i'll say
store the actual password which is pwd1
in my case and what is the variable i
need to use here i have to use password
because that's the variable which we
have used in login test here and then
after that i need to use a command which
is called as run now what this run
command does is run and whatever target
you give which is basically your another
test case it is going to run the test
case now in our case our test is login
test this is all our test case is going
to be okay so what is that we did we do
in this test case we created a variable
username and password and assigned the
actual username and password and then we
are just calling this login test and in
this login test this username and
password will get passed which will be
user1 and pwd1 and then it will execute
this test with the or with the value
which we have passed to this variable so
now which test case we need to run the
invalid credential so let's go ahead
close this window and execute this test
executed so now look at the log of this
invalid credential test see running
login test called by invalid credential
before that it said store this value
store user 1 in the value username that
is your variable this is this line and
then the password then it says run login
test so it called the login test
functionality and in the login test we
have all this clicking on the password
field clicking on the username and then
asserting the text and that's exactly
what is done here this is how you use it
so now let's write one more test here
for the same login test so
let me add another test i'll say valid
credentials and let's say add now same
thing i will do here i'll say command
store my target will be now i'll say
user3 value will be username right okay
now second command will be again storing
this time it is for the password my
password is pwd3 and
the variable name is password and same
thing i'll just call run and my login
test that's it now similarly let's run
this test and see what happens now this
test is going to fail why let me close
this window i don't need this why did
this test case fail because my assertion
point let's go to the test session my
assertion point in login test is look
for failed login however we created a
test case for valid credentials right
because our valid credentials said that
the login was successful which did not
match with what we were asserting which
is fine right so we just wanted to see
whether we can write a test case with
valid credentials and invalid
credentials and this is how you do that
by passing the variables through your
test case to your actual test case the
next feature is the debugger in the id
like every other id offers a debugger
functionality so does selenium id so
let's look at what are the different
functions available for us in the
debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium ide
offers us so one is called as the step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques works what
i'll do is let's go ahead and create a
new test script so let's go to our id
and i will create a new test case so
i'll say new test case let's use uh
facebook login this time so i'll say fb
login test or we'll just say fb test so
now for this fb test i would go ahead
and use the facebook login page so i'll
just copy this url paste it here and
then i will minimize this other firefox
window and i will launch the recorder
now so i'll click on start recording now
let's keep this side by side and what is
that we are going to do here is let's
do a simple login functionality so i'll
just use some email id here so i'll say
my user at gmail.com this is just a
dummy user id and password values and
i'll say password as password1 then i'll
click on login button let's stop the
recording here so let's read the script
once whether it has got everything
whatever we need okay it has launched
facebook it clicked on email id there's
a double clicks here because i happen to
click twice on the email id field so
what i'll do i'll remove one we don't
need it and then i'm typing the keys
which is myuser.gmail and then i'm
clicking on the password field typing
the password and clicking on the login
button and then once i do that okay so
i'm going to get this pages the password
you have entered is incorrect so let it
be so we will use the script until here
and check out some of the login options
okay so we have completed writing of the
script let me go ahead and close this
window now first thing what we will do
is we'll just simply execute the script
so we have to just say run current test
so it's going to log in your facebook
it'll enter my user at gmail it'll enter
the password it'll log in and that's
about it so now your script is executed
now let's go into the debug mode as we
said there are multiple options for
debugging what is the first option let's
see so first option we have is something
called a step execution so what the step
execution does is from your script you
can execute all the steps one after the
other so you can basically control the
execution of each step and how you do
that what you have to do is just go and
click anywhere so let's start from the
beginning let's close this window of our
previous run and there is an option here
which says step over current command so
when you click on this what it does is
it basically executes your first line
where your cursor was and it stops
immediately after that so if you look
here it has launched the facebook page
which says open the url facebook and
then let's go ahead and just do the
simple step execution again i will click
on that it is going to execute this
command where it set the window size to
certain value again i will do a step
execution now observe what happens here
it clicked on this email field do you
see the cursor there now let's do the
next step again again i will do step
over current command now the current
command was it entered my user at gmail
you can see it on the left side here now
it will be more visible again i will do
a step execution it is going to click on
the password field now it is going to
enter the password and now the last step
is it's going to click on the login
button and with this all our commands
are executed and this is how you do the
step execution and now where is this
useful say if you've got a very long
test case written and you want at
certain point you want to start doing
the step execution to see where your
test cases fail probably one of your web
element you entered is wrong or probably
the text which you are entered is wrong
so for you to debug such cases you can
use this step over current command
functionality so what's our next command
break points so there are break points
which you can insert in your script okay
so let's close this execution and let's
come back to our script so what i will
do is first let's add a breakpoint how
do you add a breakpoint say for example
we want to add a breakpoint after we
type in our email id so here what i do
is i simply go and click here so once
you click here this is where your
breakpoint is added other way of adding
breakpoint is you can right click on any
command and you can use this toggle
breakpoint so if there is no breakpoint
it adds the breakpoint and for you to
remove it you can simply go and select
the toggle breakpoint again so now i've
added a single breakpoint now what you
need to do is once you execute this once
you say run test what it will do is it
will come till here till your break
point it will execute all the commands
before that and it stops or pauses your
execution at this point okay let's go
ahead and see how it does so what i'll
do is i've added a break point at the
click on password field and i will say
execute this test do you see here it
says paused in the debugger so by adding
breakpoint my test has entered the
debugging mode and where has it stopped
to at the point where i added this
breakpoint so just go back here and see
whether the previous steps have been
executed yes my previous step was adding
this myuser gmail.com into the email
field which it has done and it has
paused here and now from here i can
either run the rest of the tests if i
just click on this run current test what
it will do is it will go ahead and
execute all the steps or even i can do a
step execution from here so say if i
want to do a step execution i'll do this
let me minimize this window a little bit
so that you can see and i'm still again
doing that step execution so it added
the password and after this i'll say
just go ahead and complete the test so
it has clicked on your sign in login
button and it is logged in so this is
how you can use the breakpoint so that
is about adding the breakpoint let's see
what's the next removing the break point
so i showed you so if you want to add a
breakpoint you just click here or you
can do a right click and do toggle
breakpoint if you want to remove the
breakpoint just click again on the same
place where it has added the breakpoint
or you can always do this toggle
breakpoint so this is the way of adding
and removing the breakpoints what is the
third option disabling now say for
example my test case is a pretty long
one okay so i might have a multiple
breakpoints so say let's add one
breakpoint here at the email and then
before clicking on login let's add
another breakpoint now when i execute
this it is going to stop here and then
again if i say continue execution it is
going to come and stop here so let's do
that first and then i'll show you how
the disable works so let's close this
window again execute this bring this
window here can you see this it's paused
here okay and here now you should be
able to see it now i'll say just run
after this breakpoint do you see here it
is paused after entering the password it
has not clicked on the login button it's
paused at the click and now i'll say
again complete the test so your click on
the login button is done and it is
logged in so it's a little bit slow yeah
now you got that logged in page at some
point of time while i'm debugging my
test case i would want to just disable
all the breakpoints and not remove
everything for that i have an option
here which says disable breakpoint so if
this button is highlighted here that
means i have selected disable breakpoint
so what this does is when i execute this
test it ignores all these break points
for this run it ignores this break
points until i have selected this
disable breakpoint button okay so let's
see this let me close this again and i
have enabled this disable breakpoint is
what i have selected i'll just simply go
ahead and run this test case do you see
that it did not stop at this breakpoint
it went ahead and completed the
execution why because i have temporarily
disabled it once i remove the selection
and run it it is again going to stop at
the breakpoints so this is how it works
so we saw adding of breakdowns removing
of breakpoints and disabling of
breakpoints what is the next one enter
debugger by using play to this point
option okay now another way of doing
this is so let's remove all this
breakpoint now for example like the last
time we said we want to add a breakpoint
here so now instead of doing that what i
can do also do is i can just right click
on that particular command and i can say
play to this point only so when i select
this what happens it acts like a break
point and it comes and pauses at this
particular command where i have said
play till this point so let's try to do
that so let me close this window and
then for say type the password so here
okay i'll say right click play to this
point so it is going to execute all the
steps until the password and it will
stop here can you see this paused in the
debugger so it again enter the debug
mode and now it is stopped at this point
so now there are multiple options now
every time last time what we did we did
a step over and also we said continue
with the rest of the test now what we
will do we will just stop the execution
so this is also an option available say
if you want to change something here you
do not want to continue with your
execution you can simply go ahead and
stop the execution so we saw how do we
use the play to this point option now
debugger command now all these things
whatever we did now adding the
breakpoints this was done in the id
there is also a way of adding a debugger
programmatically and how do we do that
let's see now at the same place say
after entering the password so here i
will insert a command in this command
i'll just say debugger this is all the
command is now what happens when i
execute this test cases at this point
wherever it finds this debugger command
this program enters into a debug mode
and it comes and pauses the script here
let's see this in action so simply i'll
just play the script let's type the
email id let's type the password okay it
is going little slower here okay and
there there you go now it is paused in
debugger so this debugger did the same
job as what we did earlier with the
breakpoints now let's go ahead and just
stop the execution because let's not
keep logging into facebook with invalid
username and id okay so this is how you
can use the debugger command so i will
stop the execution here close this
window and then now let's see the next
one let's close this window so we saw
the debug pause on exception okay this
is a very brilliant feature of this id
i'll show you how it works now let's say
let me remove this command now i do not
want the debugger i'll say delete this
command just click let it be there now
if you look at this what we are doing is
we are identifying these elements like
email password and then clicking on the
login button now say for example say
this click so
let's run this then i'll show you what
it is and i want it to come and uh stop
here okay so i will execute this all
right so now it is paused here so now
what i will do is the click right so
this is where i'm clicking is this login
button so this login button is
identified by some identifier which is
an id now there is a possibility that
tomorrow this particular id might change
or any of the locator might change on
this particular website and if that
happens the first point of failure what
you will see is when you click on this
button because this script will say that
this element is not found in such cases
if you are using pause on exception that
is here pause an exception what happens
is whenever this script finds an
exception it goes and pauses at that and
enters into a debug mode otherwise what
happens whenever you find an exception
your complete test script will stop
executing because there is an error and
your test case fails instead since we
are in a debugging mode if you choose
this option what happens is if there is
an exception it is going to come get
into the debugger mode and it is going
to pause the execution at that point and
once it pauses what you can do is you
can go and correct it and then continue
your execution so let's see that in
action so now for example the click
button so here the id is you underscore
0 underscore so say i try to change this
let me add 1 here and then if i execute
this this script should fail for me
basically because it is not going to
find this so can you see us trying to
find this id and since this particular
element with this id does not exist this
whole test case should fail for me now
as i said earlier in this video so if by
any chance if one of the element id is
not found so if that is not found it
always falls back into the other locator
techniques and that is what it did in
this case it tried to locate the login
button using some other id and that's
what it says element found with the
secondary locator okay to use it by
default update the test step and to use
it as a primary locator and that is
where the test case pass so let's try to
see if i can make this test case fail in
any way for that let's remove this and
let's try on the email id so what i will
do is let me try to comment this out
remove the debugger and i will add a
command here i'll say insert new command
and in this i will say click and then i
will use the target as id equal to email
now in this case i do not have a
fallback id because i am not using id to
recognize the element rather i added my
own command and i added my own locator
here so now let's try with this and
now instead of this is the right id so
what i will do is i'll just change this
id to something like underscore one so
that this test case fails for me now let
me close this and let's run this test
case and basically this test case should
fail so if you see here in the log it's
saying trying to find the element with
id email underscore one so this id has a
default timer so it will keep trying to
find the element until the timeout value
is completed now there we go so it had
an implicit timeout of 30 000 so that is
30 seconds 30 000 milliseconds which was
30 seconds now after that this test is
filled so this is the scenario we wanted
what happens here is it simply started
executing the moment it found an
exception it completely stopped so as a
tester what you need to do is you need
to go back look for this red lines where
it has failed correct it and then rerun
the whole test now instead of that what
this pause and exception does is let me
click on that so this is what is
selected now what it does is when i
execute this this is going to come and
stop here let's see that so let me close
this and run this program again so run
current test i'll bring this to the side
now see it's trying to find the id since
the timeout is almost 30 seconds we need
to wait until it pauses at this so now
do you see this now it is not exited
from the test it is just at the same
step where it is unable to find this
email field okay and it's saying okay it
failed with an implicit timeout of 30
seconds but now since i'm in the
debugging mode and how did i get into
the debug mode by selecting this option
pause an exception now what i can do is
i can go ahead and change this back to
the actual one and then from here i can
just simply do this i can say run the
test now so now see what it did the
moment i changed that and i said run it
passed and how did it pass because i
gave the right id here and that's
exactly you can do with this departure
control flow statements so in the legacy
id uh these control flow statements were
available as plugin so one had to
install the plugin for you to use any of
this control flow statements however in
the new ide these are available out of
box so let's see what this control
statements are so let's go to my notes
so there are two types of control flow
statements one is conditional branching
and the other one is looping so in
conditional branching we have a regular
if else if nested if else and end and
when we talk about looping there are
multiple loops available one is the
while end loop so how does the while end
loop work the code between the while and
the end is executed until the expression
is true and then we have a do repeat so
do repeat where the commands after the
do will get executed first and then the
condition is checked and this is
evaluated in the if statement times end
so you can specify a number of
iterations you would like a piece of
code to be executed using this loop and
then there is another loop which is a
for each loop so this provides the
ability to iterate over collection
objects like say if you have an array
object with you and you want to say or
traverse through the array and perform
certain operations on each of the array
element so that is possible using the
for each loop so let's go and write a
test script and see how this work so
what i will do is i will demonstrate a
use case for the if else and then for
the looping i have a few test scripts
which i have already written which i
will show you and i will walk you
through them it's a simple counter which
we can use where it will be incrementing
the counter using one of these loops so
we'll just see how the loops are to be
used what is the syntax to be used and
how they execute in the id so let's go
to our id now let's minimize this so
this was our previous test case so what
i will do is i will close this project
and open another project so i have
another project here which is called as
control flows so as i said i have few
scripts written for some of the loops
however for the demo use case we will go
ahead and write a new script so i'll say
add new test and
we are going to be working with a demo
site called calgary calculator so let me
name the test case itself as calorie
calculator test so let's look at what is
our use case now in this use case this
is my use case i am saying go to this
gallery counter website okay so let's
see what that website is i have this
website open here so this is a calorie
calculator website in this website we
are saying if the gender is male then
click on the mail radio button so you
have multiple fields here where you are
accepting the age of a person the gender
of a person the height the weight and
then the activity level of the person
and when when you click on calculate
this is going to give you the number of
calories so for our purpose for our demo
use case what we will do is we will
store the gender to be selected in a
variable say for example i want a gender
female to be selected and then i'm going
to write an if condition here that if
the gender is male right so if the
gender is male then click on the male
radio button here and then i'm saying
click active from the activity drop down
so there's a drop down called activity
here in this i'm going to go and select
active as daily exercise or intense
exercises three to four times a week
this is what i'm going to be selecting
and if the gender is female so if the
value passed from the gender is female
then what is that i want to do i want to
click on this radio button female and
select very active intense exercise from
this activity dropped up a very simple
use case so this is what we are going to
write in our test script so let's
minimize this window or we can just
close this window for now we don't need
this and here so how do we start this
test case i need to enter the url so for
me to enter the url let me go to that
copy this url control c minimize this
and control v done so now here i will
start my recording by clicking on the
start recording button so now this url
is open now the first thing what i need
to do is in my test script i need to
write a open command so i'll say open
and my target is what this url done the
next command is as per our use case i
want to store the gender to be selected
in a variable so we will use the store
command and when we use the store
command we need to specify the target so
let's say the target is f and where is
that i want to store i'll create a where
gender that's my variable so i have
stored this now what is the next thing i
want to do so once i have stored this
first is i need to put an if statement
because my use case is if the gender is
male and if the gender is female now
since by default the male is already
selected here so let's put an if
condition for this condition if the
gender is female okay so that is exactly
what i am going to do so here i will say
if in the command once i say if in the
target you need to specify the condition
now condition is i want to check for
dollar that's my variable where gender i
want to check if this is equal to f and
how is that i can check i need to use 3
equal to here in double quotes i'm going
to mention f now this is what i have
stored in the variable that gender this
is what i'm going to check so if this is
the condition in the next line now all
the next lines whatever i'm going to
mention are the ones which will be
executed if this condition is true now
in the next line what i want is i want
to select this radio button correct so
now what i will do instead of writing
all the commands manually i will now use
a recorder to do that since i'm already
in the recording mode i'll just go to
the url or the website here and i'll go
click on this female so on the right if
you see these steps are getting recorded
and then our use case also said that
from the activity drop down we want to
select very active so now if you look
here all our steps have been recorded so
i clicked on the female radio button and
then we selected the id activity here
which is our activity drop down and then
we clicked on the desired value which is
very active and then you end the if
statement here so but we also want to
add an else statement so instead of
saying end here i will say else so that
means if the gender selected is mail
okay what is that we want to do i want
to go and select in the activity field
as active because the mail is already
selected so i'm not going to select it
again and then i will end the if loop by
end statement that is all so this is all
my script is so let's stop the recording
here there are some mouse move mouse up
which i really do not need so what i
will do is i just delete this so this is
the simple statement what i need in the
else where i'm saying select so select
is something a command which is used to
select a web element which is your drop
down so you select the drop down here
and once the drop down is clicked and
then you go ahead and click on
this particular target is nothing but
your active daily exercises or intense
this value from the drop down is what
i'm selecting and same same thing what
we did in the if statement so let's
remove these also we don't
mouse move at and mouse up at so all
these statements we don't need so same
thing if i'm saying the if statement
says if the gender is f that is female
click on the radio button then go to the
select activity select the activity by
clicking on very active and then end the
loop so this is all our scripters now
let's go ahead and execute this and see
whether it works so let's minimize this
window and i will simply say execute the
current test let's slow down the
execution speed little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now i'll say run the current test so the
calorie calculator is open so we are
passing the value f for the gender
correct so that means it entered this
loop you can see here in the log so if
the gender is f which is female yes it
found the condition to be true and then
it clicked on this radio button it went
to the select field which is your
activity drop down it selected the very
active option from here and then it
ended now in the same program what i
will do instead of f let's pass the
value m mail and let's see what happens
and then we will go ahead and execute
this program so let's close this window
again and execute the test script again
so now according to the script we are
not reselecting the radio button because
this is already selected by default and
in this descript if you see now all the
green colored one if you see okay the
open command ran successfully store
command run successfully it came to the
if condition it checked if the gender
was f or m it found that this condition
is not true so can you see here all
these other statements in the if are in
black color that means these were not
executed instead it came to the else
part and then it executed all the
commands in the else part so this is how
you use a if condition in your selenium
id so let's close this now as i said
there are other looping statements what
we have like while end loop or do repeat
and time set so i have couple of
examples written here let's walk through
that and see so let's take the while
loop first so what happens in this while
loop let's see in this while loop what
i'm basically doing is i have created a
counter and i'm counting it from 1 to 5
and then displaying the value of the
counter and i'm using a while loop for
that so here it says first i am setting
a counter value to 1 and then i am
saying while the counter value is less
than 5 this is the loop while and end so
whatever commands are within that those
get executed until the condition is true
so this loop will get executed until the
counter becomes 5. so once it sees that
counter is 5 it is going to exit the
loop and just print the value of the
counter it's as simple as while loop so
just pay attention to the syntax the way
it has been used here so this execute
script is what a simplest statement what
i have used this could be anything it
could be any of your web elements you
are performing certain operations say
there is a calculator which you are
using say a calculator under test so if
you want to key in certain numbers until
say the sum of the numbers is 30 or
something an example like that could be
a valid use case for your while loop so
you could use that so let's execute this
and see how the counter works so if i
execute this command so now take a look
at the log here this is running while
test so first statement where it
assigned the counter value and then it
got into the while loop and it executed
the volume until the counter was
assigned the value 5 and once the
counter became 5 the while loop got
exited and we are printing the counter
value so this is how a while loop is
used now similarly the same function of
using a counter i have tried to use a do
loop here so let's look at it now in the
do loop what happens is the first the
script is executed because it's the
first command after the do statement so
whatever is between the do and repeat if
is executed and then the condition is
checked here so here what i'm doing is
i'm just first assigning a counter with
value 0 and i'm incrementing the counter
every time by 10 and then i have a
condition that once the counter becomes
50 please exit the loop that's all i'm
doing here and another statement what i
have written here is every time the
counter gets incremented i am printing
the value of the counter so let's
execute this can you see that the way it
is executing it all right now let's see
the log running do loop test okay the
counter has been initialized to 0 and
then it executes the script and this
script is doing what it is just
incrementing the counter by 10. the
counter becomes 10 and then 20 30 40 and
50. so as soon as it becomes 50 it's
going to exit the loop and print the
value of the counter so one thing to
notice is there is no web element or
website testing which i am doing from
the script however
one thing what the id needs is it needs
a starting point so whenever you create
a new test kit it asks you to at least
give it a url from where it can start
though it is not going to launch that
url it is going to launch your browser
definitely before even it executes a
single line of test so that is something
a mandatory in the id so we saw do loop
we saw the while loop there's also
something called as time slope so which
is what i have said here times and end
so this is something you can specify a
number of iterations you would like to
perform a set of commands so now in this
example what am i doing i'm simply
incrementing a counter by one right and
i am saying just increment that is this
is the only command which i want to
execute but i wanted to execute two
types that's all so there is no other
conditions here it is simply saying
there is a set of command or a single
command which i want to execute it twice
and the number of times which i want to
execute is what i mentioned here in the
target so first initially i am assigning
a counter with value 100 and then i am
saying increment this counter by one two
times and then print the value of the
counter so let's execute this and then
change the number of times if i say run
test here so can you see this the number
of times it got titrated and now the
value is 102 why because initial value
was 100 in the loop which is the time
slope i am saying the iterations is 2 2
times execute the command which
increments the counter by 1. so that is
why your counter value becomes 102. now
say i increase this to say 10 so that we
get a feel of how the loop executes here
and same thing i will execute it now see
it you can visually see the number of
times the loop is getting executed all
right and in the log you can see the
values also here okay can you see here
so this loop executed 10 times and hence
the counter value becomes 110 so these
are a simple ways of using these loops
in the id so you can implement this
loops for any kind of functionality you
may want to perform on your web elements
or any logic which you want to build for
your test cases selenium side runner
selenium side runner is a command line
runner tool which allows the user to run
your selenium id test cases on any
browsers or to run the test cases
parallely and also it gives you a
mechanism to use the grid setup to run
your test cases on a remote machine okay
so for us to work with this selenium
side runner there are certain
installations which we need to do and
some of the installation prereqs are one
is you need a node.js server and what is
this node.js server node.js server is a
powerful javascript based platform and
this is the platform which is
intensively used by many developers
across the world for developing their
web applications and it's an open source
and it is available free of cost to
everyone to use it so we will need to go
ahead and install a node.js server for
this so now let's look at all the
installation steps which are involved in
installing the side runner and running
it okay so let's go to my notes so the
selenium seleniumhq.org has a complete
documentation on how to install this
command line runner how to use it and
what are the different ways we can use
this runner i'll just show you where it
is and you can use this as a reference
for any of the tests which you're
creating and using the side runner to
run it
so let me open a new window here let's
go to this website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
runner right including the setups what
is the prereqs installing the browser
drivers
and
how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the side runner so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers it
also gives you complete details on how
to do that and also using the parameters
changing your base url so this is a
complete guide which you can refer to
when you are working with the site
runner okay so let us go back to our
installation
so coming back to our installation here
so the first prereq what we need for the
selenium side runner to run is your
node.js okay so if you go to this
website nodejs.org
let me open the same
browser okay
all right so here you will see that the
node.js is available as an installable
for all the platforms like do you have a
windows installer you have mac os
installer you have linux installers also
so if you're working with the windows
machine there are two options for you
either you can go ahead and download the
msi installer or you can just download
the zip and unzip it into any folder on
your system okay and since i'm using mac
machine what i have done is i have
downloaded this version pkg version and
have installed it on my machine okay so
once you download say if you're working
on the windows machine so say 64-bit is
what you require and you click here and
download the zip package i'll show you
how the folder structure looks like so
this is where i have downloaded the
node.js installable now if you look at
the windows one so this is what happens
when you download the zip file and unzip
it this is the folder structure it
creates and this is what we would need
right so npm is something which we would
be using to install all the packages
which are required on this node.js
server and i will explain to you what
those packages are okay so once you do
this installation you need to go and
check if your installation is gone
properly or not so for that what you do
is go to your terminal window or in your
case if you are using a windows machine
just open a command prompt right and
then you have to just give this command
here you say npm minus v which is
basically saying what is the version of
the node.js which you have installed
which is 6.9 okay now what is this npn
npm is nothing but it's a node.js
package manager and it gets installed
with your node and this is used to
install all your other packages or what
it is called as modules on your system
so now with this we know that our npm
has been installed properly so let's
move to the next step of installation so
now we have our node.js installed now
next thing is to install the selenium
side runner now the selenium side runner
is a library which is available to us
and we need to install this library
using the npn so let me go back to my
terminal again so i'll just show you the
command what it is what we use for
installing this package or the library
and since i've already installed on my
machine i will not be doing the
installation here so what you need to do
so if you are a windows user you can
directly give the command as npn install
minus g selenium site
runner okay so this is the command which
you need to get however if you're a mac
user or a unix user since you need to
use a root user here what you need to do
is just say sudo once you press enter
here it will go ahead and install this
complete library on your system now
since i've already installed i'm not
going to do that okay so i'll just exit
from this now once the installation is
done how do you check whether your
installation has gone correctly or not
you have to just simply give a command
like selenium side runner minus version
okay and now this will give you the
version number if the installation has
been successful so right now the version
installed which is the latest version is
3.11 okay so so far we have done the
installation of the node.js server we
have done the installation of the
selenium now while you also you do this
installation you need to know that where
is the selenium ide side runner has been
installed right as i said it's a library
or what you popularly call as module in
your npm right so for you to check
whether where it has got installed you
simply need to go to the directory i'll
say ls minus user local library so if
you see here you'll see something called
as node modules so whatever packages
you're going to install using npm would
get installed in this directory the node
modules directory so let's go ahead and
see whether i have my selenium side
runner there or not so i'll just use the
same ls slash
node modules okay do you see this
selenium side runner is what has got
installed and previously to that when we
installed the node.js server it also
installed this npm right so that is also
available under the same folder so far
so good so we have our selenium ide
installed now what else is required so
we installed the nodejs we installed the
selenium side runner now we need this
browser drivers now what are these
browser drivers now what you did using
your ide was let me
id was we said right in the id itself i
said run the current test and since i am
using firefox browser here any test case
using the ide plugin on your firefox you
execute is going to execute on the
firefox browser correct same way if you
are using the selenium ide on chrome
which is an extension on chrome and you
run the test cases there it is going to
use the chrome browser to run the test
case however any test cases or any
automation scripts you're going to write
you want your scripts to run on all the
browsers because you want to do a cross
browser testing right so for that
purpose what we do through command line
is we install this browser drivers right
so say if you want to run your test
cases on edge browser so that means you
first need to install your edge browse
driver on your systems before you run
your test case on edge process if you
want to do it for chrome similarly you
need to download the chrome web driver
and install it for firefox the same and
once you install that then you should be
able to run it on any browser now where
are these chrome browsers available so
if you go to the
seleniumhq.org let me show you that
okay in the selenium hq website if you
go to this download tab and if you go
down here you will see something called
as third party drivers bindings and
plugins and here you have a list of all
the browsers and its corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go and
download for example say i want to run
all my tests on chrome browser right so
what i do is i click here okay in the
download session go to the latest chrome
driver available click on that and then
depending on which os you're working on
if you're working on mac just download
this if you're working on
windows you download this and once you
download the driver what you need to do
is you keep that drivers like for
example uh
can you see this driver file so this is
my driver file this is my executable
driver file so what i did was i just
downloaded this file for mac and i
copied it to the location where my tests
are present okay now so once i have this
available what i need to do is i need to
install this driver using again the npm
command and to install this driver what
you need to do is you need to be in the
same directory where your driver file is
present okay in the same directory you
just issue this command you say npm
install minus g and your chrome driver
this is it so once you install this
driver you should be able to work with
your chrome driver got it very simple so
similarly if you're working with
different browsers say if you also want
to run your test cases with edge or
internet explorer or the firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers from this location
so from here like you have edge browser
here opera browser you have a mozilla
firefox browser so any of the browser
which you want to work with you have to
just download your driver from here
place it in this location and install it
using npn command okay so since i will
not be executing this command again
because i've already installed it so
once your drivers are installed what's
the next step we are ready to execute
our test cases okay so these are all the
installation steps which are required to
get your command line runner which is
called as selenium side runner ready for
you to execute your test from the
command line all right okay now let's go
ahead and see how do we execute the test
cases so let's go back to our previous
example in this video where we wrote
some of the test cases for testing our
control flows okay so these are all the
test cases now if you observe here i
have not created any test suite here we
just had a default suite which was
created when we created the project and
we just went ahead and created all the
tests here for the side runner to run we
need to have a test suite there so if i
just try to run the test switch let's
try to run this what is the name of this
project control flows so will show you
what happens if there is no test suite
defined for this so let me clear the
screen and uh which is a project here
this one okay so what i will do is let
me simply go ahead and execute this
project so to execute any test this is
the command which you use you simply
call selenium side runner and the
project name okay and also once you have
installed the selenium side runner you
can also check the version of it so
let's execute this selenium
site runner and the project name project
name is this
done so now if i press enter now see
what happens
okay it's saying running the default
suite carries here
it looks for a test suite to start its
execution okay so it picked up the
default suite which is here
okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine however
it's a test suite failed to run why
because your test suite must contain at
least one test and all our tests are
residing outside the test suite we have
none in the default test way correct so
what we will do let's go ahead and
create this test suite instead of
default what i will do is i'll say first
rename this so let's give it a proper
name so we'll say control flow test test
suite okay done so i have renamed it now
let's go ahead and add all those test
cases which we have created to this so
i'll just simply say add test and select
all these tests so we have around four
tests here so i'll just select all that
done so i'll save this project
i'll go to my folder id tests and the
same file name i'll just say replace now
we have a test suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again now let's see what happens okay so
there are multiple test cases here so
let's see all these test cases will be
run one after the other sequential so we
have that calorie counter test case and
then we have the loop test cases all
right so it is done so now let's
understand the flow of this test case
okay so this is where we started running
our test suite so it finished first test
case it finished the second test case it
finished the third test case and then
the fourth test case so all the four
test cases it has completed and it says
all the four passed total four and it
also shows you the total time taken for
the complete test suite to run and for
every test case what is the amount of
time required to execute the test so
this is all the information which is
available here if at all there is a
failure in any of the test case that
would get reflected here it would say
for past one phase and total four
executed okay so this is the kind of
report what you will get to see good so
far okay so let's go back to our notes
and see whether we have done everything
so the other way of running is say you
have multiple browser drivers installed
and you want to run this on a particular
browser so during that time what you can
do is you can use this command you can
say selenium side runner minus c minus c
is nothing but setting the capabilities
capabilities for what for the browser
and then you give a browser name here so
you can say chrome or you can say
firefox whatever the browser of your
choice and then give your projecting so
with this what happens is if your
browser is installed now we have to
install the browser using this command
correct so if your browser is installed
it will execute this particular test
suite on the browser which you have
mentioned here right and that is how you
use this selenium side runner to run
your test cases on multiple process now
simply what you can do is you can create
a shell script or a batch script you can
add this line into your batch script for
the multiple browsers and you can
execute this so that way all your test
cases would executed on all the process
so that that way you can achieve your
cross browser testing so other thing if
you remember i also said that command
line runner like if you go back to our
presentation it says we can run it for
parallel testing now let's see how do we
achieve this parallel testing now to
achieve this parallel testing there are
certain steps which you need to do in
the id so let's go back to our test
suite so we have this test suite so if
you go here and go to the settings can
you see this run in parallel so you need
to check this check box to run all these
test cases in parallel so right now what
happened when we executed it all the
test cases ran sequentially one after
the other correct so for every test case
there was a chrome browser launched and
the chrome browser was closed before the
next test was launched now let's try to
do this i i'm going to check this check
box where it says run in parallel and
i'll say submit i'll save this project
again now
same thing i'll overwrite this project
save done replace now let's go to our
terminal window and run this test cases
again so for that what i will do i'll
call the same command again however now
please observe the number of chrome
browser windows it's going to open okay
i'll show you that so it has started
running the test suite okay can you see
this three chrome browser windows open
at the same time okay and one by one
they're going to get closed out okay so
there was also the fourth one open but
since the test case was so small that it
was too quick for us to see here now
look at the complete execution here so
what it has done is it opened all the
browsers in parallel okay and it ran all
the test cases parallely you will see a
big difference and since these are very
small testers you might not be able to
see a big difference in the execution
time however if you have got a bigger or
bigger test cases which you are running
you will see a remarkable difference in
the time taken by the swede to run the
test cases still here you can see okay
it's almost 11 seconds it took whereas
in the previous example it took 13
seconds as i said the difference is very
small because our test cases are very
very minor test cases right if you have
a bigger test cases where it launches
the browser launches your application
under test then you're doing multiple
operations you'll be able to see a
remarkable difference when you run the
test sequentially and when you run it
parallel so this is how you work with
the ide and this is how you achieve the
parallel execution okay so that
completes our selenium side runner now
let's look at some of the limitations of
the selenium id the first limitation is
you cannot export your id scripts to web
driver scripts the support is yet to be
added right so earlier in this video i
showed you there are ways to export the
scripts to junit and python however the
previous ide did have this capability of
exporting your scripts to web driver
scripts and that support is yet to be
added to the new id data driven testing
like using excel files or reading data
from the csv files and passing it to
your scripts so this capability is not
yet available in the id so you cannot do
data driven testing database testing is
also not possible so you cannot actually
connect your database read the test data
from your database or even you cannot
perform any kind of database testing
reporting facility so it does not have a
good reporting we saw when we use the
command line runner or through the id
when we run the test there is a very
minimal reporting capabilities what we
could see so it does not really have
capabilities of reporting like your test
ng or the report engine all right so to
sum it up what all we did we learned in
this video we learned how to use the
selenium id to create automation scripts
we also looked at some of the key
features of this new id like the
reusability of the tests using the
control flow statements how do we use
the debugger and most importantly using
the command line runner which is called
a side runner to run your tests on any
browser and also to run test case
parallel let's get started with what is
j meter
j meter or apache j meter is an open
source software which is a 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance performance testing means
testing a web application against heavy
load multiple and concurrent user
traffic
it was originally designed for testing
web applications but has since expanded
to other test functions
to simplify let's assume that someday
your team lead tells you to perform
performance testing of some website like
google.com or facebook.com for around
100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with computers and
access to the internet and accessing the
same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for 1000 or 10 000 users
this is when a need for software like
jmeter arises
so what jmeter actually does is that it
simulates it will simulate real user
behaviors and perform load tests on a
server group of servers network or
object
moving further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as linux
windows mac us or even ubuntu
now that we know the basics of jmeter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system first let's check if you have
java installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type java hyphen
version we can see that java is present
in our system here it will show the
version of java present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter
go to google chrome and type jmeter
download
now go to the official apache jmeter
website and go to the binary sections
in the binary sections we shall download
the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder once the folder is again
extracted go inside the folder and go
inside the bin folder here
the bin folder contains the jmeter
script file for starting jmeter
now it's time for us to launch a meter
but before we launch jmeter we need to
know that there are typically two types
of modes in which jmeter can be launched
the gui mode and the non-gui mode the
non-gui mode may refer to two types the
first being running jmeter in the server
mode and the second refers to running j
meter in the command line
and if we talk about the gui mode then
the gui mode has a limitation which
slows down the cpu utilization while
running the recorded script but gui mode
of jmeter is perfect for adding and
editing new configuration elements
thread groups and samplers as a result
of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging here today we shall be using
the gui mode
so to open the gui mode inside this bin
folder select the jmeter.bat file
double click on this file this may take
a while and then the j meter window will
open up on the screen the home window is
divided into two sections on the left
side all the elements of the test plan
are added and on the right side all the
configuration of that element are added
as we see on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first jmeter
now when you click outside this window
section you can see the element name
will change otherwise you can just save
this and also the name will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups right click on
first j meter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group the thread
group refers to the users that are used
or created or needed to run this test so
let's name this thread group to be j
meter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to run infinite number
of times
there is also scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
test's end time
for now let's leave everything to be 1
only
the next step is to go to first j meter
and again to go to add in the box that
appears select samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on
for now we will choose the simplest of
them all let's choose the http request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip
let's pick a website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the url from
here
come back to the jmeter window and paste
it in the server name box keep in mind
we don't need to give http or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the http request
case
then in the path dialog box since we
have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our http test is ready we will
perform the test on it to determine what
the result of the test will be we need
to add some more test elements we shall
again right click on first j meter go to
the listener options
then in the box we can check the
different type of reports that jmeter
provides us for now we shall select two
of these
let's choose view results in table
and the view results tree
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button here to run second you
can go to this run option and choose run
the test and the third way is you can
right click on first j meter and choose
to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be one there's just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing we shall go to j meter
and change the number of threads and the
loop count let's make the number of
threads to be around 10 and also the
loop count to be 10
and now run the test
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and the same happens in
the case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since the loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link
let's get started with what is
performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch as it verifies and validates the
overall product performance this testing
can be done in different forms depending
upon the resource availability and the
type and volume of the user base
the main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected before it gets launched
into the market so performance testing
is the process of testing a software
application under a specific workload
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application under a particular
workload
the main purpose of performance testing
is to identify and eliminate performance
bottlenecks in the software application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed
here it identifies whether the response
of the application is fast or not then
comes scalability where the maximum user
load is determined and the third one is
stability where the stability of the
application is checked under various
workloads
now we know what is performance testing
let us understand why if we need
performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality the
response time reliability resource and
scalability are also important factors
so the goal of performance testing is
not to find bugs but to eliminate
performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application concerning the
application speed stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals what needs to be
improved before the product goes into
the market if there is no performance
testing the software might suffer from
issues such as running slow while
several users use it simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and for usability
performance testing determines if the
software or application meets speed
scalability and stability requirements
under expected workloads applications
sent to market with poor performance
metrics due to non-consistent or poor
performance testing are likely to bring
a bad reputation and fail to meet the
expected sales goals
now we know the relevance and need for
performance testing let's look at the
types of performance testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely load testing stress
testing volume testing capacity testing
reliability testing and scalability
testing let's have a look at all the six
types of testing one after the other
so the first type is load testing load
testing is a type of performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and peak usage
an application's performance is checked
concerning its response to the user
request and its availability to respond
consistently with an accepted endurance
on different user loads
here the main consideration is the
maximum load the application can hold
before the application starts behaving
abruptly
then another consideration is regarding
how much data the database can handle
before the system crashes the second
type of performance testing is stress
testing
stress testing is a type in which
different ways to break the system are
found that is how much load a system can
sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually the test started with a load
for which the application has already
been tested then more load is added
slowly to stress the system
the point at which we start seeing
servers not responding to the request is
considered the breaking point
here the major considerations are the
maximum load to a system can sustain
before it breaks down then how is the
system broken down and how will the
system be able to recover once it has
crashed
we also see in how many ways a system
can break and which are the weak nodes
that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load moving
forward the next type is volume testing
volume testing is the type where the
performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or steady
test in the incremental test the volume
of the data is increased gradually
generally with the application usage the
database size grows and it is necessary
to test the application against a heavy
database if we consider an example let's
say there is a website of college having
small amounts of data to store initially
but after 5-10 years the data stored in
the database of the website is much more
and has become huge
now comes the fourth type of performance
testing the capacity testing
so capacity testing is a type of testing
where the application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects
here the main concerns are if the
application would be able to support the
future load
if the environment is capable of
standing the upcoming increased load and
what are the additional resources
required to make the environment capable
enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many uses or transactions of a given
web application is capable of supporting
and will perform well during this
testing resources such as processor
capacity
network bandwidth memory usage disk
capacity etc are considered and altered
to meet the goal
to consider an excellent example of
capacity testing we can see the case of
online banking moving forward the next
type of testing is the reliability
testing
reliability testing is a type in which
the application is verified if the
application would be normal again after
an abnormal state
it estimates the time that the system
would take to return to its normal state
to understand the concept let's say
there is an online trading site that
experiences some failure and because of
which the users are not able to buy or
sell shares at a certain point of the
day but after a couple of hours they
were able to operate their shares and
the application became normal this is
when it can be said that the application
is reliable and can recover from its
abnormal state
the last type of testing is scalability
testing
scalability testing is a type where the
application is determined if it would be
able to scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load
now when we have learned the types of
performance testing we must learn the
process of performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts that is
requirement gathering selection of tools
performance test plan performance test
development performance test modeling
execution of test test result analysis
report now let's have a look at all of
these processes one after the other the
first step in the process is requirement
gathering the requirements are
identified and gathered from the clients
by the performance team this includes
getting information on the application's
architecture technologies database used
intended users functionality application
usage test requirement hardware and
software requirements etc the second
step in the process is selection of
tools after the previous step poc or
proof of concept is done with the
available tools
the proof of concept is a sort of
demonstration of real-time activity but
in a limited sense
the list of available tools depends on
the tool's cost the protocol that the
application is using the technologies
used to build the application the number
of users we were simulating for the test
etc now the third step
the third step is the performance test
plan in reference to the above two steps
test planning and designing are
conducted the process of test planning
involves information on how the
performance test is going to take place
like the test environment workload
hardware etc moving forward the fourth
step is performance test development in
this step the use cases for the
identified functionalities are created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval
once the clients approve the use case
the script development begins these
scripts are validated against several
different users and parallel to script
creation the performance team sets up
the test environment the performance
team also takes care of metadata through
scripts if the client does not take up
that activity so the next step is
performance test modeling
performance load model is created for
the test execution
this step aims to validate whether the
given performance metrics are achieved
during the test or not then the sixth
step is execution of tests the scenario
is designed according to the load model
in controller or performance center
initially the tests are not executed
with maximum users that are in the load
model the test execution is done in
incremental order let's say there are
1000 users then the scenario will begin
testing from 100 then go to 250 then 350
and so on it will gradually increase and
go up to 1000 users
the next step is the seventh step in our
process
that is the test result analysis
the test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that we must have a
unique and meaningful name for every
test result which will help us
understand the test purpose in the test
summary certain things must be included
like the reason for failure how the
performance of the application changes
regarding the previous runs it is also a
good practice to make a result summary
after each test run so that the analysis
results are not compiled every single
time the results are referred
then the final and the last step in
performance testing process is the
report the test results should be
simplified so that conclusion is clearer
and should not create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis comparison of
results and details of how the results
were obtained the test report is
considered to be good if it's brief
descriptive and to the point
now that we know the performance testing
the next important topic to discuss is
the understanding of performance testing
metrics
the first is processor usage which
refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threads second metric is memory usage
memory use is the amount of physical
memory available to the processor on a
computer system the third metric is this
time which is the amount of time the
disk is busy in executing read or write
request the fourth metric is the
bandwidth that shows the bits per second
used by a network interface moving
forward the next metric is the private
bytes it is the number of bytes a
process has allocated that can be shared
amongst the other processes these are
used to measure memory leaks and usage
then comes the committed memory this is
the amount of virtual memory used
then the next metric we have is the
response time it is the time between
when the user enters a request to time
to the first character of the response
is received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives requests per second moving
forward the next metric is the hit
ratios the hit ratios are concerned with
the number of sql statements that are
handled by case to data instead of
expensive input output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights these are monitored to
determine what wait times can be cut
down to make the data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment garbage
collection thread counts heads per
second cpu interruption per second disk
q length etc now when we know almost
everything that is needed regarding
performance testing it is very important
to know the tools that make performance
testing possible here are the top 5
performance testing tools in the market
today the first tool we have is the load
runner or hp load runner as the name
suggests the load runner is great when
it comes to handling a large amount of
users for testing the second tool in our
list is webload web load is one of the
best testing tools for stress and load
testing the next tool in our list is
load ui load ui is a great testing tool
to map the scalability and speed of the
target product the fourth tool in our
list is new load it is one of the
fastest testing tools with a speed of
around 10 times the traditional testing
tools that are integrated seamlessly
into our existing software with a wide
array of tests the last tool in our list
is the apache j meter apache j meter is
one of the best and most used testing
tools in the market right now it is
highly capable of creating a large
number of virtual users working on web
server moving forward we shall talk
about jmeter and understand why jmeter
is preferred over all the other
performance testing tools in the market
so moving forward let's see what j meter
is
j meter or apache j meter is an open
source software that is 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance
j meter is originally designed for
testing web applications but has since
expanded to other test functions to
understand the concept of jmeter let us
assume that some day your team leads
tell you to perform performance testing
on some website like facebook or
google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to internet and
accessing the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for 10 000 users this is when a
need for software like jmeter arises so
what jmeter does is it actually
simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server group of servers network or
object now let's have a look at some
reasons why gmeter is used for load
testing we have divided these reasons
into six parts
the first one is it's free of cost
second one is performance testing of
applications next one platform
independent the fourth one is
customizable fifth is recording and
playback and finally sixth is the
community support let's see all of these
one after the other the first reason we
have is free of cost one of the main
deciding factors in any software is its
cost normally a software can range from
high as six to seven figures per license
here jmeter is free of cost very
intuitive and has all the possibilities
you need to automate your work then the
second reason is performance testing of
applications the application is used to
perform performance testing on different
types of applications like web
applications web services ldap database
and shell scripts jmeter can conduct
load and performance tests for many
different servers and server types web
http and https database via jdbc ldap
and jms the third reason is
platform independence
jmeter is written and developed using
java to run on any environment or
workstation that accepts java virtual
machine for example windows linux mac
etc the next reason we have is that the
jmeter is customizable since jmeter is
an open source application it enables
developers to customize
whenever needed jmeter has a
comprehensive and user-friendly
graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding and defining elements
as more intuitive also one screen shows
everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis
the samplers are highly customizable
when determining which request to be
sent to the host however samplers don't
enable full control of test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback
the application provides record and
playback options enabled with the drag
and drop feature making the application
faster and easier the next and the last
reason on our list is incredible
community support jmeter is an open
source tool with a brilliant community
that keeps adding features and supports
users who run into issues and problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
longtime users can improve their
abilities on jmeter also having an open
source tool ensures that it keeps
getting better and is always in line
with users needs and requirements
finally let's have a look into the demo
that shows the working of jmeter
so the first step is we shall go to the
apache jmeter folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the
jmeter.pat file
double click on this file
this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the test
plan elements are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
i have renamed this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add
then go to thread or users
and select thread group let's name this
as perform
here the thread group refers to the used
or created users or needed to run this
test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after
there is an error you can choose it the
way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the users hits third there
is a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to run in finite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test end
time let's make the number of threads to
b2 and let's make the loop count to be
100
the next step is to add an http request
for that right click on the thread group
go to add option and go to the sampler
option in the menu that appears select
the http request option here on the
screen there is a server name or ipbox
we have to give the server name or the
ip in that let's pick up a website and
place the link in the box we shall use
the simply learns website here go to
simply learns website and copy the url
from here then come back to the jmeter
window and paste it onto the server name
box keep in mind we don't need to give
the http or https since these are
protocols which will come in the other
box and
they will be automatically taken in the
http request case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash there since we
have to access the root page
and let's rename this http request as
simple now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that are used to
provide the outputs of a load test there
are different types of listeners present
in jmeter and many may be added using
plugins we will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the ad select listener option
and go to the view results entry option
then again right click on the listener
option and choose graph results
and for the third listener again right
click and select the view results in the
table option
now it's time to run the test
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button here to run second
is you can go to the run option and
choose the run the test and the third
way you can right click on the first
jmeter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this j meter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then we
can also see the time the test has been
executing since we had put the threads
to 2 and the loop count 200 so the test
will run for a while
we can check the view results in the
table we can see different performance
testing metrics on the screen you can
see the thread name label sample time
per second bytes sort bytes and the
latency
and in the tree option when we click on
the test we can see a lot of information
appearing on the screen these are again
several performance testing metrics and
in the graph results we can see the
graph coming up on the screen now which
represents the test taking place with
respect to the ip address thread and
loop counts so what jmeter exactly does
is creates a request and sends it to the
server once it receives the service
response it collects them and visualizes
those details in a chart or graph after
that it processes the service response
and finally it generates the test
results in several formats such as text
xml json so that the tester can analyze
the data let's get started with what is
load testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior when a large number of users
access the application together
here performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability and reliability
of the software application under a
particular workload the testing
determines a system's performance
according to real life conditions
to give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer so you want to test a
printer by transferring large number of
documents for printing or test a mail
server with thousands of concurrent
users or to test a word processor by
making a change in a large volume of
data this helps to know whether the
existing infrastructure is capable of
running the application or not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle the testing identifies the
limitations due to hardware like cpu
maximization network bottleneck memory
limitation etc and it also identifies
the issues in software configuration
such as web server application server
database server etc
it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an application
and checks the performance of the
application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components load testing is
conducted to determine the number of
concurrent users that an application can
support without performance
deterioration the response time of each
transaction of an application and the
network delay between the client request
and server response are also checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to data mining
user demands and satisfaction
several tools make load testing possible
such as apache j meter web load load ui
load runner neo load load ninja etc
here in this session
we shall be using j meter for load
testing
so j meter or apache geometer is open
source software that is 100 pure java
application the application is designed
to load or test functional behavior and
measure performance
performance testing means testing a web
application against heavy load multiple
and concurrent user traffic it was
originally designed for testing web
applications but has since expanded to
other test functions to simplify let us
assume that someday your team leads tell
you to perform performance testing for
some websites like yahoo.com or
google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind do you think it's
practically possible to arrange 100
people with 100 computers and access the
internet and accessing the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what jmeter does is it simulates it
will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server group
of servers network or object next let's
have a look at some reasons why jmeter
is used for load testing
we have divided these reasons into six
parts
it is free of cost performance testing
of applications
platform independent customizable
recording and playback and community
support
now let's see all of these one after the
other the first one free of cost one of
the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost normally a software
can range from high as six to seven
figures per license here j meter is free
of cost very intuitive and has all the
possibilities you need to automate your
work the next one is performance testing
of applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like web applications web
servers ldap database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
tests for many different server types
like web http and https database via
jdbc ldap and gms
the third important reason is it's
platform independent in nature jmeter is
written and developed using java
programming language to run on any
environment or workstation that accepts
a java virtual machine for example
windows linux mac etc
the next reason we have is jmeter is
highly customizable since jmeter is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize it whenever
needed jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler and
cleaner and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive
also one screen shows you everything you
need the script the scenario and the
analysis the samplers are highly
customizable when determining which
request is to be sent to a host however
samplers don't enable full control of
test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback the application
provides record and playback options
enabled with the drag and drop features
making the application faster and easier
the next and the last reason in our list
is incredible community support jmeter
is an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter
also having an open source tool ensures
it keeps
getting better and always in line with
users needs and requirements now after
we know about jmeter and the reasons to
use shear meter let's understand the
process to perform load testing with a
hands-on demo the only thing that is
kept in mind before this demo is we must
have a fully functional j meter on our
system and by now we know that jmeter
can be used in any operating system like
linux windows mac os and ubuntu in this
demo we shall look into both the
graphical user and non-graphical user
interface mode of load testing
so the first step is we shall go to the
apache geometer folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the jmeter.pad file double
click on this file this might take a
while and then the jmeter window will
open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side the elements
of the test plan are added and on the
right side all the configurations of the
element that are added as we are on the
test plan element we can see the
configurations of the scene here the
test plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests the listeners and everything
will be stored here so the first step is
to add listeners for that go to test
plan right click on the test plan go to
add then go to threads users and select
a thread group
the test group refers to the users that
are used or created or needed to run
this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the users hits then the
third one there is a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
also choose the test to run in finite
times there is also a scheduler here to
help you schedule the start time and the
test and time for now let's leave
everything to be only one
the next step is to add the http request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option and go to the
sampler option
and go to the http request option here
on the screen there is a server name or
ipbox we have to give the server name or
the ip in that let's pick a website and
place the link in that box we shall use
the simply learns website here go to
simply learn's website and copy the url
from there
now we have copied the simply learns url
now let's come back to the jmeter window
and paste it in the server name box keep
in mind that we don't need to give up
the http or https since these are
protocols which will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case
so this is what i was talking about
now let's rename this name as simply
moving forward let's create one more
http request
for that again right click on the thread
group select samplers and select http
requests and go to simply learns website
again and there we have the resource
link go to that link and copy the url
then place that url in the server or ip
address box
we shall remove the http from that link
and add from the end cut the resource
part and paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the http request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more http
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the http request option again to
add one more link to the server and ip
address go to simply lens website go to
the corporate training link now copy the
url and go back to the jmeter window and
paste that url in the ip box
now cut the corporate training part from
the link and paste it to the other path
box
we shall again rename this http request
box as corporate now let's save this
file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
load testing dot jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners listeners are something that
is used to provide the outputs of the
load test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins the listener
we will use here is the tree as it is
comparatively easy to interpret for that
right click on the thread group then go
to add select listener option and we go
for the view results in three option
now it's time to run the test and check
the load for running the test there are
three simple ways first you can simply
click on the green button here to run
second is you can go to the run option
and choose the run test and the third is
the way you can right click on first
geometer and then choose run let's
simply choose the green button and run
the test after we run the test we shall
go to the check the results of the test
in the view results entry section we can
see the green symbol that states the
test has successfully completed since we
had left all the values to be one in the
beginning that's why there is just one
test for each http request now let's
increase the load and let's change some
numbers let's make the number of threads
to be 10 ramp up the periods to be 2 and
the loop count to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed since we
have increased the number of users and
ramp up the periods and the loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count now was
10 for each user the test will run 10
times
so here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed on the status of each hit onto
the website this is how you perform load
testing in graphical user mode now
perform the same test in non-graphical
user mode we shall remove the listener
so let's remove the view results in tree
after this we will go to the command
prompt then in the command prompt we
shall put the bin folder path in the
apache geometer folder let's go to the
bin folder and copy the location from
here now paste the path in the command
prompt and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for jmeter load
testing this command has got three parts
the first part is the hyphen n hyphen t
and hyphen l here the hyphen n
represents the non graphical user
interface mode hyphen t is used to
specify the location of the
test script hyphen l is used to specify
the location of our output result now go
to the location where our jmx file is
stored let's search for the load
testing.jmx file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link that we paste towards the
end make sure that you add the name of
the file with dot gmx
now go back to the folder and make a dot
csv file make an excel spreadsheet and
rename it with dot csv extension
now copy this path and go back to the
command prompt and paste it after the
hyphen l in the path don't forget to add
the name of the csv file towards the end
then execute the command and wait for
the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see that the tree is
successfully created and towards the end
of that execution you can see that the
message is the end of the run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the loadtesting.csv file in that
file you can see the entire test result
has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the load
testing is successful in the
non-graphical mode without any errors
this is what we had in this demo we saw
the load testing in graphical user
interface and non-graphical user
interface mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include several
graphs that explain the working of the
website link we use in the http request
the dashboard generator is a modular
extension of jmeter
its default behavior is to read and
process samples from a csv file to
generate html files it generates the
report and at the end of the load test
are on demand the dashboard reports
provide metrics like the apdex or
application performance index the
dashboard also provides a statistics
table response time over time response
times percentiles over time active
threads over time and response times and
percentiles we shall learn about
dashboards and more in the forthcoming
videos in this video we learned how
critical is load testing in the software
testing process and how it ensures high
user satisfaction
a successful load testing will help to
release high quality software if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
let's get started with what an api is
we often come across this term while
reading any technical blog or magazine
an api or application programming
interface is a programming code that
enables data transmission between one
software product and another it is an
intermediary software allowing two
applications to communicate with each
other to understand api even better
let's take an example
for example you're booking a flight
for that you will begin with searching
flights online concerning your
destination departure return dates and
many more filters
to make all these choices you interact
with the airline's website and access
their database and see if there are any
seats available on those states and what
the cost might be
while you're doing all this from the
time to begin to the time you finish
booking your tickets you're doing that
with the help of an api
to simplify it even more it can be said
that whenever we use an application on
our mobile phone the application
connects to the internet and sends data
to the server the server then retrieves
the data interprets it performs
necessary actions and sends it back to
our phone
the application then interprets the data
and presents the information we wanted
in a readable way
this is what an api is so that means
each time we use an application like
facebook send an instant image
check weather on our phone or make some
specific choices while online shopping
we use an api now when we have a good
idea about what an api is let's look at
another major thing before going on to
the hands-on demo that is why we use j
meter for api testing
apache g meter is an open source
software and it is used to simulate
loads of various scenarios and output
performance data in several ways
including csv and xml files and graphs
we know that the apache geometer is 100
pure java application
so it is available on every os that
supports java 6 or later
some of these specific reasons what
makes jmeter a perfect fit for api
testing are
jmeter enables fast api testing it
performs quick scope tests and enables
load and stress testing
then as we know it is an open source
tool and supports load testing and
stress testing
it has a lot of plugins and extensions j
meter can be used across several
platforms and can use various
programming languages
now we know about api basics and why we
use jmeter for its testing
it is the right time to see the process
of api testing in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
apache jmeter website and download the
file to know the entire downloading
process and installing jmeter you can
check our jmeter download and
installation video in our jmeter
playlist
moving on
i have my jmeter installed i will go to
the apache jmeter folder go into the bin
folder and open the batch file
this might take a while and then the
geometer window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections
on the left side all the elements of the
test plan are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward right click on the
first j meter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error or you can choose it the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user hits
third there is a loop count where you
can choose how many times the test will
run for the number of users
you can also choose the test to run in
finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the time for starting the
test and the time for ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser and search for some sample rest
api for testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is
raq res.n
or request response dot n
we will create and run get
post
put and delete rest api request in
jmeter in the demo
here in this link we have all get
post put delete apis
so we shall choose the first link here
list users
here we have the link request
open this link in the new tab
then we have got the url for this api
copy this url and go to the j meter
window
then in the geometer window right click
thread group and go to add
in the box that appears select samplers
you can see all types of requests that
jmeter can work on we shall choose the
http request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
here in the server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip
so here we shall paste the get api
request url
in the protocol box we shall put the
https
if in the url the protocol would have
been http then we would have left this
box empty
in the url we shall put the url link
remember that we do not put any slashes
here and that anything after the url
would be put in the path so we shall
remove the path from the url and put it
in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get api we will have to
give parameters we will add the name in
the parameters and give the name as page
and value s2
in this http request drop down we can
see all the different types of http
requests that jmeter accepts for now we
shall leave it to be get since we are
using the get api and also let's name
this http request as get api
now when our http request is ready we
shall perform the test on it
to determine what the results of the
test will be we need to add some more
test elements we shall again right click
on the thread group go to the listener
options then in the box we can check the
different types of reports that jmeter
provides us
for now we shall select two of these
let's choose view results tree and the
view results in the table
now save the test
i will save the test with the name api
testing
and finally let's run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways
first you can simply click the green
button on the run
second you can go to this run option and
choose to run the test
and the third way is you can right click
on the first j meter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test let's go to
the view results stream
here we can see the green status that
shows the test was successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again the status is green since we
had put the number of threads and loop
to be one there is just one entry in
both the results now let's try one more
thing
we shall go to the thread group and
change the number of threads to be 10
and run the test again
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and same happens in the
case of view results in table
now in the view results tree we can
click on a request and see different
information here we can see the sample
start load time latency error etc
same in the view results in table
you can see all such information in a
tabular format
you can also see the response data here
this is the same data as it was there
when we copied the url from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the request that was placed
now we are done with the get api request
let's add the second request that is the
post request
again add a http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group then come
back to the browser window and click on
the post api option
then
open the request url in the new window
then go to this window copy the url and
come back to the jmeter window
first let's rename this http request as
post api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox again let's put http in
the protocol box
address in the server or ip address box
and path in the path box
and in this http request drop down
select the post option this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option
and we shall have to add body now
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
here you can check some advanced
settings also in case you need them
for now
since this is just a demo we shall keep
it really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again let's
see what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running a required number of times
that is 20 times again i can see
information about different requests
that include different parameters like
latency errors etc
now let's move on to our third api
request that is the put request
go back to the browser and click on put
request
open the request in the new tab
copy the url and come back to the jmeter
window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
put api
then let's paste the url in the server
name
or ipbox
again let's put http in the protocol box
address the server or ip address box and
path in the path box
and in the http request dropdown select
the put option this time
here also we shall have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output make the
thread count to be one and then we shall
save the test and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is one here by
clicking on the api request we can check
a lot of data like the response body and
response headers and same in the case of
view results in the table you can see
the data in a tabular format let's make
the thread count to be 10 and again see
what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running a required number of times
and here i can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last api request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
url and come back to the jmeter window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
delete api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox again let's put http in
the protocol box address in the server
or ip address box and path in the path
box
and in this http request drop down
select the delete option this time
here there is nothing to be added in the
parameters section so let's go to the
two listeners and clear what all is
there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time we can see the
test running n number of times
we can see the information of any api
request by just clicking on it
let's get started with what is script
recording record testing in j meter
helps testers to record and run their
activity against test targets it is a
type of automated testing but for
multiple users the test script is
designed to record such scenarios
the proxy server allows jmeter to watch
and record user activity while browsing
web applications with a normal web
browser when we talk about proxy it is a
component that is present between you
and the remote server let us say that
you want to record web browser
interactions when jmeter starts acting
like a proxy this is when jmeter script
recording is used script recording is
one of the advanced and impressive ways
to figure out and eliminate the
complexity of browser interactions and
software testing now when we know what
script recording is and how it is
relevant let's look into how to do it in
jmeter but before that let's check the
prerequisites of script recording and
jmeter there are three major
prerequisites first is having j meter
installed in your system the second
requirement is having java installed in
your system the third and final
requirement is having mozilla firefox in
your system now let us have a look at
the hands-on demo of how to perform
script recording in jmeter so the first
step is we shall go to the apache jmeter
folder in that folder we will go into
bin folder and then select the
jmeter.bat folder let us double click on
that this might take a while and then
the jmeter window will open on the
screen the home window is divided into
two sections on the left side all the
test plan elements are added and on the
right side all the configurations of the
elements are added as we are on the test
plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here you can
think of the test plan like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored all the requests all the
listeners and everything will be stored
here now the first step is to add thread
group so for that right click on the
thread group select add and from add go
to threads or users and in that select
thread group here the thread group
refers to the users it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period and second
option that states the time gap between
the user hits third there is a loop
count where you can choose how many
number of times the test will run for a
number of users you can also choose the
test to run for infinite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the tests
end time the next step is to add an http
request for that right click on the
thread group go to the add option and
now go to the sampler option select the
http request option here there is a
server name or ipbox we have to give the
server name or ip in that let us pick a
website and place the link in the box we
shall use the simply learns website here
go to simplylands website and copy the
url from here then come back to the
jmeter window and paste it in the server
name box keep in mind that we don't need
to give http or https since these are
protocols that will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case then in the
path dialog box we will leave a forward
slash there since we have to access the
root page now the next step is to add
the http test script recorder for that
right click on the test plan then go to
non-test elements and select the http
test script recorder option the window
on the screen shows several options here
we can see the start option to begin the
test then there is a box that has the
port number you can make this number
whatever you like i'll put this number
as one two three four for now then let's
go back to the simply learns website and
go to the resources page then come back
to the jmeters window and rename the
recording controller as resources now
let us add another recording controller
so that jmeter works like a proxy with
the help of https test script recorder
then again go back to the resources page
that we just opened and scroll down a
little bit here we can see several
technologies and several other links in
those links you can select any one of
the links i will select digital
marketing here then go back to the
jmeter window and rename the recording
controller as digital marketing then
finally let's add a recording controller
for the home page and rename it as
simply learns home page so now we can
see that we have a thread group here
then there is a http request where we
have simply learn website in the server
name then there are three recording
controllers one for the resources the
second for digital marketing and a third
one for home page and last we have a
http test script recorder here i will
rearrange the recording controllers in
sequence putting the simply learns home
page controller on the top and then
placing the resources finally digital
marketing recording controller now let
us open mozilla firefox in our system go
to the general option here and scroll
down to the network settings in the
network settings option select settings
in the window that appears select the
manual proxy configuration here we shall
put the port number for now i will put
the port number as 1234 in this box
here in the http proxy we have localhost
and we have selected to use this proxy
for ftp and https and then click on ok
now go back to the apache jmeter folder
and now we shall use this apache jmeter
temporary root ca file which is a
security certificate file so coming back
to the mozilla firefox window go to the
options tab and in this tab i will type
certificates and here we shall select
view certificates in the window that
opens let us import the security
certificate from jmeter folder here we
shall select these two boxes so that the
proxy server can access the website that
we shall enter here in the browser and
then select ok coming back to the jmeter
window let us add some listeners to get
the results listeners are something that
are used to provide the outputs of a
test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins for adding
listeners right click on http test
script recorder for adding listeners
right click on the http test script
recorder then go to add option and then
go to listeners option and then add view
results tree now let us add one more
listener in the same way we shall add
view results entry now in the http test
script recorder in the target controller
option save the target controller here
in the drop down select the simply learn
home page option as we will begin the
script recording for the home page
finally let's start the test by clicking
here click on ok now go back to the
mozilla browser and here let us open the
simply learns home page now come back to
the jmeter window go to the home page
recording controller you can see the
homepage controller has started as you
can see the home page controller has
started recording the scripts that are
being performed these are the tasks that
are performed on the client side to the
server side now we can check both the
listeners that we have put to see what
all functions are working fine and what
all are not all the tasks from the time
that we have entered to simplylearn.com
in our browser are recorded in this
homepage controller to take the test
further go to the test script recorder
and stop the test now here in the target
controller select the second controller
that is the resources controller now
start the test again select ok go to
simply learns website select resources
after opening the resources link go back
to the jmeter window and now in the
resources controller you can see what
all events are recorded from the client
side to the server side once we click on
the resources link now again in the two
listeners you can check all the scripts
and tests are successful or have failed
now for our last recording controller go
back to the test script recorder and
stop the test now here in the target
controller select the third option that
is the digital marketing now here in the
target controller select the third
option that is digital marketing start
the test and select ok now get back to
the mozilla firefox window go to
resources go to digital marketing after
digital marketing link has opened go
back to the jmeter window and now in the
digital marketing controller you can see
what all events are recorded from the
client side to the server side once we
click on that link i guess this is
taking a while you can see all steps
coming under the recording controller
and then you can also see the two
listeners some of the tests are being
successful and some are not we can sum
this entire process as a way of
communicating between the server and the
client with a proxy server help in this
case the proxy server is rj meter that
is why it was able to record all the
steps that are happening while we were
performing any task this is how we can
perform the jmeter script testing in few
simple steps now when you are done with
the proxy server do not forget to go
back to your browser and change your
network settings back to normal that is
go to the settings select use system
proxy settings and that's how it is done
and so with that we come to the end of
this complete tutorial
if you found this video on devops
training helpful let us know in the
comments section below
also if you have any doubts or queries
feel free to leave a comment in the
comment section
thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you